TWENTY SEVENTH MEETING OF
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AT ONE THIRTY HI WE
HAVE A LOT OF HOUSEKEEPING AND
OTHER THINGS WE NEED TO DO SO
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO START OF
TIME SINCE WE HAVE SEVERAL
BILLS. THAT WE NEED TO GET
THROUGH TODAY AND SO I WILL.
AND THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM- I
WILL BEGIN WITH THE- WITH THE
WELCOME. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY HEARING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME ORDER
WE'RE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH. AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING A MASS B. WARRANT IN
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY IN THIS
ROOM FROM FORTY TWO OH TWO WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF IN THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIXTY DISPLACING. THERE ARE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AM
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN A
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND. I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN. TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING
USE OF OUR ONE WE USUALLY USE
OF ONE OF OUR WITNESS. VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
THE CORRESPONDING ROOM FOR OUR
HEARING IS ROME ONE TWO SEVEN
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASKED
HIM QUESTIONS. FOR DIAL IN
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THE WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PERSON PLEASE BUT
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON. IS BEGINNING.
THEIR BIG A BILL PRESENTATIONS
VERY IMPORTANT NOT TO CALL IN.
ON A DIFFERENT BILL MAKES YOU
CALL IN THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
CALLING IN ON. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU. SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
A BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE LIMIT ALL BACK FOR NOISE.
THIS INCLUSION YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE TO SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOUR
MAIN WITNESS. I PROVIDED
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL WILL REMAIN ON A ALIVE
LIGHT AND NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED TO SPEAK.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR. AGAIN
THAT'S. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE
NINE THREE SEVEN. FOUR FOUR AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CAN CAN YOU TO SERVE. OTHER
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
ALL FACE. WE STILL IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WE HAVE
FOUR MEMBERS HERE. MAYBE ONE
MORE. AND. ON THE OFF CALENDAR.
ITEM EIGHT. AB EIGHT TWO ONE
COOPER SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS PLACEMENT OUTSIDE
COUNTY ABOVE DOMICILE PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY COULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL. I THOUGHT
IT'D- YEAH. JONES SAWYER I.
COURT HERE SANTIAGO C. A. R. T.
HER WICKS. PLEASE. I THANK GOD
MOVING NOW TO PUT CAN COUNTY
CAN YOU. I DON'T. THE ITEM
NUMBER AB EIGHT EIGHT TWO
VICTIMS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
ONE THREE FOURTHS JOHN SAWYER
PALE CREAMY I DON'T KNOW BUT A
THIRTY THIRTY NO WHEN HATE
CRIMES TASK FORCE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE ONE THREE SMITH
COLLATERAL RECOVERY AND I
NUMBER TWENTY TWO A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO TANG. STATE
PRISON. HELLO ON THE CONSENT
CAL JONES. JOHN SO YOU'RE A
LACK I BLACK I BARRICK HAND
CORK BY CORK I SANTIAGO. THEY
ARE HIGH THEY ARE TO I LICKS.
LEE LI. AND YOUR PASSION. SO
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND- THE
CHAIR IS GOING TO ALLOW MISTER
TEEN. ABOUT AND MISS OUR LORENA
GONZ TO BRIDGE THEIR BILL- SO
IF ANY OTHER AUTHORS AFTER THAT.
IF YOU NEED TO M<c.cyan> ALL INCOME</c>
PLEASE BE THERE AND I WANTED
QUICKLY RE SOME- AND MAKE A
STATE- BUT BEFORE WE THE
BUSINESS OF THE CA. I WANT TO
TAKE A OF FOR THE LIVES DURING
THE EARLY. SHOOTING SPREE IN MY
DISTRICT. THE SHOOTING TOOK
PLACE JUST SIX MINUTES FROM MY
DISTRICT OFFICE. AND ONE MILE
FROM MY HOME AT THE STARBUCKS
WHO ARE ROUTINELY CONDUCT
MEETINGS. FAR TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE SAME POWER OF A SHOOTING SO
CLOSE TO YOUR HOME OR PLACE OF
WORK. THERE'S STILL MUCH WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
THIS MORNING BUT WHAT WE DO
KNOW IS THAT WE DESERVE BETTER
FROM OURSELVES AND EACH OTHER.
AND THEY DID TO THOSE AFFECTED
OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH YOU
TODAY. AND THIS TRAGIC EVENT
SERVICES TO UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT WEEK
CONDUCT IN THIS COMMITTEE WE
MUST CONTINUE TO THINK
THOUGHTFULLY ABOUT THE
POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING
LEGISLATION THAT IS BROUGHT
BEFORE US. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE BILLS TO RESTORE
CRITICAL FUNDING TO VIOLENCE.
PREVENTION AND TO CHAMPION
POLICIES THAT ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE SAFE WHERE
THEY WORK AND LIVE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ENDING DISCORDS OF
COMPILING TO PLACE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LET'S
HAVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR
THE VICTIMS OF THIS MOST RECENT
SHOOTING AND FOR ALL LIVES LOST
TO SENSELESS GUN VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU BOB WE WILL BEGIN
WITH MR MISTER CHANG BUT JUST
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW MISTER
TANG. TODAY IS GREAT PAGANS
LAST DAY AS CHIEF CONSULT
SULTON OF THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY HE'S BEEN DOING THIS
WORK I DON'T KNOW HOW HE DOES
IT- FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS SO-
HIS HAIR WAS BLACK BEFORE HE
STARTED AND- AND SO WE JUST
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU AND
ACTUALLY THANK YOU WE WILL HAVE
SOMETHING ON THE FLOOR I THINK
LATER IN A WEEK BUT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HERE
TODAY KNOW HOW WE- ARE WEAK I'M
SORRY HOW CALIFORNIANS. REALLY
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE FOR THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA AND THEN FOR US
HERE. THANK YOU. SPEAKING MAY
NOW BEGIN THANK YOU AND ALSO.
TO MR PAGAN FOR THE ALL THE
MAYES WORK OF THESE DE- I'M I'M
HERE TO PUT A BRIEF. AWAY A. B.
FOR ONLY. BUILT ON MY AB TEN.
SO IT OPENS THE DOOR. FOR
AUTOMATIC EXPUNGED SPEECH THE
YEAR SEVENTY THREE THEN THIS.
HI A BILL UPON THE LAW WHICH
WAS. WHICH WHICH OF THE
TARGETED OF HIS. TO HELP PEOPLE
WITH EXPENDABLE- IT'S- THAT.
IT'S FUNDAMENTAL PEOPLE GET HOW
HELPED GET EMPLOYED IT'S GOOD
FOR OUR COMMON. IT IS GOOD TO
HELL. THE EIGHT MILLION.
RESIDENTS WEBER CAN. THAT MAY
HAMPER THEIR ABILITY TO GET
WORK. OR BENEFIT DRIVEN CAUGHT
UP WITH A RESPECT US RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU AND YOU'RE WAITING
SAID LIVE. CALIFORNIA FOR TWO
AND JUST. OP MAY OPEN UP
THAT'LL- YEAH IS OPEN. SHARE
AND MEMBER OF THE SAN PUBLIC
SAFETY. MY NAME IS A LITTLE AND
I'M WITH CALIFORNIA THE STATE
AND JUST. I COME BEFORE YOU TO
SPEAK BEHALF OF MILLION OF TELL
LIVING WITHIN OUR- MISDEMEANOR
FORCE CAN. HAVING A CONVICTION
YOUR RECORD CAL EXPO YOU COUNT
THEIR YOURS NICK IMPACTED
QUALITY LIFE. MOST OF YOU HAVE
HEARD OF THE AND MOM BARRIER
TO. AND BUT I WONDERED STOPS A
MOMENT AND HAVE YOU THINK. HOW
THESE VARIOUS HOW ONE AND
CHILDREN. YOUR CHILDREN AND
IT'S A BUYERS. BUT CONSIDER
CLOUD DOWN. OVER ONE BY WAVE
COLLATERAL TIME MATCHING LOT SO
ONE WHO ARE THERE WITH THE CAN.
THERE ARE NO WORSE DESCRIBE THE
LOOK ON A CHILD'S. WHEN THEY
ASK THEIR PARENTS. NINETY TWO
CAN YOU ME OUT AND BY THE
SCHOOL WE'RE GOING INTO THE
SOME. OKAY SAYS NO I CAN'T
STAND I'M NOT WORK RIGHT NOW.
CHARLES CONTINUE SIX THAT'S YES.
USUALLY WHAT. YOU'LL OUR
CHILDREN WAS TRYING OUT FOR THE
BEST TEAM. YES CHAU WELL I MADE
THE CHOICE. WHAT YOU CAN AFFORD
BASKETBALL SHOES RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE FORCED TO WATCH THIS
SADNESS THE SWITCH ACOSTA CHILD
SPACE. GIVEN THEN IT'S UP TO
YOU ARE GOING TO ALL OF THE-
AND SELF. AFTER POINT GET SHOT.
HOW CAN YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN
MONEY. IF I WERE A BETTING MAN
HERE AGO ANY PETS THAT MISTAKE
LESS KEY. AND CAN CHANGE TO
HOLD IT AGAINST. ONE OF THE
PRIME INJURIES COULD BY.
THERE'S A LOT OF A PERSON SHE.
FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO DO SO.
TEST TO OFF I CREAM A HOT DAY
IS ACTUALLY REGIONALLY. SO
MEMBERS OF AND BLUE COMMUNITIES
ARE. BEAR OF TEN TO CONSIST OF
COMPLEX. I AM JUST WAITING TO
REPAIR YEARS OF HOMES.
NORMALITY IS WHICH CHANGE WHAT
HAS YESTERDAY WELL WE CAN DO
WHAT IS RIGHT FOR THE. DR KING
ONCE TO A MOST AT OAKLAND CA.
THAT IS ALL RIGHT. TO DO WHAT
IS. I URGE YOU TO GET. TO DO
WHAT IS RIGHT ON BOTH YES. ONE
EIGHTY THIRTEEN. THANK EACH DAY
YOU. AND NOW WE'RE LOOKING TO
RUN RT WITNESS AND TO IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OF TWO. US WILL. TO
THE TELLER. OTHER ANY WITNESSES
TO TALK ROOM. C. N. ON OUR YOU
NOW MAY OPEN UP THE LINE. FOR
AB- WAIT- K. THE BILL HAS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD- ON BEHALF OF
SPONSOR HERE'S A LINE
CALIFORNIA ALSO EXPRESSED
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF MARK JUST
THE CALIFORNIA IF YOU KNOW YOUR
CALIFORNIA ACTION CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
THEY ARE BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. YOUR SILICON VALLEY.
YOUNG WOMEN TREATMENT CENTER
INITIATE. TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
CA DEFENDER WE THE PEOPLE CAN
DIEGO. THE COMMUNITIES DANTE
AGO THANK THE COMMITTEE EIGHT
INEQUALITY ARTICLE AFTER
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
SAN DIEGO AND NORTHERN COUNTY
SAN DIEGO LOGO COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES REJECTED MORE
GOVERNMENT AND LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS KAREN
MCDANIEL REPRESENTING THE PLACE
BERKELEY AND JOIN A THOUSAND
CHILDREN WITH AN INCARCERATED
PARENT WE ARE. IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIRTEEN OH EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MADISONVILLE COP WHAT
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK IT'S- A GOOD PRIMARY
PHONE THAT I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOT SURE HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND GRABS A SMILEY THANKS FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU NOW
WILL BEGIN TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY
PROGRAM TO SPEAK TODAY. OUR SO
WE'LL GO TO THE ROOM. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
FORTY TWO OH TWO. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCING LINE. SO AT&T
YOU CAN NOW GO AND OPEN UP THE
TELEPHONE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT TEAM. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE ABOUT THREE IN Q.
ONE MOM FOR THE FIRST LINE.
RIGHT ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOTABLE PLEASE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT FOR
THE NEXT LINE. RIGHT THREE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY AGAINST AB ONE FIVE OH
NINE CORRECT NO. THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT OKAY GIVE ME PLEASE. AND
NEXT DOOR TO LINE THREE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
JONATHAN BYRD- WITH- ASKED ME
LOCAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION
OFFICERS- IN RESPECT TO AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE WE'RE NOT ON
I ALSO. OKAY NEXT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER LINES THANK YOU.
OKAY BRING YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS BUT TO SEE ARE THE-
THANK. MISTER KING YES THANK
YOU- THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- I UNDERSTAND
THE INTENT OF IT IS YOU KNOW
PEOPLE PAID THEIR PRICE AND-
YOU KNOW- THEY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES-
ISN'T THERE A PROCESS CURRENTLY
WHERE THEY CAN EXPUNGE THEIR
RECORDS. THERE IS A PROCESS
IT'S VERY CONVOLUTED VERY
COMPLICATED IN AGAIN TO PUT THE
BILL DOES IS IT STREAMLINES
THAT PROCESS FOR THEM- WE HAVE
A DATABASE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. AND BY ADDING
THEIR NAMES THE DATABASE THE
COUNTIES CAN THEN CALL INTO
THAT DATABASE TO KNOW WHETHER
THEY CAN RELEASED INFORMATION
ABOUT SOMETHING. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WANTED TO DO
THAT FOR THEMSELVES DIFFICULT
TIMES MULTIPLE COURT HEARING
SPEND MONEY TO VERY CONVOLUTED
IN A VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS AND
SOMETHING THAT THEIR ATTORNEY
WOULD. I THINK IS PART OF THE
PROCESS THERE YOUR ATTORNEY
HELPS THEM WHEN. THEY GET WOULD
HAVE TAKEN FOUR HUNDRED YES
RIGHT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW. OF
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND GOT THEM THERE-
IS THE DETECTIVE CONCURRENT TO
DOING THAT IS. THIS PROCESS.
THE PROCESS THAT THEY GO
THROUGH TO MAKE THAT RIGHT THAT
WRONG RIGHT AGAIN NOT NECESSARY
RIGHT. TO SHOW THAT THEY'VE
GONE PAST IT. AND IN AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND NINETY AND IF
THEY'RE PUTTING IN IT
THEMSELVES IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A RECORD
EXPUNGED. THEN THEY- GO OUT
AND- AND GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
SO THEY REMEMBER NEXT TIME
THAT. WHY THERE'S A HECK OF A
PROCESS TO GO THROUGH IF I WANT
THIS OFF MY RECORD. SO THERE'S
NOTHING INHERENTLY THAT
PREVENTS THEM FROM GETTING THAT
RECORD EXPUNGED AND I'M GOING
ON A HITTING JOBS AND DOING ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE HAD HEARD
FROM SOME OF THE WITNESSES ON.
AND THAT SO- YOU KNOW I'M I'M-
OPPOSING BILL BECAUSE I THINK
THAT- PEOPLE NEED TO. HAVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HAVE THAT
PROCESS IN PLACE SO THAT THEY
REMEMBER NOT TO DO THIS STUFF
OR AT LEAST. HAVE A DETERRENT.
FROM EVER PARTICIPATING IN THAT
KIND OF THING AGAIN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR QUIRK. YES SO FOR
THOSE OF US A LOT OF RESOURCES
YOU CAN PROBABLY GO THROUGH
THAT PROCESS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE. FOR THE
MOST PART MAKING IT- PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE THE TIME OR ENERGY
TO GO THROUGH THE CURRENT
PROCESS. WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
THEM A SECOND CHANCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTY I'LL JUST LET. MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD SAY THE FINAL
ORDER THINK HE SAID IT VERY
WELL SO WITHOUT RESPECT FOR US
FOR ABOUT IN THANK YOU AND I
PROBABLY MENTIONED A MILLION
TIMES IN THIS COMMITTEE HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS RIGHT NOW. TO
GET OUT AND AFFECTED THEIR
BARRIERS TO EVEN GETTING
THROUGH THAT'S PROBABLY MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND-
BUREAUCRATIC. IS NOT JUSTICE
AND SO- RESPECTFULLY WILL ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR ALL THE
MEMBERS. CALDERON PLEASED THE
BILL'S THE MOVED IN SECOND. AB
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT BY THREE
MEMBER TEAM THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER- JONES
SAWYER IRAQI. OUR CAN CORK WORK
AYE SANTIAGO. C. R. TWO NO C.
R. TO KNOW WICKS LI LI I. THE
MEASURES ARE CALLED ME TO MARK.
YOU MAY BEGIN RICHER YOUR LAST
BILL THANK YOU STEMMING FROM
THE NOVEL REPORT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE AB FIFTEEN FORTY
HONORS THE SIGNIFICANT TIME
THOUGHT AND EFFORT THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES PUT INTO
REFERRALS. AND PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE FOR JUDGES
REGARDING RESENTENCING AB
FIFTEEN FORTY WILL CLARIFY THE
PRACTICE OF SECOND LOOK
SENTENCING WHICH AUTHORIZES
COURTS TO REVIEW THE SENSES OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
WHEN RECOMMENDED BY CERTAIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES.
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
REFLECTS CONCERNS RELATED TO
OVERCOMING THE PRESUMPTION OF
RESENTING DUE TO UNREASONABLE
RISK AS WELL AS WE SENSE INTO A
LESSER RELATED OFFENSE OR
LESSER INCLUDED OFFENSE. IN THE
PROSECUTION MAY NOT BE IN
AGREEMENT I AM COMMITTED TO
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE
SB FIFTEEN FORTY WORKABLE FOR
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. VALERIE I'VE
TWO WITNESSES VALERIE BOLDEN
HAS BEEN PERSONALLY IMPACTED BY
CALIFORNIA RESENTS HIS LOSS AS
WELL AS OUR SO WE ARE HER TADO
WHO'S A MANAGING ATTORNEY OF
POST CONVICTION OF THE POST
CONVICTION UNIT OF THE. SAN
FRANCISCO. DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU. MISSPELLED
OR HER DAUGHTER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. I'M CAN YOU HEAR ME-
DEFINITELY WE CAN. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
VALERIE BOLDEN AND I'M FIFTY
NINE YEARS OLD I WAS
INCARCERATED FOR TWENTY FOUR
YEARS AFTER RECEIVING AFFECTED
FIFTY SIX YEARS TO LIFE FOR
SECOND DEGREE MURDER. THE SANTA
CLARA STATE LOOK BASED ON THE
RESPECT LAW WHICH MANDATED AN
EXPERIENCE CENTER BECAUSE THE
TIME I HAD ALREADY STARTED LONG
AGO. I GIVEN A LIFE SENTENCE
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE BACK TO
BACKS IT WHILE EXPERIENCED.
WHILE EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SORRY. WHILE IN PRISON
OPERATIVES A PAID NFL HELP
GROUPS AND CLASSES FOR YEARS
INCLUDING THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE GROUP BRIDGES TO LIFE
WHAT'S THE BEST ROUTE FOR ME IN
TERMS OF DEVELOPING SELF
AWARENESS. I GOT MY HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND MY FELLOWSHIP
DEGREE OF SOCIAL AND BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AND I WORKED ON ME
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DATE WE THANK
HIM WHAT AFRICOM. WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT MUCH TIME TO DO HARD TO
HAVE ANY HOPE. MOST OF THE TIME
I FELT LIKE I WAS THAT BIG
FIFTEEN. BASICALLY WALKING
AROUND LIKE A ROBOT GOING TO
STAND WITH PAIN PAIN EVERY DAY.
OPERATORS WELCOME THE BILL ONE
DAY AFTER ANOTHER AND MY
CHILDREN. IF I DIDN'T GET THE
CHANCE TO COME HOME TO BE SPENT
IN VAIN I WOULD HAVE EITHER
DIED IN PRISON OR MAYBE HAVE A
CHANCE TO WALK OUT OF MY
NINETY. AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PRISON STAFF
RECOMMENDED ME FOR RESPECT AND
PAINT THE TAPE ABSOLUTE
BEHAVIOR WHICH FOR ME INCLUDED
PROGRAMMING AND REMAINING
DISCIPLINARY. FREE FOR OVER A
DECADE SO. RIGHTS PROJECT
REACHED OUT TO ME BECAUSE THEY
WERE CHECKING PEOPLE
RECOMMENDED FOR RESENTENCING BY
CDC ARE. I HAVE BEEN REACHING
OUT TO THEM FOR YEARS ABOUT MY
THREE STARTS CASE AND THEY
WROTE TO ASK IF THEY COULD
REPRESENT ME. OF COURSE START
DATE YES AND AFTER AWHILE I HAD
A RESENTENCING HEARING IN COURT
IN LOS ANGELES. SUGGEST ME
CENTER MADE A FIFTEEN TO LIVE
AND ABOUT SIX MONTHS LATER I
HAD MY FIRST PAROLE HEARING AND
WAS GRANTED PAROLE. SINCE MY
RELEASED I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
GETTING CERTIFIED TO BECOME A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ADVOCATE AND
FACILITATOR. AND TRYING TO GET
MY SPEED TRYING TO GET TO KNOW
MY CHILDREN WHO ARE GROWN WOMEN
NOW. AS WHEN I LEFT THEM THEY
WERE. NINE TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD. I WOULD HAVE HAD THE
CHANCE GET RESERVE THEM IF I
DIDN'T REP. I KNOW PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALSO RECOMMENDED BACK CDC
ARE BUT WHEN THEIR CASES WENT
TO COURT. STAY WITH  NIGHT
WITHOUT EVER BEING CONSIDERED
JEFF DEFEATED MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T FAMILIAR
WITH THE RESENTENCING OR THEY
DIDN'T FIND IT TO BE OF ANY
IMPORTANT. PLEASE SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE HAVE A FAIR CHANCE
THAT WE SPENT THE SAME.
INCLUDING HAVING A RIGHT TO AN
ATTORNEY AND A HEARING. ON THAT
MANY PEOPLE SITTING
IMPRISONMENT I WORK HARD ON
THEMSELVES AND ARE BETTER
PEOPLE NOW THEY DESERVE A
CHANCE TO COME HOME TO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU CHAIRED JONES SAWYER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION AND THANK
YOU MISS BOLDEN'S FOR SHARING
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE- THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANGLE
FOR YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND- PROVIDING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I AM A SENATE WITHOUT THOUGH
AND THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
MENTIONED ONE OF MY
RESPONSIBILITIES IS MANAGING
THE POST CONVICTION UNIT OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MY UNIT HAS
WE SENTENCE FORTY FIVE PEOPLE
UNDER THE NEW RESENTENCING
PROVISIONS IN CALIFORNIA LAW
EACH PERSON WITH THREE SENTENCE
WITH THE STRONG RE ENTRY PLAN.
THANK YOU TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
SUPERIOR COURT DEFENSE COUNSEL
AND COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS
THAT HAVE MADE THIS POSSIBLE IT
SORRY AND THAT THERE WE
WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY WHILE A
SUCCESSFUL START THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
RESENTENCING LAW HAS REVEALED
SEVERAL PROCEDURAL CHALLENGES
THAT MUST BE REMEDIED. AS THE
MOST PRACTICED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN THE STATE
ON THIS MATTER WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED CHANGES IN THE LAW WE
ARE NOT ALONE IF YOU SEE A
BROAD COALITION OF REGISTERED
THE QUARTERS IN ADDITION AS
STATED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KING
THE PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW
COMES FROM RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
BY THE COMMITTEE. FOR THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE. A
FIFTEEN ONE RESULT IN MORE
CONSISTS. AND EQUITABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RECALL AND RE
SENTENCING LAWS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY WELL ONE EXPAND
THE LONG FOR SPENT AGENCIES
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO RECOMMEND
A PERSON FOR RESENTENCING. TO
INCLUDE THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL IF THEY PROSECUTED THE
CASE. TO STRENGTHEN PROCEDURAL
DUE PROCESS BY PROVIDING NOTICE
TO THE INCARCERATED PERSON.
RECOMMENDED FOR RESENTENCING
ESTABLISHING COURT DEADLINES
AND ENSURING A CLEAR RIGHT TO A
HEARING. THREE CLARIFY THAT A
JUDGE CAN REDUCE A CHARGE TO A
LESSER INCLUDED- LESTER RELATED
OFFENSE. THE CHOICE OF THE
APPROPRIATE TERM REMAINS WITH
THE COURT. FOR PROVIDE A
PRESUMPTION IN FAVOUR
RESENTENCING WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAKES A REFERRAL.
FIVE ENSURE THE RIGHT TO
COUNSEL AND SIX MAKE PENAL CODE
PENAL CODE SECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY D. ONE ITS OWN PENAL
CODE SECTION TO CLARIFY THE
LAW. THIS BILL IS PRACTICAL
TIMELY AND NECESSARY AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO SEEING NONE
YES. ANY WITNESSES. ON ITS
SUPPORT ON A TELECONFERENCING
AND NOW. WE'LL OPEN IT UP. TWO
AB FIFTEEN FORTY TEAM ANY
SUPPORTERS AT&T COULD YOU OPEN
UP A LOT THEIR LIVES. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HE SAID. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN IN Q.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING THREE SIX
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. NINE THREE SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. BY THE WAY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSES POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY THE PUBLIC SPORTS
SPOKE OF OUR- JEFF. I WANT TO
GET LIKE WHO ALL. YEAH ALL- DO
THEY ARE HELLO FIRST. NAME
ORGANIZATION. ALL OPERATE TRY
RIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THERE READY THIS
IS SERRA REGNI IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. AB FIFTEEN FORTY ON
BEHALF OF RESTORE JUSTICE
MOVEMENT REBOUND SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE SECURE
JUSTICE SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE SAN DIEGO SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AREA MIGHT
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA PROSECUTORS
ALIGNED TO CALIFORNIA SURVIVED
AND PUNISHED THE YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER TRANSFORMATIVE
INCRETIN WORKGROUP TRANSGENDER
GENDER VARIANT AND INTERSECTS
JUSTICE PROJECT UNCOMMON LINE.
W. HAYWARD BURN INSTITUTE WE
THE PEOPLE SAN DIEGO FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ROKER.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LAST ONE
YOU'RE DONE IMPACTED FAMILY
MEMBERS CALLING FROM THE CITY
OF RIVERSIDE- I IMPORT THE PART.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR OH SEVEN PLEASE GO HEAD. I
DID TIMELINE THREE ZERO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON THE HELP THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU BLIND THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME'S
CASSANDRA NELSON I'M CALLING
FROM TUSTIN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY. THANK YOU. BY TWO
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DIFFICULTY LANDS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS CALLING IN WITH A
CONSOLIDATED LIST OF SUPPORT
FOR A BI FIFTEEN FORTY FROM THE
IF YOU KNOW YOUR CALIFORNIA
ACTION AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET.
DIGNITY AND POWER NOW HELLO
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT INITIATE JUSTICE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW AND THE PRISONER
ADVOCACY NETWORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO A
LOT OF INJURIES GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS LEADER ADULT NINE
THE STRONG SUPPORTER AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY. NINE THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS SHERRY TO MINGLE WITH
SILICON VALLEY DE BUG IN SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL RIGHT YES PLEASE
GOING. YEAH MY NAME IS SMITH ON
JANUARY CALL NINE FOUR THE OLD.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW I CAN
TALK TO SOMEBODY BY MY CASE.
SOME FORTY YEARS AND THEY YOU.
WHAT WHAT BERMAN YOU WRITE
THREE NINE SIX PLEASE CALL. THE
FEDERAL YEAH WE NEED KIRK. AND
I AM IN THE I'LL- AT EIGHTY
COURT. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FOR THE LIGHTING YOU AT
THIS OKAY NOW IN OPPOSITION
LARRY MORSE ONLINE. YES SIR
GERMAN- THE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS LEARN MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN THE
SHUFFLE UP ROOM TO AB FIFTEEN
FORTY UNLESS AMENDED AS DRAFTED
THE BILL REPRESENTS A DE FACTO
MANDATE TO RE SENTENCE
REGARDLESS OF CIRCUMSTANCES OUR
ISSUE WITH THE BUILDERS OF THAT
FIRES THE COR TO SCHEDULE A
CONFERENCE WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
OR THE APPOINTMENT OF COUNSEL.
ACCESS TO AN ATTORNEY IS
FUNDAMENTAL ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
IS THAT IN VALUE EIGHTY QUEST
FOR RESENTENCING THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A VERY HIGH
STANDARD TO SORT OUT FOR
STANDARD FAVORING RECALL AND RE
SENTENCING OF THE DEFENDANT
WHICH MAY ONLY BE OVERCOME IF
THE COURT FINDS THAT THE
DEFENDANT POSES AN UNREASONABLE
RISK PUBLIC EIGHT FEET BECAUSE
THE COURT DETERMINES THE
DEFENDANT WOULD LIKELY COME AT
A SO CALLED SUPER STRIKE A VERY
LIMITED NUMBER OF VIOLENT
OFFENSES SET FORTH UNDER
SUBSECTION OF PENAL CODE
SECTION SIX SIX SEVEN.
REQUIRING JUDGES TO IN EFFECT
MAKE PREDICTIONS ABOUT FUTURE
CRIMINAL CONDUCT IN EVALUATING
SUITABILITY FOR RESENTENCING IS
FANCIFUL AT WORST AND
UNWORKABLE IT BASS MOREOVER
THIS PRODUCTION IS UNNECESSARY
UNDER CURRENT LAW AND THE
PROPOSED BILL JUDGES HAVE
DISCRETION TO CONSIDER JUDICIAL
COUNCIL RULES AND THE JUDGE
SENTENCES IN AN EFFORT TO
ACHIEVE UNIFORMITY IN
SENTENCING AND CONFORMITY WITH
CHANGES IN SENTENCING LAW. OUR
OTHER MAIN CONCERNS THAT THE
BILL ALLOWS THE COURT TO
LITERALLY CHANGE THE CHARGES
FOR WHICH A PERSON WAS TRIED
AND CONVICTED IN ORDER TO
REDUCE SENTENCES IT WOULD ALLOW
THE COURT TO VACATE A
CONVICTION AND IMPOSED JUDGMENT
ON DIFFERENT CRIMES SO CALLED
LESSER INCLUDED AND LESSER
RELATED OFFENSES SUCH A CHANGE
WOULD CONTRAVENE THE DA'S
CHARGING DECISION AND THE
JURY'S VERDICT AND IS VERY
LIKELY AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
INTRUSION INTO EXECUTIVE BRANCH
FUNCTIONS. FURTHERMORE THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
HELD THAT MUST WILL LAY OF. ARE
NOT. WITHOUT THAT CAN OF PART.
SIGNIFICANTLY AS WELL THERE'S
NO MENTION IN THE BILL OF THE
RIGHTS OF VICTIMS THE NOTICED
AND GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HEARD DURING CONSIDERATION OF A
RESENTENCING CONTEST. AND WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED REVISIONS
REQUIRED IN EXPEDITED PROCESS
WE'RE HEARING ALREADY
AUTHORIZED UNDER PENAL CODE
SECTION ELEVEN SEVENTY. OR THE
TIMELY APPOINTMENT OF COUNSEL.
BUT THIS BILL AS DRAFTED
ABROGATE DECISIONS OF
PROSECUTORS AND JURIES AND
CREATES A FAMILY FALL FLAWED
PROCESS FOR GRANTING RELIEF.
BASED ALMOST ENTIRELY ON
JUDICIAL PREDICTIONS PLEASE
REASONABLY ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL UNLESS AMENDED
SPECIFICALLY BY ONE.
ELIMINATING THE UNNECESSARY
PRODUCTION IN FAVOR
RESENTENCING TRUE INCLUDING A
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES ALL
PARTIES TO AGREE TO ANY CHANGE
IN CHARGES AND THREE INCLUDING
LANGUAGE GUARANTEEING VICTIMS
RIGHT TO BE HEARD. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING'S WILLINGNESS TO DISCUSS
OUR CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO REACHING A COMPROMISE THANKS.
SIR THANK YOU SIR. NOW
WITNESSES WITHIN TWO OH TO IN-OPPOSITION SEEING NONE TO THE-
TO THE TELE CONFERENCING SCREEN.
SEEING NONE- OPERATOR YOU CAN
NOW OPEN UP THE LINES FOR A BI
FIFTEEN FORTY TEAM FOR THOSE
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BORDERLINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KAREN LEGGETT PRIMARY AND WE
NEED TO STOP MAKING EXCUSES
CHAU ACCOUNTABILITY AND BE A
BETTER ROLE MODEL TO KIDS I
URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU. RIGHT
ONE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI MY NAME IS MEGAN MAY HAVE
BEEN JUST BROKE. UP AND MAKE
BIG THE GENERAL. AT THAT WE
NEED TO. RIGHT AND FOR ME IT'S
AN OPEN. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
ALIVE AND PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
RIGHT- I'M MY NAME IS THE NAME
VAN HAAR I'M WITH SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG ANYWHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND
THREE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
A TEMPORARY SAN DIEGANS AGAINST
CRIME PRESIDENT PROPOSED AB
FIFTEEN FORTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DR REMAIN HIM I'M THE
FOUNDER OF ASIAN AMERICAN GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA BUT WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
FIVE FOUR ZERO SINCE MANY OF-
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LEFT. DUE TO-
PRO CRIME POLICIES SET FORTH BY
SEVERAL DIFFICULT POLITICIAN.
YOU THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MISTER CORK. MR
LACKEY- I FIND VERY LITTLE
RESEMBLANCE BETWEEN YOUR BILL
AND THE WAY THE DA'S DESCRIBED
IT- I THINK THAT YOUR BILL DOES
ALLOW FLEXIBILITY FOR THE JUDGE
TO CONSIDER ALL SORTS OF
THINGS- AND RESENTENCING COULD
MEAN IT GOES FROM A LIFE
IMPRISONMENT TO THIRTY YEARS IN
THE GUY HAS DONE MORE TO SERVE.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND OR
PERHAPS YOU CAN TELL ME THAT
TO- THAT I'M CORRECT IN THAT
THE DA'S DESCRIPTION IS NOT
ACCURATE WHAT WE'LL GET OUT
YOUR POINT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP WORKING WITH- THE DA'S
ASSOCIATION I THINK THEY DO-
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO CONVERSE TO
GET THEIR FEEDBACK BAD AYE I
WOULD TEND TO AGREE WITH I
THINK YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
BILL. AND IT AGAIN THE BILL IS.
STEMMING FROM THE COMMISSION-
THE COMMITTEE TO REVISE THE
PENAL CODE WHICH AGAIN THIS IS
THEIR THIS IS THEIR
RECOMMENDATION IN THIS IS ALSO
A WAY TO. STREAMLINE THE TWO
THOUSAND RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
CAME OUT OF C. D. C. R. THEY
THEY THEY RECOMMEND THESE OTHER
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS OWN
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY. HAVE STALLED
WITHIN THE PROCESS. THANK YOU
COULD YOU MAYBE. THANK YOU
COULD YOU MAKE ME A CO OP
SALUTE THANK YOU. MR LACKEY.
YEAH I HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
APPARENTLY THIS RESENTENCING
ACCORDING TO YOUR BILL A COULD
BE GRANTED WITHOUT. CONSULTING
HAVING ANY KIND OF HEARING A
CONSULTING VICTIMS. AND THAT
WOULD BE IN VIOLATION OF THE
VICTIM WRITES AN ARTICLE ONE
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT. I'M GONNA
ASK MR TADA TO ADDRESS THAT.
QUESTION- FOR STATEMENT. SURE
I'M HAPPY TO THANK YOU- THAT IS
NOT CORRECT- WE ARE GOVERNED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
IT'S OUR DUTY TO ENFORCE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
VICTIMS HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
HEARD- AT ANY PROCEEDING
INVOLVING A CASE THAT THEY WERE
INVOLVED IN AND MY OFFICE AS
I'M SURE ALL OFFICES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ABIDE BY THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION. TO
NOTIFY ANY VICTIM OF ANY CRIME
WHEN THERE'S A HEARING OF THIS
TYPE THAT INVOLVES RESENTENCING.
THAT'S JUST A CONFLICT OF
INFORMATION I'VE BEEN PROVIDED
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS CURRENT YOU MAY
CLOSE AGAIN LET LET ME JUST
THINK THE CHAIR FOR HELPING ME
OUT AND ALLOW ME TO GO FIRST-
WE THINK THAT THIS- THIS IS
REALLY A SMART JUSTICE THE
PROPOSAL WE'RE REALLY JUST
TRYING TO CODIFY WHAT THE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED AFTER A
REAL NOT REALLY MONTHS OF
DELIBERATION AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE FOR
A BI FIFTY FOUR. K. DID. NEED A-
OR DID MISTER CORK MOTION.
SECOND MADAM CHAIR YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL CALL AND I DID JUDGE
RECOMMEND I VOTE UP MAINLY
BECAUSE I THINK YOU CAN WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IS
SATELLITE MISTER LARRY MORSE'S
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU
DIRECTLY AND IF THERE'S ANY
DISCREPANCIES ARE CONCERNS FOR
MR LACKEY HIS FATHER FAR AS THE
WORDING THAT I THINK IF YOU ALL
GET IN A ROOM AND LOOK AT THE
SAME WORD AT THE SAME TIME. THE
SAME PAGE THE SAME PARAGRAPH
AND WORDING- YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
STRAIGHTEN IT OUT. THANK YOU.
THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB FIFTEEN FORTY BY
SOME MEMBER CHECKING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY. LACKEY NOW BARRICADE
HAN. CORK CORK I SANTIAGO. THEY
ARE TO NOW THE OUR TURN NOW
WICKS. LEE. YEP THERE ARE
CURRENTLY THREE MORE. MISS
LOREENA GONZALEZ. FLETCHER. MY
HUSBAND THANK YOU FOR USING MY.
BETTER UP TO HIM- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THAT
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES. AB
FIVE A SIX WOULD REQUIRE YOU
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT SPECIFIED CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MEASURES REQUIRE
VOLUNTEERS OF YOUTH SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO BE MANDATED
REPORTERS. IN RECENT YEARS
INCREASE STATUE LIMITATIONS AND
MEDIA ATTENTION HAVE HEIGHTENED
OUR AWARENESS OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ABUSE. THANK YOU I WON'T
GET INTO THE DETAILS OF EXACTLY
WHAT THE BILL DOES BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE WITNESSES AND I DON'T
WANNA BE REDUNDANT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I THINK WE HAVE-
KANTOR'S ALERT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ON THE
LINE. DO WE ALSO HAVE. LOCKS
GRANT. CHILD ABUSE YES WE ARE
ALSO IN A LONG LINE. IT OPERATE
COULD OPEN UP THE WITNESS
LICENSE. THANK YOU BOTH PLANES
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KENDRA
DOLLARS HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA'S
VERY PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY FIVE OR SIX AND WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
MEASURE. WE APPRECIATE NINE
EIGHTY FIVE A SIX THIS YEAR
BECAUSE THE POEM PLAN I CALLED
MADE YOU FEEL MORE ISOLATED
THAN EVER MAKING THEM
SUSCEPTIBLE TO CHILD ABUSE.
RECENT LITIGATION HAS ALSO SHED
LIGHT ON NOT ONLY THE IF YOU
TEACH YOU SUCH AS OCCURRED IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION BUT THE
FAILURE OF NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
TO IMPLEMENT A FINE CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MEASURES SUCH AS
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND MANDATED
REPORTER TRAINING. CONSEQUENTLY
LIABILITY INSURANCE COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN DROPPING THE BAD
ACTOR YOU ORGANIZATIONS FROM
COVERAGE ALLEGING THAT THESE
PARTICULAR YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS
FAILED TO INFORM THEIR ENSURES
THAT SUCH WIDESPREAD USE THAT
IN SOME CASES THE COST BY THE
YOUTH ORGANIZATION- LACK OF
OVERSIGHT. SUN NEWS ORGAN. HAVE
OR ADOPTED INTERNAL BEST
PRACTICES WHICH ARE PROVEN TO
HELP PREVENT THE OF CHILDREN.
BY HELPING TO. AT THE STATE
PRACTICES ALSO LA PHILIP RESCUE
YOU CHECK THAT THE ORGANIZED.
WHICH CAN PROVIDE MORE
ASSURANCE OF SOVEREIGNTY TO THE
INSURER. HOWEVER IF YOU
COTINUE TO JOIN YOU
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH ARE SLOWLY
RETURNING AND PERSON FUNCTION.
THERE'S STILL A LACK OF UNIFORM
STANDARDS FOR THE PREVENTION OF
THE USE AND ORGANIZATIONS.
EIGHTY FIVE SX WOULD GUARANTEE
YOU ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
PROACTIVE MEASURES IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT INCIDENTS OF ABUSE
ARE CAUGHT EARLY ON. IN
ADDITION THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY BY
ALLOWING LIABILITY INSURANCE
COMPANY J. YOU IDEAS
ORGANIZATION COMPLIANCE. WITH
THE STANDARDS PRIOR TO ISSUING
ANY INSURANCE POLICY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE. MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WEEK HELLO. IT
THERE WITH THE PUBLIC EIGHT
EIGHT. MY NAME IS WALKING AND I
AM A VICTIM OF INSTITUTIONAL IS
AT AND THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
CHILDREN TALKING. AND JOINING
YOU TODAY AS THE EFFECTIVE
DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT
COALITION FOR INSTITUTIONAL
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION. I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT AB FIVE OH
THANK WITH REQUIRE YOUTH
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT SACRIFICE HOW THE NEW
PREVENTIVE MEASURES. AND WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE SPECIFIED
VOLUNTEERS AND YOUTH
ORGANIZATION TO BE MANDATED
REPORTERS THERE ARE MANY WIDELY
STUDIED BLACK REPORTS THAT SHOW
HOW TRAINING FOR REFUSING
GROOMING AWARENESS COMBINED
WITH THE LEGAL IMPLICATIONS OF
FAILURE TO MANDATE REPORT.
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
POSITIVE IMPACT ON PREVENTION
AND INTERVENTION. BUT I AM NOT
THAT SEXUAL ABUSE VICTIM AND
CHILD ABUSE ACT BURKE I AM ALSO
A MOM. BEING A SURVIVOR AND A
MOM BUT WE. GET GREAT. THANK AS
I IT AND I THINK RIGHT FIND
STATE. BUT I ENROLL MY DAUGHTER-
IN. IT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT
ONLY HELP IF YOU'RE PREVENTIVE.
BUT CAN EIGHT BIT BUT I'M-
EVERY. THANK YOU ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER ON A.
B. FIVE OH SIX LORENA GONZALEZ
IN SUPPORT. AND NOW WE'LL GO TO
THE TELECONFERENCING ROOM ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND NOW
WE GO TO TELEPHONE LINES ARE AB
FIVE OH SIX LOW REYNA GONZALEZ.
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH. EIGHTY FIVE THE
BAND YOU NEED TO BE. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- I HAVE NONE. IN
OPPOSITION ON MY SHEET- TO SEE
IF ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH TWO
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE OH SIX LORETTA GONZALES
SEEN NONE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCING SCREEN. AGAIN
SEEN NONE- NOW OPERATOR GO TO
OPEN THE LINE FOR AB FIVE OH
SIX LORENA GONZALEZ BILL. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE ONE MINE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
COMMENT.
FOUR FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MELISSA COLLAPSE ON THE
CALL SIR FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU BRING IT
NOW BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR
BARKEVIOUS. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT A LOT OF YOU KNOW AS
PARENTS WE BOTH KNOW THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO COACH OUR KIDS IN
OUR IN OUR KIDS LIVES ARE
VOLUNTEERS- AND THEY DO NOT A
GOOD AS THEIR HEART BUT HAVING
THOSE PEOPLE INCLUDED IS
ACTUALLY REALLY IMPORTANT I
KNOW THERE WAS SOME QUESTION
ABOUT THE OVER BREADTH OF THIS
OBVIOUSLY THOSE PEOPLE IT MAKES
SENSE YOU KNOW. BUT AB IS THERE
A WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REALLY FOCUSING ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SERVING IN
FUNCTIONS THAT ACTUALLY
TRADITIONALLY ARE ARE MANDATED
REPORTERS RATHER THAN THE
PERSON WORKS AT THE SNACK SHACK
AT THE- SOCCER GAME HE WELL-
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THE EXAMPLE YOU
USED BECAUSE THAT MIGHT NOT FOR
I MEAN THAT STILL MAY BE A
MANDATORY REPORTER IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES- SO I DON'T WANT
TO SUGGEST THAT I'M SPEAKING TO
THAT EXACT EXAMPLE WE DO NEED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
PTA IN PARTICULAR- ABOUT- IT'S
NOT WE FOCUSED ON THE HOURS
THAT A VOLUNTEER SERVES IN
ORDER TO NOT BE OVERBROAD. BUT
THERE ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE TRADITIONALLY USED SERVING
THAT DON'T ACTUALLY- COME INTO
PLAY WITH THE U. S. WHICH IS
KIND OF BIZARRE SO WE WILL
TIGHTEN UP THAT AND ENSURE THAT
WE- NARROW THE SCOPE IN THAT
SENSE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ENSURE THOUGH IS THERE ARE
SITUATIONS IN IN THE SNAPSHOT
MAY BE AN EXAMPLE WHERE YOU
DON'T REALLY THINK OF THEM AS
YOU SERVING OF BUT PERHAPS
THERE'S KIDS WHO ARE HELPING IN
THE SNAPSHOT AND SO- IT I'M
THINKING MY KIDS BASEBALL GAME
RIGHT THE PARENT DOESN'T DO THE
TIME. AND THIS TAX. ANYONE HAS
AND LITTLE LEAGUE UNDERSTAND
THE TIME THAT YOU HAVE TO
SERVE. THEM BUT MAYBE THE KID
DOES AN OLDER KID AND WHAT WE
WANT TO PREVENT IS WHEN THEY
HAVE THAT ONE ON ONE CONTACT
WITH OUT OTHER SUPERVISION IF
IT'S FOR PROLONGED. AMOUNTS OF
TIMES THAT THEY ARE NUMBER ONE
TRAINED AS MANDATORY REPORTERS
AND BACKGROUND CHECKED I MEAN
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS SOUTH.
YES WE ARE GOING TO ENSURE-
THAT IT'S NARROW ENOUGH THAT
WE'RE NOT INCLUDING. SOMEBODY
WHO SHOWS UP TO THE PTA BAKE
SALE- IN IS NOT INTERACTING
WITH THE CHILD ON THEIR OWN BUT
NOT QUITE YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TO
BE CAREFUL IN HOW WE DO IT. FOR
PATIENTS AND I REPORTS WARNING
ABOUT THINKING. THANK YOU. YES
MRS HERE TO. SO THIS IS A BILL
OF THE WE REALLY WANT TO
SUPPORT REALLY BAD BECAUSE IT
INVOLVES CHILD ABUSE AND ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE FOR YOU IS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS WHAT WOULD BE
THE MINIMUM AGE CONSIDERED TO
BE A VOLUNTEER THAT WOULD FALL
UNDER THIS IS EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN. YEAH BECAUSE I THINK
OF PLACES LIKE THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB AND I THINK OF YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE OTHER CLANS
WHERE THEY DO. HAVE A LOT OF-
YOUNG VOLUNTEERS THEY'RE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE OR- IN
THAT RANGE. AND HOW ILL
EQUIPPED THEY ARE. TO RECOGNIZE
AND UNDERSTAND WHEN SOMETHING
IS WRONG SO THEY GET THIS
TRAINING WHICH CONSISTS OF HOW
MANY HOURS. I BELIEVE IT'S FOR
THE WITH THE RECOMMENDED
TRAINING I BELIEVE IS TWO HOURS
OKAY. SERVICE SOME PEOPLE. GET
MASTERS AND DOCTORATES IN
THINGS LIKE THIS AND THEY STILL
HAVE A HARD TIME FIGURING OUT
WHAT IS AND WHAT ISN'T. ONE OF
MY CONCERNS IS THE LIABILITY
PLACED ON A VOLUNTEER PERSON ON
MAKING MONEY DOING WHAT THEY'RE
DOING. TO EXPOSE THEMSELVES TO
WHAT CAN BE A WRONG. A WRONG
FULL REPORTING. IN A WRONGFUL
REPORTING ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT
YOU KNOW AS YOU AS YOU KNOW IS
WHEN. SOMEBODY GET CPS ON
SOMEBODY I MEAN ON A ON A
PARENT. WHEN THERE WAS REALLY
NOTHING THERE- THEY IN OTHER
WORDS THEY MISINTERPRET SOME OF
THE CLUES THAT THEY MAY BE
TAUGHT YOU KNOW ACCEPT BRUISES.
THINGS LIKE THAT I WAS A
MANDATORY REPORTER MYSELF
OBVIOUSLY AND- WE HAD TO
STRUGGLE WITH THAT SOMETIMES WE
GO IN THE HOUSE AND WE LOOK
AROUND AND GO. ONE WAY YOU KNOW
WE'RE ABOUT TO SEND THESE
PARENTS LIFE INTO HELL FORMER.
WHAT WE THINK IS AN ABUSE
SITUATION. I CAN'T IMAGINE
PLACE IN THAT ON A YOUNG
VOLUNTEER SO I WAS HOPING THAT
WE COULD SOMEHOW HAVE THIS BE A
BILL WHERE THOSE VOLUNTEERS ARE
GIVEN THE TRAINING THE BASIC
TRAINING. AND THE ORGANIZATION
NEEDS TO HAVE THOSE VOLUNTEERS
REPORT TO A MANDATORY REPORTER
IN THAT SYSTEM THAT HEY I
SUSPECT THIS SO THAT THAT
MANDATORY REPORTING IS ACTUALLY
DONE BY. AT IT'S AN ADULT THAT
IS PAID THAT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
I WAS PAID FOR TO DO THAT. AND
THEREFORE PROTECTING THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM THOUGH NOT
ONLY POTENTIAL LIABILITY BUT I
I'VE SEEN A FEW OF THESE ANGRY
PARENTS. WHO COME AND SAY HEY
WHAT WHAT'S WHAT THE HECK
HAPPENED I SENT MY KID HERE
NEXT THING YOU KNOW I GOT CPS.
COME BRING THEM DOWN MY THROAT
I CAN'T GET MY KIDS BACK. IT'S
A NIGHTMARE FOR SOME PEOPLE AND
WE WANT TO PROTECT THOSE KIDS
THAT'S THE TRADE OFF. BUT I
SOMEHOW WANT C. THAT
TRANSFERRED TO THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY THE ADULTS IN
CHARGE. SO THIS THAT'S JUST MY
STRUGGLE WITH IT SURE HAVING A
HARD TIME NOT SUPPORTING AND
BACKING AND NOT I'M NOT GONNA
BONDS I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THIS IS A RESULT OF IN FACT THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB AND THE BOY
SCOUTS. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
WHITE BOY SCOUT NINETY THOUSAND
CASES PRIMARILY BY VOLUNTEERS
OF ABUSE AND NO REPORTING
WHATSOEVER BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB-
THERE WERE OVER TWO HUNDRED
CASES AND THEY FOUND THAT
DESPITE INTERNAL POLICIES THEY
WERE DOING BACKGROUND CHECKS ON
THEIR END OWN EMPLOYEES. SO
THIS IS SET IN FACT TO NOT HAVE
THE VOTE THE LONG TERM
VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
A CASUAL VOLUNTEER RATES
SIXTEEN HOURS IN A MONTH OR
THIRTY TWO FOR THE YEAR A LONG
TERM VOLUNTEERS TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
AS WELL UNFORTUNATELY IF WE HAD
LET THE LAW. JUST ALLOW- USEFUL
IT'S NOT USEFUL IN TEARS
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE OVER
EIGHTEEN BECAUSE IT DOES GET
TRICKY UNDER EIGHTEEN BUT OVER
EIGHTEEN TO SIMPLY TELL-
SOMEBODY AT THE INSTITUTION
THAT THAT MIGHT BE THAT IN ALL
OF THESE CASES IT WAS SOMEBODY
AT THE INSTITUTION ITSELF THAT
WAS WAS PERPETRATING THE ABUSE.
AND THIS IS REALLY GEARED
TOWARDS CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE
IN INSTITUTIONS THAT SERVE
CHILDREN- SO I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS AT AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD THAT CALLS- THAT THAT
REPORTS TO BE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ISN'T SUBJECT TO LIABILITY I IN
AND IT'S NOT IN THEIR HANDS
WHETHER OR NOT. THE LAN PORTS
AND HAS TO DEAL WITH CPS IN THE
RESULT OF C. P. S. U. YOU WERE
PROBABLY IN A DIFFERENT SPOT
SO- I'M COMFORTABLE WITH THAT I
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH UNDER
EIGHTEEN FOR VARIETY REASONS
I'M NOT SURE THAT THE
COMPREHENSION- WOULD BE
COMPLETE. AND SO IN FOR THE
MOST PART WE DON'T HAVE UNDER
EIGHTEEN VOLUNTEERS WERE
VOLUNTEERING THAT MUCH AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS BUT UNFORTUNATELY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE IS ALSO
APPEARED OF TIME WHEN WE DO
HAVE PREDATORS- AND I HATE TO
SAY THAT PEOPLE GET REALLY
ANGRY WHEN I USE THE WORD
PREDATORS BUT PREDATORS.
UTILIZE THESE ORGANIZATIONS AS
A GROUNDS TO GROOM AND- SELECT
CHILDREN TO ABUSE SO. I
UNDERSTAND IT I PERSONALLY AS A
MOM- AS- SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN
WORK IN CHILD- ABUSE ISSUES NOW
FOR. MY ENTIRE TIME HERE I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD ALWAYS-
ERR ON THE SIDE OF CHILDREN AND
PROTECTING CHILDREN AND SO IT
IS. IN IN PARTICULAR I'M
CONCERNED ON CPS WHAT WHEN THE
BIG ISSUES IS BLACK AND BROWN
FAMILIES ARE VIEWED AS ABUSERS
OF CHILDREN MUCH MORE OFTEN
THAN WHITE FAMILIES. AND THAT'S
A WHOLE NOTHER ISSUE BUT FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND BECAUSE WE'RE
REALLY TARGETING CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT. THAT HAS
OVERWHELMINGLY HAPPENED AT
INSTITUTION SERVING CHILDREN-
AND- WE HAVE THE PROOF OF EVAN
BY VOLUNTEERS OR VOLUNTEERS WHO
KNEW IT WAS GOING ON AND DIDN'T
SPEAK UP WE NEED TO- TIGHTEN IT
UP. RIGHT AND I AGREE WITH YOU
ON THAT I JUST I LOOK AT THE
OTHER PART WHICH IS CHAIR. YOU
KNOW FOR ME MANDATORY REPORTING
IS WHEN YOU GO AND YOU SEE SOME
KID WITH THAT BUNCH OF BRUISES
ON ON. THAT YOU NEED TO LOW.
NOTIFIED THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
NOTIFY C. P. S. R. C. P. S.
AND- AND WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT INTERNAL ABUSE- IN WITHIN
THE SYSTEM ITSELF. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT PART SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT THE-
CLARIFICATIONS IN THE
CONVERSATION I APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY. ONE
ELSE COME MISTER CORK. WITH
REGARD TO P. T. HEY I WAS A PTA
PRESIDENT AND I WAS. NEVER
WORKED WITH YOU. BUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO. HI IN A TEN HOUR
EVERY WEEK IN THE CLASSROOM- SO
I DO THINK THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE IN PTA WHO SHOULD COME
UNDER THIS. WORKS OUT MUCH IN
THE CLASSROOM- AND- I'M NOT
QUITE SURE WHAT THE PTA IS
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER THEY
WANT TO BE OUT OF IT ALTOGETHER.
OR JUST OUT OF IT- EXCEPT FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK A LOT WITH
KIDS CAN YOU STATE WHAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THEIR POSITION ON MY
UNDERSTANDING IS SO- I I'M I'M
TO GIVE MY OWN. EXAMPLES OF MY
INVOLVEMENT OF PTA SO ONE YEAR
I WAS TO THE PTA PARENT TO
PARENT CLASSROOM PARENTS FOR MY
DAUGHTER IN THIRD GRADE AND SHE
BIG MAY NEVER BE CLASSROOM
POUND AGAIN- I'M APPARENTLY
VERY CONTROLLING. THAT IN THAT
CASE I AM IN THE CLASSROOM I
JUST SAW A SIDE NOTE THAT COULD
IMAGINE- SO IN THAT CASE I'M IN
IN THE CLASSROOM EVERY SINGLE%
WEEK SOMETIMES TWICE A WEEK FOR
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF HOURS RIGHT
DIRECT- DIRECT INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE CHILDREN SOMETIMES
UNSUPERVISED YOU KNOW THERE
THERE WERE. ISSUES IN WHICH I
SHOULD HAVE A BACKGROUND CHECK
BY THE WAY I DID AND- AND MORE
THAN I THINK THE ONLY THING I
HAD TO HAVE WAS A TB TEST.
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A. LITTLE
PROBLEM THERE RIGHT- THE OTHER
SIDE. IS AS I COULD NO LONGER
BE A ROOM HERE BECAUSE MY CHILD
DISQUALIFIED ME. I'M INVOLVED
IN PTA BUT I AM THE CASUAL
VOLUNTEER MAYBE EVEN MONTHLY
VOLUNTEER BUT I'M JUST SELLING
PIZZA. AT THE KIDS SCHOOL ON
FRIDAYS IN THE AFTERNOON AS A
FUNDRAISER SO I'M HAVING
CONTACT I'M NOT HAVING DIRECT
CONTACT. OR INDIVIDUALIZED
CONTACT AND WE NEED THOSE
VOLUNTEERS TO BE ABLE TO SIGN
UP FOR. BIG SALES AND SOMETIMES
PTA VOLUNTEERS IT COULD WE
DON'T WANNA LABEL THE PTA AS A
CHILD SERVING ORGANIZATION WHEN
SOME PTA MEMBERS WHO DO A LOT
OF STUFF NEVER ACTUALLY EVEN
INTERACT WITH THE CHILDREN. SO
WHAT WE NEED TO. I THINK WHAT
PJ'S CONCERNS ARE WE NEED TO
TIGHTEN UP HOW WE WHO IN THEIR
ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THIS BUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN NONE OF THEM WOULD BE
SUBJECT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S FINE
THANK THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. EIGHT QUESTIONS FROM
THE. FORTY TWO OH TWO. HOW ARE
YOU TODAY OKAY NOW YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU SO I ADDED
MYSELF AS A- REJECT US. AREN'T
IN THE CLASSROOM FOR MY KIDS
BUT BEYOND THAT I THINK
EVERYTHING ELSE I SAID MAKES
SENSE TO PEOPLE AND I HOPE THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
PROTECT CHILDREN. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE. THANK YOU FOR TOO
MANY AND I CALL THE ROLL. THE
BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON EIGHTY FIVE OH SIX
BY NOT ENOUGH GONZALEZ THEM
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI
BLACKIE AND BARRICADE IN CORK.
CORK ACCENT IAGO. C. R. TO. HI
SEE OUR TOP FIVE WICKS LI LI I
THE MEASURE PASSES MISTER
COOLEY EIGHT NUMBERS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. TWELVE FORTY
FIVE COOLEY RESENTENCING.
HOLLY'S GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
PLEASED TO BRING THIS BILL TO
IT IS. A KIM TO MISTER TANKS
FIFTEEN FORTY SECOND LOOK
SENTENCING BILL. AND- FOR THE
SENATE TO PROBE IS TO BE IN
THIS COMMITTEE I WAS ADMITTED
TO THE BAR EIGHTY FOUR BUT I
NEVER PRACTICE- CRIMINAL LAW.
AND THIS ISSUE HAS OFTEN MADE
ME GET. AND ACROSS SPACE GREG
ALWAYS THINK YOU IN YOUR SHOP
WHEN THESE ISSUES COME UP. FAR
BEYOND MY EXPERIENCE SO
CONGRATULATIONS. ON THIS BILL
COMES OUT OF MY DISTRICT IT
COMES OUT OF MY LIFE IN THAT I
HAD A CONSTITUENT AND RICK CAME-
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION A
GENTLEMAN NAMED QUENTIN WATTS
WHO HAD BEEN SENTENCED. FOUR HE
WAS A DRIVER AND A BUS. GOING
TO THE COLUSA CASINO. THAT WAS
IN A TERRIBLE AUTO ACCIDENT
ELEVEN PEOPLE DIED TWENTY ONE
WERE INJURED. AND TRIED IN A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTY IS
AFRICAN AMERICAN GENTLEMAN. WHO
HAD A HISTORY OF. SEIZURES BUT
THE SEIZURES ISSUES NEVER CAME
OUT IN THE TRIAL. YOU SUGGEST
THAT MAYBE HE HADN'T GOT
SUFFICIENT SLEEP EAT LETTUCE
DIABETES GET OUT OF CONTROL.
ELEVEN HE WAS SENTENCED. TWO OF
TWENTY SIX YEARS TO LIFE. AND
THERE WAS A CASE OF. THE
MANSLAUGHTER CHARGES COUPLE
SOME BOTTLE AND- SO SEVERE. A
PART BY TERM OF ART- GREAT
BODILY INJURY ENHANCEMENT ALSO
APPLIED. AND LEAD TO THE
SEVERITY OF HIS SENTENCE. I GOT
INTERESTED WHEN I REALIZE THAT-
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAD
ISSUED A RULING IN PEOPLE
VERSUS COOK THE SELLING THIS
FACT PATTERN THESE GREAT ALL
ENHANCES COULD ACTUALLY BE
APPLIED IN SEVEN SEASONS AS A
HEAD OF A CLINTON WHAT'S- AND
THE LONG STORY IS I STARTED
ASKING QUESTIONS I ACTUALLY
WROTE MY FIRST LETTER TO
GOVERNOR BROWN. IN JUNE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HI THIS IS
MAGGIE AND I'M CALLING STUDENT
LOAN RELIEF HI. ASKING THAT HE
WOULD- COMMUTE. WHAT WHAT'S THE
SENTENCE I WROTE AGAIN TO
GOVERNOR KNEW SOMEONE THAT
DIDN'T PRODUCE A RESULT- BUT
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
IN QUITE A LOT SAID I'D HAVE TO
SAY ADVOCATE AND OTHERS. ALL I
WAS A SUPPORTER IN THIS BUT NOT
IN THE VANGUARD ACTUALLY. OF
CDC AND OTHERS REALLY EXAMINE
THIS SITUATION A SAP WILL BE
PROVIDED A GREAT DEAL OF
COVERAGE OF A WRITER JASON PAUL.
AND EVENTUALLY A LETTER WENT TO
THE COURT ASKING THEM TO
REVISIT THIS CASE THEY DID
REVISIT THE CASE THEY LOPPED
OFF YEARS OFF A SENTENCE AND
COULDN'T WATCH WAS RELEASED
NINE DAYS LATER THE BILL-
CIRCUIT SO I DO BELIEVE IN THIS
IDEA THAT THERE CAN BE FACTUAL
SITUATIONS THAT WARRANT SECOND
LOOK SENTENCING. AND I THINK
THEY I CAN UNDERSTAND HOW
PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS BUT I ACTUALLY THINK
IT IS AN AREA OF THE LAW THAT
WILL LOOK AT AS MY BILL
PROPOSES AS I KNOW MR TANG IN A
MORE PURPOSIVE LIFE SO I
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL. ON BEHALF
OF AB TWELVE FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MR COOLEY I SEE. YOU HAVE
NO PLAN WITNESSES AND I'LL GO
TO A FORTY TWO OH TWO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE COOLEY. SURE
BE THE SAME TO THE
TELECONFERENCING. AND NOW TO
THE TELEPHONE LINES OPERATE KEY
OPEN UP FOR AB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE COOLEY- PEOPLE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LINE ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR MORE
CONCORD HAVE HELPFUL PUBLIC
DEFENDERS THE THIRTEENTH AND-
WHAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FOR THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES CARE BEGAN ON BEHALF OF
PLACE THE GRAYSON FULL SUPPORT
OF TWELVE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
YOU THANK YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT.
RIGHT FOR SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERICA
WOULD BE MITCHELL FROM ORANGE
CALIFORNIA AND I FULLY SUPPORT
AB TWELVE TWENTY FIVE AND URGE
A YES VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE ALLOWED ANY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HI YOU YES HE.
OKAY HI GOOD AFTERNOON- BENEATH
THE HEART WITH THE LOOK ON
VALLEY PEOPLE AGAIN WEREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY
AND I SEE ON HERE I HAVE. MITCH
VILLACH COULD TELL FROM THE
ASSAULT TREASURER FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ON THE FONG. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR- MISTER CHAIRMAN
JONES SAWYER. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME- YEAH PERFECTLY GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SIR. IT'S A
GERMAN JOINT SAWYER AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS THEIR
CONCERNS REGARDING AB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE MY NAME IS MADE YOU
FELT COULD TELL TREASURE OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SO WITH THE
ADDITION OF DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA. IT'S RETURNS SO
SEE ASIAN AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION OF AB TOLD FORTY
FIVE MINUTES AMEND. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW YOU TO.
INCARCERATED FOR SEARS VIOLENCE
FENCES. ON THEIR OWN BEHALF
RECALL THEIR SENSE EVEN SENATE
IMPOSED AS PART OF A PLEA
BARGAIN. I WOULD FORCE THE
COURT IMPORT STANDARD THAT
WOULD GUARANTEE THAT ALL SUCH
PETITIONS MUST BE GRANTED
REGARDLESS OF THE INMATES CRIME
THIS GREAT RECORD CONTINUING
CRIMINAL CONDUCT WHILE
INCARCERATED. PARTICIPATION IN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS OR POST
RELEASED REENTRY PLANS ARE
THREE CONCERNS ARE AS FOLLOWS
FIRST. RT OF PETITIONS TO
RECALL AT THE END AFTER
CONDUCTING A REVIEW OF THE
MERIT BASED FACTORS THAT MAY BE
CONSIDERED BY THE COURT. AB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE ALLOWS ANY
INMATES TO PETITION THE COURT
FOR RESENTENCING. THE MOST
VIOLENT OFFENSES. HUMAN
INCLUDING CONTINUOUS SEXUAL
ABUSE OF A CHILD HOMICIDES
INVOLVING GUN VIOLENCE WITHOUT
ANY CRITERIA ANY VETTING
ALREADY SCREENING. THIS WOULD
CERTAINLY BE COSTLY AND
BURDENSOME TO THE COURT SYSTEM
JUST LOOKING AT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DESCRIPTIONS OFFICE IS
REVIEWING CASES PURSUANT TO THE
CURRENT STATURE. RECENT GDPR
INFORMATION INDICATE THERE ARE
NINE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR INCARCERATED PERCENT
ORIGINATING FROM L. A. COUNTY
FIRST SERVED AT LEAST FIFTEEN
YEARS. THEY ALL WILL BE ABLE TO
DIRECTLY PETITION THE COURT
WITHOUT REGARD FOR THE RECORD.
OTHER FACTORS TO REFLECT ON
THEIR SUITABILITY TO REENTER
SOCIETY. THERE IS A STRONG
LIKELIHOOD TO MOST OF THEM HAVE
ALREADY PETITIONED UNDER
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION EVEN IF
THEY WERE NOT ELIGIBLE.
INCARCERATED PERSONS YOU'RE NOT
CONCERNED WHICH RETHINKING
STATUTE APPLIES TO DUCK. IT IS
EASIER TO PETITION THE COURTS
WILL ON THAT. THIRD PARTIES ARE
PETITIONING ON THEIR BEHALF IN
THE CURRENT STATUTE THERE WILL
BE DIFFICULT IF ADDITION. AND
HOW DID THE COURTS BURDEN IS
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE COURT
ACT ON THE PETITION WITHIN
NINETY DAYS. OF THE PETITION
HAVING BEEN FILED. THIS IS
UNREASONABLE CONSIDERING THE
COURTS ARE NOT ONLY REVIEWING
PETITIONS UNDER THE CURRENT
STATUTE. ALSO REVIEWING GAVE
ITS CORPUS PETITION AND OTHER
RESENDIZ RESENDIZ ADDITION
UNDER OTHER GILBERT SECTION.
SECOND SPECIFIC ONLY TO FEED
YOUR PETITION AB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE. DEPARTS FROM AMERICA
EIGHT THOUSAND TO A BAKED IN A
MARKET THAT'S EXCEPTIONAL
REHABILITATION. IT UNKNOWN
WHITE HE DID YOUR PETITIONS ARE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY IN THIS
BILL THE OTHER PETITIONERS. IT
BILL PROVIDES NO CLEAR
GUIDELINES FOR CDC ARE TO
ENSURE. HERE'S UNIFORMITY IN
SENTENCING. THE PEOPLE HOULD
KNOW WHAT DEFINES EXCEPTIONAL
REHABILITATION. HOW THE MEASURE
WHAT IS THE THRESHOLD OF YOURS
AND- ACTIVITY TO DETERMINE
EXCEPTIONAL REHABILITATION.
OKAY TYPES BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY SINCE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS SHOULD
VARY DEPENDING ON THE CRIME-
GRAMMY NEED IN A CHILD ABUSE
CASE IS DIFFERENT THAN A
SPECIAL SOCKET. GIVE
UNCERTAINTY AND BIRD BALLS WILL
CREATE DISPARITY OF SENTENCE
RATHER THAN ELIMINATE. OF GREAT
CONCERN IS THE SHIFTING OF THE
BURDEN OF PROOF TWENTY
IMPOSSIBLE TO REBUT STANDARD
REQUIRES THE COURT TO GRANT
EVERY PETITION UNLESS THERE IS
EVIDENCE BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT. THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
QUITE LIKELY TO COMMIT A FUTURE
VIOLENT CRIME. IT'S CREATE THE
DE FACTO MANDATE TO REACH SENSE
REGARDLESS OF CIRCUMSTANCES. IT
REQUIRED THE IMPOSSIBLE. THE
BILL LEADING TO NOT ONLY
ACTUALLY PREDICT THE FUTURE BUT
TO DO SO BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT. IT'LL BE NEVER. BE
PROVED BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT OF THE FUTURE CONDUCT OF
ANY HUMAN BEING BECAUSE NO
HUMAN BUT THAT'S THE SUCH
ABILITY. MOREOVER THE PROPOSED
STANDARD ONLY CONTEMPLATES THE
COMMISSION OF A FUTURE VIOLENT
CRIME. DESPITE DEFINITION
PRECLUDES CONSIDERATION OF THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THE INMATE WILL
BE COMMIT FUTURE NONVIOLENT
CRIMES SUCH AS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE. ELDER
ABUSE EIGHT CRIME RATE BY
INTOXICATION OR CHILD
MOLESTATION. WE THE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ASSURED THAT
INCARCERATED PERSON HAD BEEN
REHABILITATED FOR SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY INTO THE COMMUNITY NOT
FOR COMMITTING CERTAIN CRIMES
BUT ALL CRIMES THAT IS
REHABILITATION. TO EXCLUDE MOST
CRIMES IN THE BILL DOES NOT
BRING CONFIDENCE AND YET THAT'S
BEEN INCARCERATED PERSON IS
EXCEPTIONALLY REHABILITATED. IT
GOES BACK TO WHAT IS
EXCEPTIONAL. IT DOESN'T MERELY
A MECHANISM FOR YOU COULD BE
OUR TO RELEASE MORE
INCARCERATED PERSONS ON
CHALLENGED IT LACKS YOU CONCERN
FOR THE PUBLIC AND EVEN THE
INCARCERATED PERSON. IS THE
PERSON THAT UP TO SIXTY
CONSIDER FOR EXAMPLE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE IT'S-
THOUSAND FORTY YOU. NEED TO
WRAP UP YOUR BY MISSOURI. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THE THIRD AT
THE OUR CONCERN IS THE
PROSECUTION AND COURT FROM THE
DRYING THERE ENDED THERE- THE
RIDGE OF THE AGREEMENT WHEN
RESENTENCED GRANTED. WITH LEGAL
DUE TO NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
AND LASTLY IN EVEN IF IT COMES
ARE NOTIFIED OUR VICTIM IMPACT
STATEMENTS BE MEANINGLESS IF
THERE IS THE FACT AMENDED TO
READ SENSE WE HAVE TO
COLLABORATE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY TO IMPROVE THIS
BILL. FOR THE BOTTOM OF THE
PUBLIC IN VICTIMS OF CRIME- AT
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
STATE FIGURES THE CRIMES ARE
ENTITLED TO FIND OUT IN THE
CRIMINAL CASES THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NOW WITH WILL LOOK INTO THE-
IDEAS FOR ANY. INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE MISTER COOLEY C.
NONE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SAME QUESTION
SEEN NONE OPERATOR COULD YOU
OPEN UP FOR A. B. TWELVE FORTY
FIVE COOLEY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MRS QUIRK- SO WE JUST
HEARD MR SPELL- I WOULD HOPE
THAT- BEFORE. EITHER BILL COMES
TO THE FLOOR THAT THE TWO OF
YOU WORK ON ONE BILL. AND RIGHT
NOW I THINK- MISTER TING'S BILL
IS SOMEWHAT MORE ADVANCED IN
TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF DETAIL-
SO I PREFER THAT ONE AT THE
MOMENT BUT I HOPE YOU TWO CAN
WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS SHARE
TO. MR LACKEY K- THANK YOU MR
COOLEY FOR YOUR BILL. SO ONE OF
THINGS I'M I HAVE A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE PART OF
THIS YOU'VE ACTUALLY CREATED A
FOR OUR THEBILL ACTUALLY HAS
CREATED A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
TO DO RESENTENCING WITH THE
DISTRIBUTION OF HAVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
CALCULATE SAVINGS AND THEN
DISTRIBUTED OUT TO THE DA'S
OFFICE AND THESE DIFFERENT
THINGS IS THAT TRUE. IS THAT
PART OF THE BILL. I'M NOT I
THINK THAT SOMEONE'S
INTERPRETATION OF HOW THE BILL
OPERATOR STUDY. FORMAL IT'S NOT
PART OF THE BILL. BECAUSE IN
AND OUT I CAN I CAN TAKE IT UP
WITH YOU LATER- THANK YOU IT
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE HEARD A LOT.
IN MY FEW SHORT MONTHS HERE-
YEAH WE CAN DO THOSE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES- FOR LIKE AN
PROPERTY CONFISCATION AND
THINGS LIKE THAT CREATE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST SO THAT IS
PART OF THIS BILL- IT THAT
CREATES I THINK THAT SAME KIND
OF CONFLICT OF INTEREST
ARGUMENT. THAT I'VE HEARD FOR
OTHER SITUATIONS YEAH IN LAW
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ESPECIALLY.
I WILL SAY THIS I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT. IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
AN INTENTION OKAY IN THE BILL.
I THINK THAT'S FOR A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AS A IS A RIGHT
ISSUE TO RAISE. HI I ACTUALLY
DO BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME PLACE THAT THIS POLICY. OF
SECOND LOOK SINCE HE WILL LAND.
I PERSONALLY- I APPRECIATE THE
ANALYSIS OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION WITH A
COMMA TO WORK WITH ME I SEE
MYSELF WORK WITH THEM RIGHT
WERE THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION. AND- AS I SAY THIS
PARTICULAR BILL GROWS OUT OF MY
OWN INVOLVEMENT WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL'S LIFE- HAVING
FOLLOWED IT THROUGH A COUPLE OF
GOVERNORS- SO. YEAH I
APPRECIATE YOU'RE DEFINITELY
NOT AN OBJECT OF MY BILL HI I
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION BUT I
HOPE YOU LOOK INTO THAT BEFORE
IT GOES TO THE FLOOR YES
INDEED. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CLARK. JUST TO READ FROM YOU
AND MAIL. PART IN THE FINANCIAL
CALCULATE THE SAVINGS ACCRUED
FROM RESENTENCING DEFENDANT.
PURSUANT TO THIS SECTION- AND
UPON. APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE 25% OF THE SAVINGS
WILL BE GO TO THE DA. TWELVE
POINT 5% TO SUPERIOR COURT. AND
TWELVE POINT 5% TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER. THANK YOU MR LACKEY
YEAH THE CASE YOU CITED IS
CLEARLY WORTHY OF. NEVADA CáC
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT
BUT THERE THERE'S SOME OTHER
CONCERNS WERE WITH THE WAY THIS
IS STRUCTURED AT LEAST MY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT. ONE OF THE
OF THE FRUSTRATIONS WAS
EXPRESSED BY- MISTER SHARP
THOUGH BUT- SECONDLY I THINK
THAT IT CREATES THE PRESUMPTION
THAT SAW. IT'S QUITE- UNFAIR
THE REQUIREMENT FOR PROOF
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT. THAT
THE DEFENDANT IS LIKELY TO OUT
FOR. BY LIKE. I THINK THAT'S A-
HUGE STEP IT'S FAIRLY REASON.
AND IT'S KIND OF A DEFECT ON
THE- SINCE TO ME DOESN'T SEEM.
LIKE IT'S AN OBJECT CRITERIA.
THAT'S ALL THAT'S MY
FRUSTRATION WITH THIS BILL OKAY
THANK YOU HELLO THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. CHRIS COMMENT YOU MAY
CLOSE THE SCHOOL. MOVING
FORWARD I DEFINITELY INTEND TO
BE WORKING WITH D. A.'S. THE
JUDGES CIRCULATION AND
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A BROADER
CONVERSATION THAN THIS BILL.
THIS BILL AROSE OUT OF MY OWN.
LIFE EXPERIENCE I'M A LAWMAKER
THAT'S HOW I ARRIVED AT THE
SUBJECT MATTER. BUT AS I SAY
WAS I WAS GRATEFUL TO SIT HERE
AND HEAR THE DISCUSSION OF
FIFTEEN FORTY AS WELL I REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME AND LISTENING. TO
YOUR ATTENTION YOUR DUTIES.
THANK YOU MR COOLEY IN A CHAIR
ALSO. RECOMMENDS AN AYE VOTE
AND ALSO- ABOUT. DISABILITY WE
TALKED ABOUT ON THE FLORIDA
COULDN'T MEMBER ID NUMBER BUT
ABOUT CONSOLIDATING OR LEASE
HAVING A DISCUSSION WITH MISTER
KING- SO THAT- WE CAN WE CAN
MAYBE MOVE S. ONE. ONE BILL-
THE OTHER THING IS- AT THE
LOOKING IN AND CLARIFY. SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE
HAVE. BROUGHT UP NOT TO GET IT
BEARS THAT WE SHOULD ACTUALLY
CLARIFY THAT FOR THEM AND ARE
STILL CHAIRS RECOMMENDED BY.
THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AT TWELVE FORTY
FIVE AS THE MEMBER COOLEY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER ADDED
LACKEY. LACKEY NOT VOTING POWER
CAN CORK. BURKE AYE SANTIAGO
THEY ARE TO NOW THEY ARE TEN
NOW WICKS. LEE. MEASURES
ARTICLE. THREE MISTER RICHARDS.
AB. TWELVE FIVE NINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMEDIAN THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FIRST
OF ALL LIKE TO START BY
THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS OF YOUR STAFF TEAM
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE SO WOULD MY
BELT THANK YOU APPRECIATE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT I ALSO
WANT TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE AS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS- AS THE BILL IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED TO LIMIT
THE BILL TO INCREASING THE
CRIMINAL FINES FOR COMMITTING
HATE CRIMES. AB TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD INCREASE THE CRIMINAL
FINE FOR COMMITTING A HATE
CRIME AND USE THAT INCREASE TO
FUND PROGRAMS ON RACIAL OR
ETHNIC SENSITIVITY OR OTHER
FAMILIAR WITH SIMILAR TRAINING
IN THE AREA OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
THANK YOU THINK MUCH THAT. HATE
CRIMES AND HATE INCIDENTS
ESPECIALLY TARGETING THE ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
OR AAPI COMMUNITY. HAVE
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY OVER THE
LAST YEAR ACCORDING TO THE
ORGANIZATION'S STOP API HE
COALITION. NEARLY THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED HATE
INCIDENTS OCCUR ACROSS THE-UNITED STATES. AGAINST THE API
COMMUNITY WITHIN A TEN MONTH
PERIOD. INCLUDING NEARLY
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED INCIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. MY DISTRICT ARE
LOCATED IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY HAS A POPULATION THAT IS
FIFTY THREE PERCENT. API'S OF
THIS ANTI ASIAN SENTIMENT IS
HITTING MY DISTRICT WHERE WE
ARE SEEING A P. OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. BEING THE TARGETS OF
ASSAULTS- HARASSMENT AND
VANDALISM. EIGHT AB TWENTY
EIGHT WILL HELP ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BY INCREASING THE
CRIMINAL FINES FOR A
MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY HATE
CRIME BY. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH IT WOULD
REQUIRE UP TO TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OF ANY CRIMINAL
FINES RECEIVED TO BE DEPOSITED
IN THE TRIAL COURT- TRUST FUND
TO FUND CLASSES- IN THE AREA OF
A CIVIL RIGHTS. I HEALTH DOT TO
GET YOU IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHINESE AMERICAN MUSEUM
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU ARE. NOT
TO TALK TO WIN BACK TO YOU AT
NIGHT GREAT MAY I AM. BEGAN
THEIR TESTIMONY NOW. HELLO
HELLO. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
BEGAN. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAN AND I'M CHAIR OF
THE BOARD OF THE FRIENDS OF THE
CHINESE AMERICAN MUSEUM WHICH
IS LOCATED IN LOS. ANGELES I
LIVE IN THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
OF WHICH OVER FIFTY FIVE OR
ALMOST 55% OF THE RESIDENTS ARE
EIGHTEEN I AM A RETIRED
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATORS WORKING IN THE FIELD
OF MULTICULTURAL EDUCATION FOR
OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS AND TODAY
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT. IT'S NO LONGER
SURPRISING NEWS WHEN WE TURN ON
OUR TELEVISIONS AT NIGHT HERE A
LIST MANY OF REPORTS OF VERBAL
AND PHYSICAL ATTACKS
PERPETRATED AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICAN. THESE ATTACKS ARE
CONTINUING TO URGE AS CONCORD
WE ATTACKERS UP TO HELP WITH
ELDERS WHO CAN'T EVEN
THEMSELVES. ANTI ASIAN
SENTIMENT IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT
NEW EVER SINCE THE MID EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS WHEN TRYING TO CAME
FOR THE GOAL RUSSIAN LEADER
ADDS VALUE TO THE BIRDS TO
BUILD THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD. THIS ONE HE
RELATIONSHIP HAS BEEN STICKER
CALL AT U. S. NEEDS FOR CHEAP
CHINESE LABOR AND MUCH NEEDED
CHINESE INTELLIGENCE WAXED AND
WANED IN THE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY PLUS YEARS OF THE.
CHINESE LIVING IN AMERICA. WHEN
YOU CALL THE TRYING WILL. WHEN
NO LONGER NEED SPEND TRYING TO
MUSK BECAUSE THEN THEY ARGUE
AGAINST. MERIT STRANGE ANIMAL
AND PETS THEY TAKE JOBS AWAY
FROM REAL AMERICANS THEY ARE
SPOTLIGHTS. AND THEY CARRIED
VIRUS. ONE OF THE MOST SHAMEFUL
ACTING. HISTORY AS KURDS WHEN
ANTI CHINESE SENTIMENT REACHED
A CLIMAX TWO YEARS AFTER THE
COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD. ON
OCTOBER TWENTY FOURTH EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE AND ONE OF THE
WORST MASSACRE IN THE UNITED
STATES HAPPENS IN DAN LOS
ANGELES CHINATOWN AND THAT'S
WHERE OUR CHINESE AMERICAN
MUSEUM STANDS TODAY. CHINESE
ADULTS AND ONE FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD BOY WAS LYNCHED AND
MURDERED BY A MOB OF FIVE
HUNDRED WHITE VIGILANTE. THE
NUMBER DIRECTLY SENATE 10% OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CHINATOWN
RESIDENTS AT THAT HI. CHABLIS
YOU WHY THE MURDERS WERE
CONVICTED THEY SPEND NO TIME IN
JAIL BECAUSE OF THE HALL ACT OF
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH
STATED THAT CHINESE AND OTHER
MINORITY GROUPS COULD NOT
TESTIFY AGAINST WHITE PEOPLE.
AS AS WE GET THE CHINESE
AMERICAN MUSEUM PREPARES TO
REMEMBER AND PAY RESPECT TO THE
SOULS OF THE MASSACRE VICTIMS A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS LATER. WE
FIND OURSELVES EMOTIONALLY
OVERWHELMED AND HEARTBROKEN
THAT WE ARE STILL HAVING TO
ADDRESS SUCH HATEFUL ACTIONS
AND NEEDING TO COMBAT AND
ADDRESS ANTI CHINESE EIGHT. IN
FACT ANTI CHINESE AND ANTI
ASIAN NEIGHBORHOODS NEVER
STOPPED IN THE U. S. ALL WE
NEED TO DO IS TO STUDY HISTORY
AND LEARN ABOUT THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT OF EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THE ROCK SPRINGS
MASSACRE OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
PLAGUE OF NINETEEN HUNDRED THAT
PLAYING BROKE UP TO THAT RIGHT
I BREAK OUT TO WAS BLAMED ON
THE CHINESE. AND VIGILANTES
BRING DON CHINATOWN JUST AS
THEY DID AFTER THE. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE L. A. MASSACRE.
THINK IN TERMS HIS IS. OF ANTI
ASIAN HATE ARE THEY ENTER OF.
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO
THE DEATH SENTENCE IN CHEN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. AND THE
REASON ATLANTA SHOOTING AT THE
ASIAN AMERICAN SALON WORKERS.
WELL THE WHOLE ABNORMAL APPLIES
NOWADAYS WE SAW SIMILAR RESULTS
WHEN THE KILLERS THE VINCENTIAN
WERE LET OFF BY THE JUDGE
BECAUSE THE FATHER AND SON
WHITE COLLAR WORKERS WERE
PULLED AND CALLED GOOD PEOPLE.
AND THE SHOOTER IN THAT LAPTOP
BASICALLY JUST HAD A BAD AGE.
SO RIGHT TWENTY IT'S IMPORTANT
IT PUTS ANOTHER DETERRENT INTO
PLACE THAT SAYS IF YOU COMMIT A
CRIME BINDO BE REPLICATION. IN
THIS CASE IF YOU COMMIT A HATE
CRIME AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS
OR ANY GROUP. THEN THERE WILL
BE A HIGHER PRICE TO PAY. AB AN
EDUCATOR I ALSO COMMENDED
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT PUTS
ASIDE DOLLARS FOR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. BOTH FOR THE
PERPETRATORS AND FOR EDUCATORS
AND TRAINERS. FOR THESE REASONS
I SUPPORT AND THANK A TUMBLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ED CHAU WITH
THE INTRODUCTION OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT AND I URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M NOT
AND I PROJECTS MR CHAU AND-
IT'S AB TWENTY EIGHT. AND AND
DR OKAY WHEN I WAS ON. THE
WRONG LINE SHOW- ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO. THAT WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEE NON- TO
THE VIDEO SCREEN ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT. NOW
GO TO THE OPEN LINE TELEPHONE
LINE OF ALL SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT CHILD. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS A SPECIALIZED- NEAR A
RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA AND I AM A FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DR RAYMOND KIM I AM THE
FOUNDER OF ASIAN AMERICAN GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLICAN AND INDEPENDENT GUN
OWNERS AGAINST HATE CRIMES AS
WELL AS ON BEHALF OF. ALL BUT
NINETEEN NINETY TWO LOS ANGELES
RIOTS VICTIMS CREATE AMERICANS
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IS THAT
WORKS HARD IT FOR A CRIME THANK
YOU YOUR NAME AND YOUR
INNOVATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GREG YOU HERE WITH
THE ARK AND UNITED CEREBRAL
PALSY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
A COALITION OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT AND
THANKS TO TRAPPERS LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS YVONNE LADY OF
SILICON VALLEY I URGE A YES
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ANNA LANE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
K. AND NOW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE IT KATHY HERE
FROM ACLU. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MR KAREN NUMBER KATHY SHARPER
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION WE
RESPECTFULLY MUST OPPOSE AB
TWENTY EIGHT- I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR OPENNESS TO
DISCUSSION OF OUR CONCERNS
REGARDING THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE THE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE REMAINING
PROVISIONS INCREASING THE FINE
CHOCOLATE MISDEMEANOR AND
FELONY HATE CRIME STE THE HARM
CAUSED WHEN DEFENDANTS ARE
UNABLE TO PAY FINES IMPOSED ON
THEM I. WEALTHY SEARCH AND
DOCUMENT. WHEN STRUCK UNDER THE
OF FROM IMPOSED OUTLOOK TO BE A-
TO PAY AS FINDS THE- THEIR
FAMILY THOUGHT FOR A DAY MORE
DEPTH. REINTEGRATE INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY MAKE
HOMELESSNESS OR EVEN RETURNED
TO JAIL OR PRISON THIS IS AS
TRUE COURT DEFENDANTS CHARGED
WITH HATE CRIMES THAT THAT IS
FOR HER TO CONSTRUCTION OF ANY
OTHER TYPE OF CON. SUS WELL THE
GOAL OF STOPPING HATE CRIMES IS
LAUDABLE AN INCREASE AND FIND
IT'S. NOT THE WAY TO REACH THIS
CALL. ACTUALLY AFTER. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY WITNESS IN THE
ROOM AND OPPOSITION CENA I DO
WITNESSES ON THE- ON THE-
TELECONFERENCE. SEEN NONE-
RIENECK PRETTY NOW MAY GO TO
TELEPHONE LINES UP FOR AB
TWENTY EIGHT CHILD YEAH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE LINE IN HURON SD ONE MOMENT.
THEY DID REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM
Q. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS
IN Q. OKAY- WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES I'M I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE CHAIR
USUALLY FINDS GET TRIPLED- WELL
I GUESS I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE VICE CHAIR WHICH YOU CAN
REFER TO STAFF FOR- WHICH IS
USUALLY FINDS WHEN THEY ARE
MADE ARE ABOUT ACTUALLY TRIPLED
IN SIZE BECAUSE OF ALL THE
SURCHARGES THAT AE PUT ON THEM
IS THAT GOING TO BE THE CASE
WITH THESE FUNDS AS WELL. YEAH
YES OKAY SO YOU'RE NOT
INCREASING THIS BY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED YOUR INCREASING IT BY
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL OF THESE ADDITIONS
TO GET PUT ON FOR THIS THAT OR
THE OTHER. AND BASICALLY WHEN
YOU'RE MAKING THE MY MINUS THE
LOWER FINE ART NOW UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED THAT'S
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FURTHER I DON'T THINK MOST
PEOPLE ARE EVEN GONNA KNOW WHAT
THE FINES ARE. AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY EVEN PAY
THEM SO WE'RE GOING TO END UP
WITH MORE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T PAY
THEIR FINES- I JUST DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO
ABOUT IT- I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS FOR PUBLIC
FIGURES LIKE YOURSELF AND
MYSELF. TO BE OUT THERE IN
COUNTERING THE- EIGHT- DIRECTLY
WITH WHAT WE SAY AND DO AND NOT
BEING LIKE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
THE UNITED STATES WHO TALKS
ABOUT. CONFLUENT CHINA VIRUS.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO PRESENT
THAT IN PUBLIC AND I DON'T
THINK CHANGES FINES WILL DO
ANYTHING. OTHER THAN END UP
WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE BEING PT
INTO POVERTY. SO I'LL BE VOTING
NO I'M SORRY. THANK TWITTER. IF
I MAKE WATER- THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CLICK FOR YOUR COMMENT AND- I
DO UNDERSTAND YOUR POSITION AS
WELL AS THE POSITION OF A CELL
YOU. YET I THINK THAT- TACKLING
THE ISSUE OF HATE CRIMES. IS
GOING TO REQUIRE A COMBINATION
OF MANY DIFFERENT APPROACHES
AND MANY SOLUTIONS. AND THIS IS
ONLY ONE OF THOSE SOLUTIONS NOW
OF COURSE. THIS BILL FOCUSES ON
THE FINES AND ALSO THE TRAINING
ASPECT OF IT HAS REACHED AS I
STATED EARLIER. ALL THE
PROCEEDS WILL BE. ALLOCATED TO
THE TRAINING OF A SENSITIVITY
CLASSES- AND THE LIGHT WHICH IS
GOING TO BE VERY HOPEFUL
BECAUSE EDUCATION IS A BIG
PIECE OF. THE EQUATION. NOW
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK YOUR
FOCUS IS ON. THE UP THE AMOUNT
OF THE FINE AS WELL AS- YOU
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT TO FIND OUT
INCLUDES WILL ACTUALLY. ADDRESS
THE ISSUE YES I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN BUT- YET I THINK UP
THERE ARE SITUATIONS WERE
IMPOSING A FINE IS GOING TO
SERVE AS A DETERRENT. A PURPOSE
FOR SOME DEFENDANTS AT NUMBER
ONE. NOW AS FAR AS THE AMOUNT
OF THE FINE AND ALSO OF THE
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY I
THINK WE HAVE SOME GUARDRAILS
IN PLACE ALREADY. NUMBER ONE.
JUDGES HAVE THE DISCRETION
WHETHER HOW HOW MUCH ALL
WEATHER HOW MUCH OR WHETHER
THEY ACTUALLY WOULD IMPOSE THE
FINES. AND IT IS ENTIRELY UP TO
THE JUDGE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION. NOW THERE ARE MANY
COURTS IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT THE
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY
BEFORE THE IMPOSED A FINE. AND
IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT IS LOOKING AT THIS VERY
ISSUE. STILL THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT- THERE IS-
GOING TO BE A REQUIREMENT ON
ALL THE JUDGES TO LOOK AT
WHETHER OR NOT THE DEFENDANT
WOULD HAVE TO ABILITY TO PAY
THE FINE. BEFORE THAT- DEFINE.
ORDER IS IMPOSED ON THE
DEFENDANT. AND FINALLY- THE
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND ALSO THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION HAS
A PROVISION THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
EXCESSIVE FINES ON DEFENDANTS
PER SE SO THERE'S PLENTY OF
GUARDRAILS. THAT OUGHT THAT
WE'RE PLACING ON ON ON THE-
THIS PARTICULAR PENALTY. OR
THIS PARTICULAR FORM OF
CORRECTION. AND FINALLY COURSE-
THERE ALL IN BE- DEFENDANTS OF
HATE CRIMES WHO COULD- PAID THE
FINE. SO JUST TO RECAP IT IS UP
TO THE JUDGE TO. OUR GRANT THE
AMOUNT OF THE FINE SO THERE'S
YOUR GOT ROSE ALREADY AROUND IT
THAT THAT THAT THE PUNISHMENT.
JUST A SAVINGS GUARDRAILS HAVE
NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE IN THE PAST.
AND YET THIS IS A- SO THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE SUBJECTS THAT IS
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR SOCIETY TO
DEAL WITH. AND ONE OF THE
REASONS IS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
DEMAND THAT SOMEBODY FEEL A
DIFFERENT WAY IF THAT'S HOW
THEY FEEL. ALL YOU CAN DO IS
TRY TO STE SOMETIMES ALL YOU
CAN DO IS TRY TO STEER THEIR
BEHAVIOR AWAY FROM ACTING OUT
ON WHAT CAN BE AT YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN LIKE I HATE CRIME- ACTING
OUT IN A MANNER THAT- THEY FEEL
INSIDE. THAT MAYBE REASON
TELLS- YOU KNOW EVEN I FEEL
LIKE THAT I'M NOT GOING TO DO
THAT. AND I THINK THOSE ARE THE
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE. THAT THIS
BILL AFFECTS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING. TO FEEL
A DARN THING THEY'RE GONNA DO
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO. BUT WHEN
YOU SEE A SPIKE IN. HATE CRIMES
GOING ON LIKE WE'RE- WE HAVE TO
A- AND MONITOR FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE IS IT. MONITOR GIVES
THEM THAT EXTRA THING TO THINK
ABOUT. WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO
ACT OUT ON THEIR ANGER OR THEIR
HATE OR WHATEVER IT IS IT'S
TRIGGERING THEM. AND SO I DON'T
SEE THE MONETARY- ENHANCEMENT
FOR THIS AS AS SOMETHING BAD I
SEE TO SOMETHING GOOD AND
YOU'VE ALREADY STATED THE PARTS
WHERE YOU KNOW THERE ARE THERE
ARE GUARDRAILS THAT ALLOW
SENTENCE SAM YOU CAN'T SQUEEZE
BLOOD OUT OF A TURNIP. IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IF YOU'RE
GONNA FIND SOMEBODY FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS I DON'T HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS IN YOUR
POCKET THEY'RE NOT GOING TO PAY
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. BUT IF
IT CAN DETER 50% OR 60% OF THE
PEOPLE THEY'RE ACTING OUT RIGHT
NOW. INSTEAD OF DOING THAT
DETER THEM FROM AND MAKE THEM
UNDERSTAND THAT. HEY YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE GOT PLENTY OF ASSETS
AND SOME OF THOSE ASSETS ARE
GOING TODISAPPEAR. BY ACT OUT.
AT LEAST WE HAVE THAT YOU KNOW
WE WISH THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
THAT. BUT WE CAN'T FIX THAT FOR
THEM. WELL WE CAN FIX IS THE
PART WHERE THEY'RE ACTING OUT
OR AT LEAST WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
DETERRENTS TO THAT. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOUR BILL IS AFTER
HERE. AND AND YOU KNOW FOR ME
THAT'S WHY I'M SUPPORTING IT IS
BECAUSE WE NEED THAT DETERRENT
BECAUSE WHAT ELSE IS THERE
OTHER THAN TO GO IN AFTER THE
FACT. AND CLEAN UP THE MESS AND
WE'RE TIRED OF CLEANING UP THE
MESS. THANK YOU. ELECTRIC THANK
YOU KNOW JUST HOW I'LL BE VERY
QUICK BECAUSE I. I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR DRESSING A VERY
BIG PROBLEM IN THE COUNTRY
TODAY. AND THAT IS THERE'S TOO
MUCH HATE AND I THINK THAT'S AN
ARGUABLE. I THINK THAT- PEOPLE
ACTING OUT ON THAT HATE IS
BECOMING MORE ACCEPTABLE TO
MANY AREAS. AND I THINK THAT.
ANY MEASURE. THAT DISCOURAGES
THEM ACTING OUT. IS TO BE
SUPPORTED AND I AS LONG AS
THERE'S GUARDRAILS AND THERE'S
A SENSE OF REASON THAT. YOU'VE
ALREADY ARTICULATED THAT YOU'VE
THOUGHT THROUGH THAT AND YOU
YOU PRESENTED HERE- THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH WON'T WORK IN ALL
INSTANCES. BUT IT WILL HELP.
ADDRESS A VERY VERY TOXIC
SITUATION THAT EXISTS TODAY SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. SO I
PERSONALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHARLIE I DON'T KNOW
WEEK- DIRECTOR SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU WANT TO DO WE
DISAGREED ON- BUT THE GREAT
THING IS WE GET A CHANCE TO.
WORK ON IT FROM. THIS POINT ON-
AND- I REALLY LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A FUND.
THAT WHAT WHAT OUR COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OR TALKING
ABOUT HOW DO YOU GET. TO START
RETRAINING. I USE WERE
REPROGRAMMED BECAUSE IT IT
SOUNDS BAD. BUT HOW DO YOU. GET
PEOPLE TO BE A LITTLE MORE
SENSITIVE. ABOUT THIS REALLY.
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE. RIGHT
NOW NOT ONLY YOU KNOW AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FROM NOW. FOR
FOREVER- PEOPLE OF YOUR STATE
TO BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT. AND
NOW THE API COMMUNITY OF. RACE
ARE RACIAL HATRED HAS NO ONE
RACES NOT ALL WHITE PEOPLE HIS
BLACK PEOPLE WITH ERRORS
LATINOS HAVE MADE WE GOTTA WE
GOTTA GET RID OF HATE. BOB
KIRBY OR FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET TO THE ROOT OF IT SO WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD SO- AGAIN I THANK
YOU FOR. HOPEFULLY JOINING ME
AS WE MOVE FORWARD UP UNTIL
NEXT YEAR. THAT WE COME UP WITH.
MMHM BUT A DECENT HATE CRIMES
BILL OR A DOMESTIC TRRORIST
BILL WE DO WE JUST NEED TO ALL
COME TOGETHER SAID ROE. ABOVE
CITED A TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT
SO THAT CHAIRED RECOMMEND ANNA
FISHER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN. THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY
MOVED AND SECONDED AB TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER CHILD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI GENSER IRAQI
PACKY I PARA QUE HAN ERA CAN I
WORK. WHITNELL SANTIAGO. C. R.
TARA ARTS THEATER I WICKS WE-
MEASURES OF COFFEE ONE MORE
VOTE THANK YOU. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. AND THEN MISSED
CERVANTES AYE. WHICH IS MISS
MARKING HIM. I MIGHT I GOT
MYSELF A BIT ROCKSTARS ARCADIA
RICHARD NIXON. OKAY YOU MAY BE
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
HUNDRED. UNDER CURRENT LAW
DEFENDANTS IN CUSTODY. FACING
FELONY CASES ARE GENERALLY
REQUIRED TO BE PERSONALLY
PRESENT DURING TRIAL OR
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION.
HOWEVER IN CERTAIN INSTANCES A
TRIAL CAN PROCEED IN THE
DEFENDANT'S ABSENCE. WHAT AFTER
THE TRIAL OR PRELIMINARY
EXAMINATION HAS COMMENCED IN
THEIR PRESENCE AND QUOTE THANK
YOU- THE PROBLEM OCCURS WHEN
THANK YOU WHEN DEFENDANTS IN
CUSTODY ARE NOT PRESENT FOR THE
COMMENCEMENT OF THE TRIAL OR
THE PRE- THIS HAS BECOME A
MAJOR ISSUE DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC- IT PUTS
JUDGES IN A PARTICULARLY BAD
SPOT. WHEN THERE'S NO TIME
WAIVER FOR THE FREE ONE MORE
FOR THE TRIAL BECAUSE THEY
EITHER HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
TIME WAIVER STATUTES- AND THE
ONLY WAY TO DO THAT THEY HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THE TIME WEBER
STATUTES THE ONLY WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO ORDER THE DEFENDANTS
TO BE- PRESENT WHICH REQUIRES
THE SHERIFF'S OF COURSE TO.
POTENTIALLY TRANSPORT THEM
AGAINST THEIR WILL WHICH KIND
OF PUTS EVERYBODY IN A BAD. BAD
SPOT SO WHAT AB SEVEN HUNDRED
WOULD DO IS IT WOULD ALLOW
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION OR
TRIAL TO PROCEED EVEN IF THE
TRIAL. OR PRE ONE HAS NOT
COMMENCED IN THE DEFENDANT'S
PRESENCE UNDER CERTAIN NARROW
CONDITIONS ONE THE DEFENDANTS
IN CUSTODY TO THE COURT MAKES
CERTAIN FINDINGS. INCLUDING
THAT THE DEFENDANT THERE'S
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
VOLUNTARILY CHOOSING TO NOT
APPEAR IN COURT. THREE THE
DEFENDANT MUST BE REPRESENTED
BY COUNSEL WHO'S PRESIDENT AND
FOR THE DEFENDANTS HAVE TO BE
INFORMED OF THEIR RIGHTS- I
WOULD NOTE THAT. THANK THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK ON
IT WE DID TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THESE A SHOW YOU
IN THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION. WHICH A-
STIPULATED OF WILL PUT INTO
STATUTE THAT. THE DEFENDANT
MUST VOLUNTARILY CONSENT AFTER
pUP FOR THIS TO BE OPERATIONAL-
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
HAVE JEFF RUBIN WITH CDA. I
BELIEVE HE'S- THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S SANTA CLARA COUNTY-
IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR RUBIN. YES HELLO
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AT THE I'M A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND I'LL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FOUR YEAH SHE-
SO DEPENDENT DO HAVE BOTH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AND STATUTORY
RIGHT. TO BE PRESENT IN COURT
DURING CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS. OF
COURSE HOW LONG HELD THAT
DEFENDANTS ME VOLUNTARILY WAIVE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
BE PREENT IN COURT. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT
COURT AT THE TIME TO
COMMENCEMENT OF TRIAL IN THE
NATION. HOWEVER UNDER THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE THE CALIFORNIA
STATUTES GOVERNING INDEPENDENT
CREDIT AND- FOUR DEFENDANTS
HELP VOLUNTARILY WAIVE THEIR
STATUTORY RIGHT TO BE PRESENT
IN COURT FOR TRIAL AND P. AX.
IT MUST BE PRESENT IN COURT AT
THE COMMENCEMENT OF THE TRIAL.
WELL YOU KNOW VETERANS WORSE
EVERY YEAR THERE ARE NUMBER
DEFENDANTS WHO DO NOT WISH TO
BE BROUGHT INTO COURT EVEN
BEFORE THE COMMENCEMENT OF
TRIAL WITH YET. BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE.
QUARTER CAUGHT A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE. IF THEY WANT TO
PROCEED BECAUSE THEY MAKE YOU
WITNESSES WHO WERE NOT MADE
AVAILABLE- BECAUSE FURTHER
DELAY DOESN'T THAT IF ANYONE.
THE COURT EVEN HAVE TO FOR THE
DEFENDANT FORCIBLY BROUGHT INTO
COURT WHICH IS DANGEROUS THE
PEOPLE BRING DEFENDANT THE
COURT AS WELL AS A DEFENDANT
HIMSELF. THEY MADE ME FEEL WAS.
FOR THEM TO BUY LIKE TO STAND.
AND A SIMILAR PROBLEM WHEN
PERSON IS WITH THE- IF YOU CUT.
AND DOESN'T WISH TO LOOK IN
COURT FIRST SPECIFIED. SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT PROVIDES A-
FIX. THAT'S ALL THESE ONGOING
PROBLEMS. WITHOUT TAMPERING
EXIST LAW GOVERNING WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN. WE NEED FAMILY.
PHYSICAL PRESENT IN COURT. AND
WISHES TO ENTER SUCH CONTRACTS.
THIS BILL WHICH THANKS TO
MODIFICATIONS REQUESTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WILL HAVE GREATER
PROTECTION THAN PROVIDED BY ANY
STATE. FOR INSURING A REPRESENT
THE DEFENDANT IN CUSTODY WHO
DOES NOT WISH TO BE PHYSICALLY
ATTRACTED THE COURT CAN WAIVE
THEIR PRESENCE. BUT ONLY AFTER
THEY'VE BEEN FULLY INFORMED OF
ALL THE RELEVANT RIGHT AND WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IF THEY CHOOSE NOT
TO BE PRESS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPER AGENT THE ROLE MINOR
BUT STILL IMPORTANT TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE PENAL CODE. AND
ALL WOMEN ON THE LINE YOU TAKE
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS BUT
I MIGHT BE ABLE TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHER. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WITHIN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES SEE NONE
ANY WITNESSES ON THE TELESCOPE
THE TELECONFERENCES SCREEN
SEEING NONE YOU MAY NOW OPEN UP
TO AB SEVEN HUNDRED CUNNINGHAM-
PEOPLE THERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANY HERE ANY WITNESSES IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO. ANY WITNESSES
ON IT. ON THE- TELECONFERENCING
SCREWED- ANY. AND OPERATE YOU
MAY NOW OPEN UP TO TELEPHONE
LINE. FOR ANY WISHES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK INOPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WHAT A LINE FOR SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER COULD NOT
YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. UNFORTUNATELY WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL'S
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED- FROM
THE ONLY WITNESS THAT THE MY
LAI TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS ARE
JUST MY NAME STRUCTURE. JUST
YOUR NAME INCOME AND YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. CHECK OUT
HERNANDEZ. APPLICATIONS A IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. NEXT
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE YOU MAY
CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND IF I NEGLECTED
TO SAY EARLIER WE ARE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES MINUTES AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
ACCEPTING MEMBERS CHAIRED.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S IN FULL SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE SO
GRACIOUS AS TO. ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER SO RECOMMENDED
I PUT. THANK YOU YES KALRA. THE
BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB SEVEN HUNDRED BY
THE MEMBER CUNNINGHAM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY LACKEY I PARA CAN PARA
QUE HAN HI QUIRK QUIRK HI
SANTIAGO SAY ARE TELL ALL RIGHT
C. R. TELL HI WICKS. WE. BILLS
OUT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THIS POWER QUE HAN-
WHICH WE YOU KNOW WHAT SENT YOU
THERE LET'S DO BOTH YOU COULD
START WITH- AB SIX TWO FOUR
POWER CAN'T. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ON AB SIX TWENTY
FOUR A TECHNICAL BE HUGELY
IMPACTFUL. PROCEDURAL BUILDING
WILL HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT ON THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH
IN OUR STATE. SECOND OUR SYSTEM
THE FOCUS IS JUSTLY ON
REHABILITATION IS CENTERED ON
WHAT IS BEST FOR THE YOUTH AND
POSITIVE OUTCOMES IN SOME CASES
THE PROSECUTION MAY ARGUE THE
HEARING THERE YOU'D BE
TRANSPORTED TO ADULT COURT
FOREGOING THE JUVENILE COURT
PROCESS. CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS
SIXTEEN HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
DAHLE CORE FACING LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. STATISTICS SHOW THE
BLACK AND BROWN YOUTH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SENT TO
ADULT COURT WHETHER WHITE
COUNTERPARTS ARE MRE OFTEN
ALLOWED TO REMAIN IN JUVENILE
JURISDICTION. BY STAYING IN
JUVENILE COURT YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO A PROCESS THAT IS
REHABILITATIVE AND EDUCATION
FOCUSED. SHOPPING LATE
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO RIGHT TO
APPEAL THE DECISION WHAT DO YOU
THIS FORCED INTO ADULT COURT
ONLY DISCRETIONARY RIPPED IT IS
OFTEN SUMMARILY. DENIED AND NOT
REVIEWED ON ITS MERITS. THE
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY DOES NOT
HAPPEN THIS PROCESS BUT AT THE
CLEAR PATH REVIEW OF THESE
TRANSFER DECISIONS. AB SIX
TWENTY FOUR CREATES AN APPEAL
PROCESS FOR THE DECISION TO
TRANSFER YOU TO ADULT COURT. IT
ALSO REQUIRES TO BE DONE IN A
TIMELY MANNER AS NOT TO DELAY
THE USE RIGHT TO A SPEEDY
TRIAL. THE BILL IS IN LINE WITH
OUR VALUES TO DO WHAT IS TRULY
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THESE
YOUTH AT A PIVOTAL JUNCTURE IN
THEIR LIFE. AND WHAT CAN
CHARITABLY CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THEIR LIFE. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS BILL AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THIS IS A
MEANINGFUL WRITE. A REVIEW FOR
THE JUVENILES INVOLVED. WITH
EACH H. TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT IS
JONATHAN LABEL WITH THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER AND
MERITS SO WHO WILL GIVE A FIRST
HAND ACCOUNT FOR THE NEED OF
HIS FELLOW. THANK YOU YOU MADE
TESTS FIVE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JONATHAN
WAHBA AND I'M A MANAGING
ATTORNEY WITH THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
AND I'M ALSO A BOARD MEMBER
WITH THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER THE SPONSORED
AB SIX TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS
ALSO KNOWN AS THE YOUTH CARE
PROCESS OCT. PJD SEES A
STATEWIDE PUBLIC INTEREST
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LEGAL
REPRESENTATION FOR YOUTH IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND TO ADDRESS
IMPORTANT JUVENILE POLICY
ISSUES. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN. ONLY A
JUVENILE COURT JUDGE CAN ORDER
AFTER HEARING THAT HE USED TO
BE TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HAS CALLED THE DECISION A
TRANSFEREE YOUTHS FROM JUVENILE
TO ADULT COURT. THE WORST
PUNISHMENT THAT THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM IS EMPOWERED TO INFLECT.
ARE YOU TO IS TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT THIS IS EXACTLY THE
SAME PUNISHMENT AS THE YOU TO
COMMITTED THE SAME CRIME. UP TO
LIFE IN PRISON. USER WAS
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT WILL
BE INCARCERATED IN THE SYSTEM
THAT FOCUSES ON PUNISHMENT NOT
REHABILITATION. TRANSFERRED
OVER DAHLE COURT- IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DESCRIBED IS
ALSO AN AREA FOR YOUTH JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT SEES SIGNIFICANT
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES.
TRANSFER USER OVERWHELMINGLY
YOUTH OF COLOR. FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND 1883% OF YOU
SUBJECT TO TRANSFER HEARINGS
WERE BLACK AND LATIN EXCUSE.
WHEN TRANSFER HEARINGS ARE
HELD. YOUTH OF COLOR ARE MORE
OFTEN FOUND UNSUITABLE FOR
JUVENILE COURT. THERE IS ALSO A
CONCERN THAT THE CLOSURE OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO ADDITIONAL
TRANSFERS AND EXACERBATE THESE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES.
DESPITE THE ENORMOUS
CONSEQUENCES OF THE TRANSFER
DECISION CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENTLY PROVIDES NO RIGHT TO
HAVE AN APPELLATE COURT REVIEW
THAT DECISION. THIS BILL IS A
MODEST TO COMMONSENSE REFORM
INTENDED TO CURE THAT
LONGSTANDING INJUSTICE SB SIX
TWENTY FOUR CREATE THE RIGHT TO
APPEAL THE TRANSFER DECISION TO
ENSURE THAT THE DECISION WILL
BE REVIEWED BY A HIGHER COURT.
THIS SYSTEM OF INTERLOCUTORY
APPEAL IS ESSENTIAL TO
DETECTING CORRECT- RONI'S
JUVENILE COURT RULINGS AND WILL
BRING CALIFORNIA'S PRACTICES IN
LINE WITH THE MANY OTHER STATES
THAT OFFER A RIGHT TO APPEAL.
THE PROCESS TODAY BETWEEN SIX
TWENTY FOUR CREATES WILL ENSURE
THAT THESE DECISIONS ARE MADE
CORRECTLY AND IN CONFORMANCE
WITH THE LAW. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MATHIS WITNESS.
WHAT GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
JONES SAWYER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARISSA-
AND I'M TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD.
I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING FAVOR
OF AB SIX TWO FOUR THANK YOU
FAIR PROCESS ACT WHICH WILL GET
YOU TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT
RIGHT TO APPEAL THAT DECISION.
AFTER STRONGLY ABOUT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE AT A YOUNG AGE MY CASE
IS CRAFTED TO ADULT COURT THE
COURT OF APPEAL REFUSED TO
CONSIDER MOCKTAIL. OF THAT
DECISION THIS IS MY STORY. I
WAS READING ABOUT CAN DO.
REFUGEES I GREW UP TO BE USABLE.
TO BELIEVE HOMELESS AND
MISGUIDED. WHILE OF COURSE
RATED I HEARD MANY INDIVIDUAL
TESTIMONY FROM OUR PEERS WATER
STARTED LIKE THIS LATE. LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD I GOT MORE
VOTER GUIDES IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN MY
LIFE. I WANT TO BE IN CHARGE OF
ATTEMPTED MURDER FOR
TROUBLESHOOTING. ALTHOUGH LOS
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOUGHT ATTEMPTED
MURDER CHARGES AGAINST ME IN
ADULT COURT. I WAS FACING A
LIFE SENTENCE. NOVEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN PROPERTY SEVEN PASSED
MY CASES SENT TO JUVENILE
COURT. THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FIVE INSURANCE FROM OCEAN. TO
RETURN MY CASE WINDOW COURT.
TWENTY THREE YEARS NOW FOR CASE
TO COME HEAR. I TOLD BECOME A
MEET OUR MY G. D. MY HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA. IF IT IS DAVID
TO ACHIEVE. I'M ONLY TWELVE
CREDITS AWAY FROM CHEAPER MY-
SEVERAL JOB AUTOMATION OF. HAS
SMARMY. AT THE TRASH. A
DIVISION OF JUVENILE ACT HAVE.
TO THEY HAVE PROGRAM TO REALLY
TO REHABILITATING. A FIVE HOW.
AND IT'S ALL WORKER. THAT HE
HAS THE DO SO HOW- OF WHICH OUT.
THE GESTURE MARKETS TO ADULT
COURT ANYWAY. THE COURT OF
APPEAL DO NOT A TO MY TO MY
APPEAL THEY SUMMARY THAT JUST
THE PETITION IS ABOUT. FORTY
FOR ME THE MENTIME. THE
LEGISLATURE PASS SB THIRTY
NINETY ONE WHICH ENDED
TRAGICALLY KILLING ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD AT THE TIME
OF THE OFFENSE. I WAS SENT TO
JUVENILE COURT SO THE PLEA DEAL
FOR THE OFFENSE AND WAS
RELEASED I WAS TWENTY ONE. I
HAVE BEEN IN JUVENILE HALL AND
WOOD COUNTY JAIL SINCE AGE
FIFTEEN. I AM NOW HOLD LITTLE
MY MOTHER STEPFATHER TO SOME
WORK EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
I HAD A CHANCE TO REFLECT MY
MISTAKES BUT THE SYSTEM WITH MY
WINNER SO SECONDS MISTAKES BY
TRYING. TO THROW AWAY A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD CHILD. ARE YOU
SURPRISED ACTUALLY FOR THIS TO.
ON AND REMEDY IS. THEREFORE OF.
IN FAVOR OF AB SIXTY FOUR THE
SPECIALIST NEXT. THANK YOU NOW
WITNESSES AND CHAMBERED IN. IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES
ON THE TELECONFERENCING SEEN
NONE NOW AB SIX TWO FOUR POWER
QUE HAN- NOW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE
LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWO
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVER TWO
LINES FOR EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NATASHA MINISTER ON
BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND
MARKUPS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY
SHARPER ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE FLIGHT NUMBER ELEVEN LORD.
NOT YOUR COMMANDED I'LL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WHICH PART.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. MARCO COURTS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
UNCLOG THE PORES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FIVE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
WASHBURN WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SHOULD SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADISONVILLE COP WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FIVE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU RIDE FOR NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT I'M NOT.
AND I THINK WHEN I PROVIDE
MENTAL COUNTY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I DO HAVE A
FEW OTHER DRINK YOU IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
COMMENT. OVERLAIN FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALKA LOS ANGELES L. U.
N. G. AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT COMMENTERS
FROM LINE FOR THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS GREG KADEL ON
BEHALF OF AN ISSUE JUSTCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE HAVE TWO MORE COMMENTS
THANK YOU JUST ONE MORE MOMENT
TO THE NEXT ONE. TWO SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER THE ANTI WOMEN BOND
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
WE DON'T YET HAVE AN OFFICIAL
SUPPORT POSITION BUT I DO WANT
TO PUBLICLY THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND HER EXCELLENT TEAM
AND YOUR EXCELLENT TEAM.
ELABORATION ON MAKING SIX TWO
FOUR WORKABLE AND EFFICIENT.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS A DEEPLY SHARE CAR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY I
DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LISTED DO WE HAVE ANY
ONLINE. OPERATOR. HE WISHES
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
SIX TWO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GOOD WE
HAVE ANY OPPONENTS HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. OKAY ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEMS PRETTY QUIET. GO
AHEAD ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR SPECT ASPIRIN
I'VE AT. OKAY CALL FOR THE
QUESTION PLEASE. THE BILL'S
BEEN PROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON EIGHTY SIX TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER BARRICADE
HAND THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. JACKIE ARE
LACKING I BARRICADE HAN HI PARA
QUE HAN HI CORK. CORK I SAN
DIEGO. CA ARE TEMP HI THERE
TELL AYE WICKS. LI LI I.
MEASURE PASSED REGULATIONS
THANK YOU. NEXT BILL WOULD BE-
AB NINE THIRTY NINE YEP. THANK
YOU AT THE THRESHER AND MEMBERS
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED
FAMILY BILL NINE THIRTY NINE
THE DENIM DAY ACT FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SABRINA CERVANTES
UNFORTUNATELY SHE'S OUT SIX I
WILL BE STEPPING IN FOR HER
TODAY. WILL BUT SHE WANTS TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS WHO ARE CO
AUTHORING A FAMILY MEMBERS
BOERNER HORVATH BURKE CORREO
GARCIA ELORANTA GONZALEZ IRWIN
PETRIE-NORRIS AND QUICK SILVA.
SO YESTERDAY ON THE FLOOR WE
CELEBRATED FERGUSON CELEBRATE
WE- HONOR DENIM DAY WHICH TALKS
ABOUT THE FACT THAT A
SURVIVOR'S MANNER OF DRESS
SHOULD NOT TO BE EVIDENCE OF
CONSENT IN A SEXUAL ASSAULT
CASE EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE SIGNED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THAT RESOLUTION.
AND YET IN OUR LAW AS IT STANDS
TODAY WHAT THE VICTIM WAS
WEARING CAN BE ADMITTED INTO
EVIDENCE IF IT IS QUOTE UNQUOTE
IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE. AND
I WAS THERE BECAUSE I FIND IT
HARD TO BELIEVE THEY WOULD EVER
BE AN INSTANCE WHERE WOULD BE
IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE TO
ADMIT SUCH EVIDENCE. WE HAVE
ALREADY DECIDED TO YOU COULD
NOT ADMIT. WHETHER THE VICTIM
AND THE- PERPETRATOR WERE
DATING- IN AMERICA
RELATIONSHIP. YOU CANNOT ADMIT
WHETHER THE PERPETRATOR IS
USING. CONTROL DEVICE YOU
CANNOT ADMITS THE SURVIVOR
SEXUAL HISTORY AS EVIDENCE.
I'VE CONSENT AND YET IF THE
VICTIM IF SOMEBODY WANTS THE
VICTIM'S CLOTHING TO BE
ADMITTED AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT
A HEARING IS HELD OUTSIDE OF.
THE JURY TO DISCUSS WHETHER
THAT IS IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE AND I WANT TO PAUSE
RIGHT THERE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS THAT MEANS YES THE
JURY LEAVES THE ROOM BUT THE
VICTIM. MUST SIT THERE AND GO
THROUGH WHAT HERE SHE WAS
WEARING IN ORDER TO DECIDE
WHETHER IT IS APPROPRIATE
EVIDENCE OF CONSENTS. FOR EVERY
ONE THOUSAND SURVIVORS IN THE
U. S. ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY REPORT SEXUAL ASSAULT.
OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
ONLY EIGHTY CASES ARE TRIED IN
OF THOSE EIGHTY ONLY FIVE
PERPETRATORS WILL EVER SERVE
TIME. FIVE OUT OF ONE THOUSAND
PERPETRATORS SERVE TIME FOR THE
SEXUAL ASSAULTS THAT ARE
ALLEGED. AND YOU KNOW MATH
TELLS US THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF US KNOW SOMEONE WHO IS THE
VICTIM VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND YOU KNOW WHY HOW DID YOUR
FRIEND IN COLLEGE WHO WAS THE
VICTIM OF DATE RAPE. AND SHE
WENT TO THE AUTHORITIES INSTEAD
OF GOING TO PRESS CHARGES SHE
WAS SAID SHE WAS TOLD WELL
THEY'RE GONNA DRAG YOU THROUGH
THE MUD IT'S GOING TO BE YOUR
WORD AGAINST HIS. AND SO ALL OF
YOU CAN GUESS WHAT SHE DID SHE
DIDN'T PRESS CHARGES. AS MOST
VICTIMS DON'T. AND THEN I HAVE
A DEAR FRIEND WHO WAS RAPED ON
HER WAY TO WORK. DRAGGED INTO
AN ALLEY IN THE EARLY MORNINGS
AND RAPED BY A STRANGER. AND
NOT A FRIEND OF MINE GOT
JUSTICE. THAT BECAUSE IT WAS A
STRANGER THEY WERE BROUGHT THEY
FOUND THE PERSON AND THEY WERE
BROUGHT TO TRIAL AND SHE GOT
JUSTICE EVERY VICTIM OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT DESERVES JUSTICE AND
WHAT WE HAVE DONE WITH THIS. IS
A TO SOME VICTIMS YOU BETTER
THINK TWICE BECAUSE WHAT YOU
WERE WEARING MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED EVIDENCE IN THIS
CASE. AND THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE WE SITTING HERE TODAY
NO THAT WHAT THE VIC WAS
WEARING DOES NOT GRANT CONSENT
EVER. IT IS ONLY THE PERSON WHO
MAY GRANT OR WITHDRAW CONSENT
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
AND SO WITH THAT. I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE WITNESS WHO
IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
PARDEE ALEXANDER U. S. AND
VETERAN U. S. NAVY VETERAN AND
A CAMPUS SURVIVOR ADVOCATE AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
IN SAN BERNARDINO. SHE BRINGS
OVER EIGHT YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
THIS FIELD AND SHE WILL TESTIFY
AS PART. JONES SAWYER AND BY. A
LACKEY IN MEMBER. MY NAME IS
COURTNEY HOW. COMMON IN EIGHT
AND I'M A CO. TO SURVIVOR AT
THE AT CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSITY
IS. NINETY OVER MY EIGHT YEAR
TO MAKE. WORKING IN AVERAGE. I
HAVE SEEN A COMMON THEME INVEST.
WAS ATTEMPTED THAT PROVIDE.
AFTER HANNAH HUNDRED SURVIVOR
INTO THAT SUCH AS FOR THE PART
OF DEFENSE BECAUSE CAMPUSES
SUPPORT HEALTHCARE I HAVE
BECOME WITH THIS. USED TO
CREDIT FOR IF YOU TO ACT OF.
SOME OF THE MOST STRATEGIES I
HAVE SEEN ARTS ABOUT THE
SURVIVOR SEXUAL HISTORY.
QUESTION HOW COULD CONSENT WAS
IMPLYING THE ON THE FIFTH
BECAUSE. THEY ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED AND ARE MET WITH
SKEPTICISM AND EVEN SOMETIMES
DISBELIEF. AFTER REPORTING EVEN
LESSER VIRUS CONTINUE WITH THE
CASE ENTIRETY YOU KNOW HOW
GRUELING THE PROCESS AND- AS AN
ADVOCATE I AM PRESENT WITH THE
VIRUS YOU EACH STEP OF THE K.
RIGHT IN THE SUPPORT THEY
WANTED SOME OF THE LOWEST
MOMENTS OF THEIR LIVES.
INVESTIGATIONS INCLUDE SURVIVOR
HAVING THEM NOW CHEN TOLD WHAT
TAKING INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
EXAM FOR EVIDENCE AND EVEN
BEING PHOTOGRAPHED NAKED. RIGHT
CAN OFTEN TAKE HOURS YOU CAN BE
VERY HUMILIATING AND
TRAUMATIZING. AFTER DEALING
WITH THREE KIDS THURMOND
EXPECTED TO GREEN LED THE
ASSAULT OVER AND OVER IT MADE
TO THE FANS THEMSELVES THEIR
ACTORS ARE PICKED APART. LESS
THAN 5% OF RATE CASES THAT A
REPORTER FALL. WHICH MEANS 95%
OF RATES ARE TRUE. WHAT'S THE
MATTER IS THAT ONLY 34% OF THE
CELLS ARE EVER RECORDED. THE
MOBILE I RESPECTFULLY AND
VIOLENCE. THE ONLY WAY TO COME
BACK WITH OUR REPENTANCE
REPORTING IT TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE AROUND HOW WE TALK
ABOUT AND DEAL WITH ALL. OF OUR
NOT UNFAIR TO BE INVESTIGATED
AND THEIR COURAGE TO BE A PART
OF IT. THE PROBLEM WITH
CONSIDERING FIRING CLOTHING AS
EVIDENCE THAT THE PERCEPTION OF
HOW APPROPRIATELY OR
INAPPROPRIATELY FEMINISTA
BERRIES BASED ON WHO THAT
PERSON IS. ONE PERSON MAY BE
TIGHT ROUTINES APPROPRIATE AND
CUTE. ANOTHER PERSON MAY SEE
THOSE SCENES AS AN APPROPRIATE
AND ASKING FOR IT. THE
TYPICALLY THIRD NO TREND AND
WHAT WOMEN ARE WEARING THAT'S
ALL. THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THE USE OF THE VICTIMS
OUTFIT AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT.
BOTH FORMAL LIKELY TO BE
ASSAULTED ARE ACTUALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR. THOSE OF LOWER SOCIO
ECONOMIC CLASS. HOMELESS ADULT
WOMEN AND HOMELESS LGBTQ ARE A
PLUS YOU. WHEN ASKED WHAT THEY
WERE WEARING LAUTECH TATTERED
CLOTHING OVERSIZED- LAYERED
CLOTHING AND DID NOT PAID
REGULARLY. WHY CONGRESS FOR
VIOLENT VICTIMIZATION OF THE
HOMELESS WOMEN IS 97% MAKING
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND NORMATIVE
EXPERIENCE FOR THIS POPULATION.
THE WAY SOMEONE IS DRESSED DO
NOT MAKE THEM. MORE OR LESS
LIKELY TO BE ASSAULTED SO
CONSIDERING CLOTHING IS JUST
ANOTHER WAY OF SHOWING
SKEPTICISM. PROVIDERS RATHER
THAN BELIEVING. WE'VE GOT OF
THE WHAT THE WHEN IS WEARING
CONSENT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
PIECE OF CONVENTIONAL CUT. BY
QUESTIONING WHAT SURVIVORS
WEARING WE'RE APPLYING THAT
WITH SOMEONE WEARING. IT AND IT
DID NOT. SOMEONE CAN BE NAKED
AND SAY NO TO SEX. SOMEONE CAN
BEGIN HAVING SEX IN THE- THEY
NO LONGER WANT TO CONTINUE. AND
ONE COMPLAINT IS TAKING AWAY
THE SEX IS NO LONGER CONSENSUAL
EVER SURVIVOR DOES NOT GIVE
CONSENT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THEY'RE WEARING WHEN THEY WERE
ASSAULTED. EIGHTY NINE THREE
NINE IS TIMELY AND NECESSARY I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK REGARDING AB. NINE
THREE NINE. OKAY THANK YOU. DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT. YES SIR. OPERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER HAVE A GOOD
TWO ELECTIVES PRESS THERE-
SUPPORT. RABIA. NINE THIRTY
NINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I HAVE ABOUT SIX
IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR THE FIRST COMMENT. AND
WE'RE GOING TO LINE FIVE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DON BAND AND I AM A STUDENT
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. I MISSED THE PART OF
THE BILL. THIS IS HOW CONSENT
JUST NOT LIKE. YES INSTEAD OF
BLAMING THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
CLOTHING WE NEED TO REFLECT ON
THE PATRIARCHAL AND COLONIAL
HISTORY AND HAS BEEN. SET UP
LETTER TO THE NORMAL BODY
OBJECT CATION WITH COMPLAINING
AND THE CULTURE OF
INTIMIDATION. AND WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED TO PASS
THIS BILL A. B. NINE THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BRIAN THREE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DR RAYMOND KIM
FOUNDER OF ASIAN AMERICAN GUN
OWNERS CALIFORNIA WE A WE
SUPPORT AB- NINE THREE. NINE
THREE NINE- ON BEHALF OF ALL
RAPE VICTIMS THAT ARE NOW ARMED
WITH CONCEALED CARRY WEAPONS
PERMITS WHICH ARE SHOWN TO
REDUCE RATES BY 35% INCREASE.
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JOANNE SHEARER ON
BEHALF OF FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER THANK YOU RAIMES FIVE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE OH
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
FIVE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHELLE THOMAS SHOT
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY DO YOU HAVE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN THE CHAMBER
HERE. K. OPPOSITION I THINK WE
HAVE MARGO GEORGE ON THE LINE.
OPERATOR. RIGHT IS RIGHT. THANK
YOU- MARCO GEORGE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION FIRST LET ME SAY
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
RECOGNIZES THAT HIS
LEGISLATION IS AN ATTEMPT TO
DEAL WITH THE SEX INCIDENT
OUTDATED STEREOTYPES ABOUT
WOMEN'S CLOTHING SOMEHOW
INDICATING THAT THEY HAVE
CONSENTED TO BEING SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED. HOWEVER WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB NINE
THREE NINE BECAUSE IT ADVOCATES
THE TRUTH AND EVIDENCE RULE IS
NOT NEEDED BECAUSE OF THE GUARD
RAILS ALREADY IN PLACE AND
WOULD POTENTIALLY DENIED THE
DEFENDANT'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO CROSS EXAMINE AND
CONFRONT THE WITNESSES AGAINST
THEM IN SERIOUS CASES WHERE THE
DEFENDANT IS POTENTIALLY.
FACING LIFE IN PRISON. AS
INDICATED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION EIGHT ALSO KNOWN AS
THE VICTIMS BILL OF RIGHTS. THE
INITIATIVE ENACTED THE RIGHT TO
TRUTH AND EVIDENCE IN ADOPTED
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION
PERTAINING SPECIFICALLY TO
EVIDENCE IN CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS. THE PROVISION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
PROHIBITS THE EXCLUSION OF
RELEVANT EVIDENCE IN CRIMINAL
CASES. EXISTING LAW PROVIDES
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO ADMIT
EVIDENCE IF IT IS RELEVANT AND
AN OUT LIAR CASE. IT REQUIRES A
SPECIAL HEARING. SOUTH SIDE THE
PRESENCE OF THE JURY TO
DETERMINE THE RELEVANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE AND EVEN UPON A
FINDING THAT THE EVIDENCE IS
RELEVANT THE JUDGE MUST STILL
DETERMINE. WHETHER TO ADMIT THE
EVIDENCE BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE
EXISTING LAWS CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION WHICH
REQUIRES THE ADMISSION OF
RELEVANT EVIDENCE IN A CRIMINAL
CASE. THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
THEIR INTRODUCTION OF
GOVERNANCE IN ALL CASES
REGARDLESS OF THE RELEVANT OR
WHETHER THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE
FAVORITE AT SUBMISSION. I WANT
TO SHARE AN EXAMPLE FROM A
LAWYER IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE HE TRY
SIX CASES. HE POINTS OUT THAT
AN HONEST AND REASONABLE
MISTAKE ABOUT CONSENT IS A
VALID DEFENSE TO RAPE CASES
IT'S KNOWN AS THE MAIN DAIRY
DEFENSE. IF THE YOUNG MAN
HONESTLY AND REASONABLY
BELIEVES THAT SEX WAS
CONSENSUAL CONSENSUAL HE SHOULD
NOT GO TO PRISON FOR LIFE.
DISTRIBUTION BILL APPLY TO
EXCLUDE EVIDENCE OF MANNER OF
DRESS EVEN IN THE MAYBERRY
SITUATION. YES IT DOES APPLY TO
THE MAYBERRY SAID DEFENSELESS
OFFER A HYPOTHETICAL. I
UNDERSTAND HOW DELICATE THIS
ISSUE AS AND THAT CONSENT IS
SACRED FOR ALL WOMEN INCLUDING
SEX WORKERS OF COURSE. BUT FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE SEX WORKER TRIES
TO GET ATTENTION ON A STREET
CORNER AND ADVERTISES. HERSELF
WITH HER CLOTHING FOR EXAMPLE
WEARING A TRENCH CLOTHES COAT
FLIPPING IT OPEN AND HAVING
NOTHING UNDERNEATH EXCEPT HER
UNDERWEAR SHOULD THAT NOT BE
RELEVANT IF SHE LATER LICENSE
CLAIM SHE WAS KIDNAPPED BY A
POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS. CUSTOMER
SHOULD THE ACCUSED BE PREVENTED
FROM OFFERING FACTS WHICH ARE
CLEARLY RELEVANT THIS BILL SAYS
THAT BATTLE AGAINST DOES NOT
MATTER. AND THAT FRANKLY IS
HORRIFYING WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NO VOTE ON EIGHTY NINE
THREE NINE THANK YOU. OKAY OUR
NEXT WITNESS WOULD BE KATHY
SURE FROM THE ACLU. YES GOOD
GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY SURE FOR
RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSE EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY NINE- WE OF COURSE
WANT TO SEE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT CHIEF JUSTICE BUT WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT DEFENDANTS
CHARGED WITH SEXUAL ASSAULT
ALSO CONSIDER JACKSON- I THINK
MAJORITY DONE- HAS SAID
EVERYTHING THAT I WOULD HAVE
SENT- AS TO THE SITUATION IN
WHICH- THIS KIND OF EVIDENCE
MAY BE RELEVANT AND MAY BE AN
INTERESTS OF JUSTICE- THOSE
INSTANCES ARE AS I UNDERSTAND
IT WHERE. IT IS DIFFICULT UNDER
EXISTING LAW FOR AN ATTORNEY TO
BE ABLE TO SHOW AT THAT HOW THE
VICTIM WAS DRAFTED IS RELEVANT
AND IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE.
AND IT'S RARE FOR EITHER SIDE
TO SEEK ADMISSION FOR THIS TYPE
OF EVIDENCE AND RARE FOR IT TO
BE ADMITTED WHAT JUSTICE
DEMANDS THAT THE EVIDENCE
SHOULD BE ADMITTED HOWEVER OUR
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE SHOULD ALLOW
THE JUDGE TO MAKE THAT CALL AND
UNDER EXISTING LAW. WE
RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR WE HAVE ANY
OTHER. PEOPLE WHO THIS PART
BILL THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THAT OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK YOUR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT NINE THREE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BLIGHTED FIVE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MISTER
MEMBERS FLYING CHANNEL
RIVERSIDE SHARE CERTIFICATION
ONE CARRYING A POLICE OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION REGRETFULLY WE WERE
UNABLE TO OUR VOICE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL EARLIER ENOUGH.
FOR DOING SO NOW THANK YOU. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE ANYBODY IN
CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE-
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS. THIS IS YOUR
TELL. SURE EXPRESSED SOME
COMMENTS ON IT- ACTUALLY I
THINK IT'S A GREAT BILL I THINK
IT'S HIGH TIME THAT. WE STOP
USING THE EXCUSE OF HOW HOW A
PERSON IS DRESSED AS SOMEHOW AN
INVITATION A. X. L. E. MATT
CONSENT TO BE ATTACKED AND
RATE- IS THE VERY PROTECTIVE
FATHER OF THREE DAUGHTERS- I
WOULD SURE LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR SO MAYBE WE CAN ASK
FOR LATER HE'S ACCEPTING CO
AUTHORS. BUT YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TALK
ABOUT HOW HORRIFYING IT IS- YOU
KNOW WHAT IT IS IT'S NOT HARD
IT'S WHAT IF YOU DON'T IF THIS
PERSON SAYS NOW IT'S TIME TO
STOP. THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT. AND AND I
UNDERSTAND ALSO THAT. YOU KNOW
SOME OF THESE TACTICS AND I
KNOW THE DEFENDERS DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS ARE THAT'S THEIR JOB.
BUT SOME OF THOSE TACTICS
INCLUDE TRYING TO PUT. IF THE
PERSON THAT'S THE VICTIM IN
SUCH A POSITION THAT THEY JUST
CAN'T STAND DOING CAN'T STAND
WHAT'S GOING TO BE DONE TO THEM
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO PROVE.
THAT SOMEHOW THIS WAS NOT
CONSENSUAL. AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT THAT
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THIS GETS
USED AND THAT'S FOR THE JURIES
TO FIGURE IT OUT. AND THAT'S
FOR THE AND THAT'S WHERE
DEFENDERS HAVE TO DO THEIR JOB.
BUT THIS PARTICULAR PART.
IRRITATES ME TO NO END- BECAUSE
EVEN IN THE CASE OF THE
PROSTITUTE I UNDERSTAND SHE WAS
TALKING ABOUT KIDNAPPING. BUT
IF THE PROSTITUTE SIDE TO SAY
NOW. IN THE GAME IS OVER. AND
AND YOU MOVE ON. SO SO ANYWAY-
I PLAN ON SUPPORTING THIS AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
AND THANK YOU WITH A RECORD K.
HUNT FOR A- FOR- STANDING IN
PLACE OF THAT SO WE COULD HEAR
THE BILL TODAY THANKS. FOR
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
LOOKS LIKE THAT'S A NO I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT- BEFORE I
LET YOU TO CLOSE IT I BELIEVE
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT IS IMPORTANT.
AND VICTIMS- DESERVE ADVOCACY
SO I TAKE YOU FOR HAVING THE
STRENGTH TO BRING FORWARD AND-
WITH THAT ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND I
JUST DO WANT TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION A FEW THINGS THE
OPPOSITION SAID IF YOU MIND. SO
OBVIOUSLY. THE CONSTITUTION
GIVES A DEFENDANT THE RIGHT TO
CROSS EXAMINE THEIR ACCUSER IN
THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE THAT
AND I WANT THAT TO BE CLEAR. IN
THE HYPOTHETICAL WAS GIVEN AND
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
MISTER SAY OUR TELL. IF THAT
WOMAN DID FLASH AND WAS ONLY
WEARING UNDERWEAR AND THEN.
MOMENTS LATER SAID NO. I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE SEXUAL RELATIONS
WITH YOU IT'S OVER. AND SO WHAT
SHE WAS WEARING NO LONGER
BECOMES EVIDENCE OF CONSENT.
NOW YOU CAN USE THAT ANALYZE
CLEAR. AS EVIDENCE TO. TALK
ABOUT THE VERACITY WHICH HE
SANG THE TRUTHFULNESS OF HER
TESTIMONY THIS DOESN'T STOP YOU
FROM DOING THAT AND I WANT THAT
TO BE VERY VERY CLEAR IT JUST
STOPS YOU FROM USING WHAT THE
VICTIM'S WEARING. FOR PURPOSES
OF CONSENT AND THE PROPOSITION
ALLOWS US TO EXCLUDE. EVIDENCE
THAT IS NOT RELEVANT THIS IS
NOT RELEVANT TO THE QUESTION OF
CONSENT BECAUSE CLOTHING DOES
NOT GIVE ANYONE THE RIGHT TO
SEXUALLY ASSAULT ANYBODY. AND
SO I THINK IT IS HIGH TIME THAT
WE DON'T PUT VICTIMS THROUGH
THIS HEARING THAT THE LAW
CURRENTLY ALLOWS. BECAUSE IS
THAT THE OPPOSITION SAID IN HIS
MAY BE THE CASE IT MAY HAPPEN
AT THE END OF THAT HEARING MOST
COURTS DON'T ADMIT THIS
EVIDENCE. BUT THAT HEARING IS
ENOUGH FOR US TO SAY. WE'RE NOT
GONNA PUT VICTIMS THROUGH THAT
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IBM. OKAY I- COULD
COULD THE MEMBERS PLEASE
RESTATE THE MOTION AND SECOND.
I JUST I MOVED A SECOND. AND
OUT OF THE SPIRIT OF
TRANSPARENCY THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDED. WELL YOU DON'T
START- YEAH IF YOU PLEASE CALL
FOR THE QUESTION. AT THE BILL'S
IMPROPERLY MOVED AND SECONDED
ON AB NINE THREE NINE BY SOME
MEMBERS CERVANTES THE MOTION IS
TO PASS JONES SAWYER. LACKEY HI
LACKEY I BARRICADE HAND.
BACKHAND I WORK CORK I SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I SAY ARE TOO HIGH
ZERO TWO I WICKS. LEE ADMISSION.
CONGRADULATIONS THAT MEASURE
PASSES. OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
AN EMPTY CHAMBER. JUST IN TIME.
NO ONE'S HERE. YEAH BUT IF I
GOT YOUR JOB FOR. GLORIA. TO
JUNE TWENTIETH NEXT OKAY MISTER
SO THE NEXT ONES ARE. AND WE'RE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS THAT'S CHU
AB. FOUR EIGHT ONE- CHIU AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE. THEN GIPSON
AB NINE FIVE EIGHT AND AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE. THEN- LEE
ACTUALLY WE KNOW WHEN AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX RODRIGUEZ
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BLANCA RUBIO.
YEP THEY DON'T SHOW UP. THEN
WHAT EVER MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE IS HERE WE MAY GO IN
THE NEXT. TWO MINUTE. WHICH ONE
OKAY- I'M SORRY ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN NO WHEN IS OUR
CONSENSUS JUSTIN CROSSETT ARK.
MY MAKE UP OF ONE ISSUES AB
THIRTEEN ONLY FUTURE ISSUES
HERE. ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN. AB
ONE TWO EIGHT ONE TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE BLANCA RUBIO. RIMAU
PROCEDURE PROTECTIVE ORDERS
MISS RODEO YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A FAMILY BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
THE COMING FOR OF THE ANALYSIS
AND THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
SEEKS TO AMEND THE PENAL CODE
SECTIONS RELATING TO
EXPUNGEMENT TO SPECIFIC TO
SPECIFY THAT THE DISMISSAL OF
THE CASE UNDER THOSE SECTIONS
WOULD NOT AUTOMATICALLY WE
BELIEVE A DEFENDANT FROM THE
TERMS F EIGHT UNEXPIRED TENURE
CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE ORDER
ISSUED IN THE CASE. THESE
TENURE PROTECTIVE ORDERS ARE
ONLY ISSUED IN CERTAIN SERIOUS
CASES SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
STALKING AND ELDER ABUSE. THE
ORDERS PLACE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN PROTECTING SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIMES. CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE NOT PUNITIVE IN
NATURE THEY ARE NON PENAL
RESTRICTIONS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT CRIMP CRIME VICTIMS.
THE BILL IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY DOES NOT
REQUIRED THAT THE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS REMAIN IN PLACE IN ALL
CASES IT MERELY PRESERVES G.
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. TO
TERMINATE OR MODIFY AN ORDER
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCE.
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND ENJOYS APART FROM
CRIME VICTIMS ADVOCATE ADVOCACY
GROUPS. I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU READY. ENTER
YOUR WITNESSES. YES I SHOULD
HAVE ON LESLIE YES CLIMB LA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ON
THE PHONE. YES HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M LESLIE KLEIN I AM I
AM AN ASSISTANT HEAD DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MOST RECENTLY
WITH THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
DIVISION. WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSORS AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE.
ATTACKED OF ORDERS ARE AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TOOLS USED
IN THE PROTECTION OF VICTIMS OF
CRIME PARTICULARLY IN CASES
INVOLVING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
STALKING. DUE TO THE INTRINSIC
ONGOING NATURE OF THESE
RELATIONSHIPS. IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHETHER THE INCIDENTS
AMOUNT TO A MISDEMEANOR OR A
FELONY ANY ACT OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CAN QUICKLY ESCALATE
INTO A VIOLENT FELONY INCLUDING
ACTS OF GUN VIOLENCE. I HAVE
CERTAINLY SEEN THAT HAPPEN IN
MY TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE. PROTECTIVE ORDERS
GIVE VICTIMS THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO KEEP THEIR ABUSERS
AWAY. A PROTECTIVE ORDER CAN
LITERALLY BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH. THE
BILL WE ARE PROPOSING DOES NOT
ADD ANY MORE RESTRICTIONS IT
SIMPLY CLARIFIES A VAGUENESS IN
THE LAW AS IT IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. COURTS ALREADY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY AND DISCRETION TO
ISSUE CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE
ORDERS UPON CONVICTION AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING.
ELDER ABUSE AND SPECIFIED SEX
CRIMES THAT ARE VALID FOR UP TO
TEN YEARS IN BOTH FELONY AND
MISDEMEANOR CASES. ALTHOUGH TO
CAN YOUR PROTECTIVE ORDER IS
MOST OFTEN OBTAINED AND FELONY
CASES THERE ARE SOME
MISDEMEANOR CASES WHERE A TEN
YEAR PROTECTIVE ORDER WAS
ISSUED. BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE CASES
INVOLVING MULTIPLE INCIDENTS OF
ABUSE PRIOR HISTORY OF ABUSE
FOR INJURIES THAT ARE QUITE
SERIOUS BUT JUST DON'T QUITE
RISE TO THE LEVEL OF A FELONY
CHARGE. IMPORTANTLY COURT HAD
THE JURISDICTION TO MODIFY OR
TERMINATE THOSE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS WITHIN TEN YEARS AFTER
ISSUANCE AND NOTHING IN THIS
BILL CHANGES THAT. CURRENTLY
WHEN A DEFENDANT MOVED TO HAVE
THEIR CASE DISMISSED UNDER
PENAL CODE SECTION TWELVE OR
THREE POINT FOUR TWELVE OH
THREE POINT FOUR EIGHT. ABOUT
THREE POINT FOUR B. OR IF
DISMISSED UNDER TWELVE OR THREE
POINT FOUR TWO FIVE NOTHING IN
THESE SECTIONS ADDRESSED HOW
THE COURT SHOULD HANDLE THE
ISSUE OF THE UNEXPIRED
PROTECTIVE ORDER. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT WHEN THE
DISMISSAL IS GRANTED UNDER ANY
OF THE SECTIONS OF THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER PRESUMPTIVELY
REMAINS VALID UNTIL ITS
EXPIRATION DATE FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE VICTIM WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME GIVEN THE
COURTS TO THE DISCRETION. TO
MODIFY OR TERMINATE THE ORDER
IF PRESENTED WITH INFORMATION
THAT WOULD JUSTIFY SUCH ACTION.
CURRENTLY WHEN THIS ISSUE
ARISES IT'S UP TO THE
INDIVIDUAL JUDGE AND HOW HE OR
SHE DECIDES TO HANDLE THE
ISSUE. IF IT EVEN ADDRESS AT
ALL. MANY JUDGES WILL APPROVED
A PROTECTIVE ORDER REMAINING IN
EFFECT MANY TIMES THE ISSUE WAS
NOT DISCUSSED AT ALL BUT THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER REMAINS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEMS LEAVING AND
DEFEND IT WITHOUT ANY INSIGHT
THAT HE OR SHE MAY STILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER. IN OTHER INSTANCES
COURTS MAY FEEL THAT THEY MUST
DISMISS TO PROTECT EXISTING
PROTECTIVE ORDER IF THEY
DISMISS THE CASE. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE GIVE THE COURT
GUIDANCE ON IT'S A STORY AND
PUT THE DEFENDANT ON NOTICE
THAT HE OR SHE IS STILL SUBJECT
TO THE ORDER. UNLESS AND UNTIL
THE COURT TERMINATE OR MODIFY
THE ORDER. IT FURTHER GIVE THE
VICTIM THE PEACE OF MIND TO
KNOW THE PROTECTIVE ORDER IS IN
PLACE. ANY SUGGESTION THAT THE
VICTIM COULD SIMPLY GET A CIVIL
RESTRAINING ORDER IF THEY
REALLY WANTED ONE IS FLAWED.
NAVIGATING THE COURT SYSTEM IS
A DAUNTING PROCESS TO MOSTLY
PEOPLE. AND IT FORCES THE
VICTIM TO HAVE TO RE LIVE THE
ATROCITIES THEY'VE ALREADY
EXPERIENCED WHILE HOPING AND
PRAYING THE JUDGE WILL GRANT IT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY AS
EXPRESSED TO ME BY A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR THERE IS A
FEAR THAT GOING BACK TO COURT
YEARS LATER WELL AS SHE PUT IT.
POKE THE HORNET'S NEST AND
REFOCUSED THE ABUSER ON THE
VICTIM. AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
HELPS ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT BEHIND TEN
YEAR PROTECTIVE ORDER LAWS
ISN'T PUT IN JEOPARDY BY
ADDRESSING THE BIGNESS
CURRENTLY FOUND IN TWELVE THREE
POINTS FOR. 12-1 THREE POINT
FOR A COUPLE OF THREE POINT
FOUR B. AND TWELVE OR THREE
POINT FOUR TWO FIVE. THESE
PENAL CODE SECTIONS WHICH ARE
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
EXPUNGEMENT FACTIONS HAVE NEVER
ELIMINATED ALL RESTRICTIONS.
EXIST FOR THE LIMITED PURPOSE
SUCH AS ALLOWING AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE CASE WAS DISMISSED THE
RIGHT TO SAY THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME WHEN
SUBMITTING A JOB APPLICATION.
BUT THOSE CODE SECTIONS AND
CASE LAW HAVE ALSO MADE CLEAR
THAT THAT THAT NOT EVERY
CONSEQUENCE OF THE CONVICTION
SHOULD DISAPPEAR. THE
INDIVIDUAL IS STILL BARRED FROM
OWNING OR POSSESSING A FIREARM
THEY MUST STILL REGISTER AS A
SEX OFFENDER IF THE CONDITION
REQUIRED IT. AND THEY MUST
DISCLOSE THE CONDITION IN
CERTAIN SPECIFIED SITUATIONS.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE COURTS
HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT NOT EVERY
RESTRICTION IS A LIMITATION OR
PENALTY LIKEWISE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE NOT INTENDED AS
PUNISHMENT FOR THE DEFENDANT
BUT AS PROTECTION FOR THE
VICTIMS. WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES INSIDE THE CHAMBER
FORTY TWO OH TWO. IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BLOCK
RUBIO WE NOW GO TO THE SCREEN
ANY WITNESSES SEEN NONE
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE FOR AB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE BLANCA RUBIO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE EIGHTY WATER PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND OVER TO LINE THREE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DR IN KIM FROM- ASIAN
AMERICAN GUN OWNERS A
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE ON THE OFF OF ALL
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE WHAT THE
WAIT MANY MONTHS TO GET A
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT AND HAVE
NO PROTECTIONS IN THE MEANTIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS
MICHELLE THOMAS SHARP
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPLYING FOR SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LIANNA LEWIS FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL
BRING IN- TO KATHY SURE ACLU-
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KATHY SURE FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION- WE
RESPECTFULLY NOT SUPPOSED AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. CALIFORNIA
HAS RECOGNIZED THE BENEFITS OF
ALLOWING CERTAIN OFFENDERS TO
PUT THEIR RECORDS BEHIND THEM
AND MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES BY
ALLOWING THOSE OFFENDERS TO
HAVE THEIR CONVICTIONS
EXPUNGED. AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
WHAT INSTEAD IN THE LIMITED
CATEGORIES OF CASES WHERE
EXPUNGEMENT IS AVAILABLE KEEP
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO PROTECT THE BORDERS UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CRIMINAL COURT FOR A PERIOD OF.
TEN YEARS IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE
ORDER TO REMAIN IN EFFECT. THE
KINDS OF CASES IN WHICH SUCH AN
ORDER CAN BE ISSUED INCLUDE NOT
ONLY FELONIES OR CRIMES OF
VIOLENCE. BUT ALSO MANY
MISDEMEANORS FOR EXAMPLE ALL
REGISTRABLE FACT AND- MOREOVER
A PROTECTIVE ORDER CAN BE
ISSUED NOT ONLY TO PROTECT THE
VICIM BUT ALSO IN SOME CASES
TO PROTECT THE WITNESS TO A
CRIME. COMPLIANCE WITH AN ORDER
THAT REQUIRES STAYING AWAY FROM
AN INDIVIDUAL'S NEIGHBORS
FRIENDS OR FAMILY MEMBERS MAY
POSE A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
THAT PERSON'S ABILITY TO
REINTEGRATE INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND BEGAN THIS. ORDER CAN WOULD
MEAN. THAT FOR UP TO TEN YEARS
DURING WHICH TIME HER NAME
UNDER. THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CRIMINAL COURT. AT UP BUT BOB
RECOGNIZE WITH INDIVIDUAL
DESERVE A SECOND CHANCE TO
START FREE OF THE CRIMINAL. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WHAT DID NINE
MANY VISUAL THAT CAN'T FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WITHIN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE- THAT SCREEN A
TELECONFERENCE IS GREEN IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE- OPERATOR
OPEN UP AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
BLANCA RUBIO FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SLIDE FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FOUR
EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE- MISTER SEA
OTTER. THERMOS RUBIO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
LIKE YOUR BILL SO MUCH. I WOULD
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON IF
YOU'RE ACCEPTING A CO AUTHOR HI
WELCOME AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. SAY YOU SEEN THEM.
YOU MAY THINK LAWS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE AND- THANK
MISS RUBIO FOR WORK OUR
COMMITTEE AND JUST THANK YOU
JUST. GETTING THIS DONE WHAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW. YOU
MAY CALL THE ROLL. THE BILL'S
BEEN PROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER IRAQI. MACKEY I
BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND I CORK
CORK I SANTIAGO. SAY OUR TOW
ARDS HERE TO HELP I WICKS.
WICKS I BELIEVE. I WE I. I'M A
VOTE. SEVENTY SEVEN AND A HALF
THANK ALEJO'S BECAUSE I AM
THRILLED ABOUT THAT IS WHY I
THINK YOU'RE TO PROCEED YOU'RE
WELCOME. MISTER GIBSON. YOU
HAVE TO BILLS ITEM NUMBER TEN
NINE FIVE EIGHT- PEACE OFFICERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT CLICKS AND IT
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE GIPSON JUVENILE
FACILITY STORAGE AND USE OF
CHEMICAL AGENTS AND YOU CAN
START WITH EVER ONE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO START WITH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN. WHEN YOU
MAKE SURE. HE GAVE THE CHAIRED
A COMMITTEE YOU- ONE TOLD ME.
TO START WITH- I GUESS FILE
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FIVE EIGHT. NINE FIVE
EIGHT YES. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET ME SAY THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO MRS
TO DETERMINES TO OTHER MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIVE
EIGHT. WITH SIX THE BAND POLICE
GAINES. ALSO KNOWN AS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALSO KNOWN AS CLICKS
EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE KITCHEN
TO THE CHAIR TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR HELPING STRIPPING AND
MAKING THIS BILL BETTER. AND
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AS MY AMENDMENTS THIS BILL ALSO
MAKES AN OFFICER PARTICIPATING
IN A POLICE CLICK SUBJECT TO
TERMINATION. I WOULD JUST HIT
THE HIGHLIGHTS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR THE MOTION.
WHEN YOU SPEAK UP PLEASE REFORM-
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
LOOK AT IT FROM A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE LANDS. AT THE
VERY BASIC LEVEL EVERY SINGLE
LAW ENFORCEMENT APARTMENT
SHOULD PROHIBIT THE
PARTICIPATION OF. OF ANY AND
ALL KINDS OF POLICE OFFICER
CLICKS IN IT OUTSIDE OF THE
WORKPLACE. HOW CAN WE EXPECT
OFFICERS TO UPHOLD THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND TRUST. IF HE OR SHE
AND THE COMMUNITY. IS PART OF
OR PURSE BEING PERSUADED TO
JOIN AND BE PART OF A
DEPARTMENTAL CLICK. AS A POLICE
OFFICER IF THEY REFUSED TO JOIN
IF YOU HAVE OFFICER WHO'S
REFUSING TO JOIN MOST OF THEM
ARE OSTRACIZED LACKS SUPPORT
FACE RETALIATION ACCORDING TO
THE REPORT BY THE LAW LOYOLA
LAW SCHOOL THERE IS A LONG
HISTORY OF IN LOS ANGELES
OFFICERS FORMING SECRETIVE
CLICKS. AT STATIONS IN MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. THE REPORT. ALLEGE
UNDERSCORE LEADS UNDER LEADS
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS OF
ACTIVITIES AMONG EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT CLIQUES. AND THAT THE
IMPACTS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
SOME OF THEM HAVE MATCHING
TATTOOS HAND SIGNALS A RITUAL
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO A CRIMINAL
STREET GANG LAST YEAR A DEPUTY
SHERIFF WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SAY
HE WAS PUT. HE WAS PUT UP- HE
HAD TO PUT UP FIVE YEARS OF
BEING BULLIED INTIMIDATED BY
MEMBERS OF A GANG OF DEPUTIES-
IF THE COMPTON SHERIFF'S
STATION KNOWN AS THE
EXECUTIONERS. THIS IS A RECORD
BUT I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF. I'M SURE ALEX
BEING AVAILABLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE FIRST POLICY
IN HISTORY OF THE DEPARTMENT
THE BANDIT GANGS AND SECRETIVE
SOCIETIES. ALLOWING A CULTURE
OF POLICE CLICKS TO CONTINUE IS
AN IMPEDIMENT TO BUILDINGAND
PRESERVING TRUST BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE IS ALSO A
DANGER IN. OUR REPUTATION
DAMAGING THE REPUTATION OF GOOD
POLICE OFFICERS IN THE STATE IF
THIS CONTINUES THE CONCERN IS
THAT THESE CLICKS FOSTER A
CULTURE. THAT IS RESISTANCE TO
PLEASE REFORM SUCH AS COMMUNITY
POLICING. THEY DO SO TO
ENCOURAGE. THESE CLICKS ALSO-
TO RATE THEM TO A BOTH THE
BOTTOM THEY CREATE A VERY
AGGRESSIVE TACTICAL APPROACH.
USE OF EXCESSIVE FORCE AGAINST
AGAIN MINORITY COMMUNITIES THIS
BEHAVIOR IS NOT BEHIND
UNDERSCORE NOT BEHIND OFFICERS
OF MISCONDUCT BUT THIS IS A
CRITICAL AREA TO REFORM POLICE
CULTURE WITH IN DEPARTMENTS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT A PROACTIVE
ROOTING OUT BAD APPLES AB EIGHT
NINE FIVE EIGHT WILL ENSURE THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE-
POLICIES IN PLACE TO TERMINATE
ANY OFFICER WHO THEY FIVE OUTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN A WOEFUL
PROMOTION ILLICIT ACTIVITIES OF
POLICE CLICKS. JOINING ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY.
HIS ATTORNEY RYAN HARRISON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND FOLLOWING HIM
WOULD HAVE LIEUTENANT BRAND IT
HELPS WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
THEY WILL SELL PRODUCE AND ALSO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT HIS BODY MAY HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN YOU CAN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YOU CAN BEGIN
TESTIFIED. SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON MY NAME IS RYAN HARRISON
I'M A BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
LAWYERS. WE REPRESENT OVER SIX
THOUSAND ATTORNEYS LAW STUDENTS
LAW PROFESSORS AND JUDGES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO I'M A FORMER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WITH A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FROM SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY WHERE I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS CHAIR. OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DEPARTMENTS COMMUNITY
ADVISORY BOARD. CABLE IS
FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON PROMOTING
THE RULE OF LAW AND CONFIDENCE
IN OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM. I'M BUT
WE CANNOT DO THIS EFFECTIVELY
UNTIL WE HAVE A GOOD LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ON THE
STREET. AT ITS CORE THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF DIRTY
COPS. AND THEIR ENABLERS. TO
PROMOTE JUSTICE. AND TO PROMOTE
PUBLIC TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND GOVERNMENT. ON OCTOBER
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY I JUST
FIVE REPORTS WERE COMMITTEE ON
POLICE REFORM IN A HIGHLIGHTED
THIS CENTRAL ISSUE OF. CLICKS
ARE GANGS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES I SPOKE AT LENGTH
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF COPS BENDING
THEIR BADGES AND CELEBRATING
TWO HOMICIDES IN THE CITY OF
VALLEJO. I SPOKE ABOUT THE
ISSUE AND THE LOS ANGELES
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WITH ALL
THE PROLIFERATION OF GANG
MEMBERSHIP IN GANGS AND
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR THURMOND AND
HOW THIS HAS BEEN THIS ISSUE
HAVE BEEN. HAVE BEEN. ADDRESS
I'M SUGGEST WE WERE FOR MANY
YEARS AND CONTINUES TO BE
ADDRESSED AND THIS LEGISLATURE
CAN HELP WITH THAT ISSUE WITH
THIS BILL. BILL BILL THAT
ESSENTIALLY THREE THINGS FOR
THE FIRST IS THAT IT REQUIRES
AN AGENCY TO MAINTAIN A POLICY.
OF THAT- PROHIBITS
PARTICIPATION AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT CLICKS. AND MAKES
THE GROUNDS FOR THAT VIOLATION
OF POLICY- TERMINATION OF
EMPLOYMENT- THE SECOND THING IS
THAT IT- REQUIRES AGENCIES TO
DISCLOSE- THIS TERMINATION OF
EMPLOYMENT- TO ANOTHER AGENCY
CONDUCTING A BACKGROUND CHECK
ON A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
THAT LOST HER JOB AND THE THIRD
THING IS THAT IT IS QUALIFY THE
OFFICER FROM HOLDING OFFICE AS
A PEACE OFFICER OR OTHERWISE
ACCEPTING EMPLOYMENT AS A PEACE
OFFICER INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA-
THE CRITICAL OF FOCUS OF THIS
BILL IS ON THE DEFINITION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT CLICK- WHICH
ESSENTIALLY IS- A GROUP OF
OFFICERS ENGAGED IN A PATTERN
OF ROPE ON DUTY BEHAVIOR. THAT
VIOLATES THE LAW OR FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES OF PROFESSIONAL
POLICING AND IT IT INCLUDES
EXAMPLES OF WHAT THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR IS. SECTION THREE
SUBSECTION TWO- IT PROVIDES
PATENTLY CLEAR EXAMPLES OF
DIRTY COP BEHAVIOR- CABLE
STANDARD PORT OF THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS-
AND WE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATURE
IN HELPING TO CREATE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT REGIME THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTRAST THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CONTRAST.
THAT INSPIRE AMONG FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED THE BELIEVE
THAT GOVERNMENT IS THERE TO
FACILITATE THEIR LIVELIHOODS
AND THEIR VITALITY INSTEAD OF
CHALLENGING IT. I'M GONNA
REMAIN ON THE LINE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT TO
CARE MEMBERS LANDED UP ON THAT.
RENDON UP ON BEHALF OF BUT HERE
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHETHER AS
MAINTENANCE THERAPY IN A WAY
THE THICKNESS ZERO TOLERANCE
STANCE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE COMMUNITY. FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE DEPARTMENT'S
HISTORY L. AST HAS IMPLEMENTED
A POLICY THAT ADDRESSES
MISCONDUCTBY CLIQUES AND CLUBS
ALONG THE DEPARTMENT TAKE
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION AGAINST
EMPLOYEES ENGAGE IN THIS TYPE
OF BEHAVIOR. THE DEPARTMENT'S
ENACTED ALL PEOPLE DEPUTY TO A
HIGHER STANDARD THE RELEASE THE
MISCONDUCT BY DEBBIE COLLECTS.
THE DEPUTY VIOLATES THIS NEW
POLICIES THE CORRECTIVE ACTION
WILL RANGE FROM SUSPENSION TO
TERMINATION OF EMPLOYMENT.
EUROPEAN A WAVE US TAKEN A
LEGAL AND PROCEDURAL STEPS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
HOLDING OUR EMPLOYEES
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE RULE OF LAW.
WILL NOT TOLERATE ANY GROUP OF
EMPLOYEES THE MYSTERY ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY. OR
ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE TO ADOPT A POLICY
PROHIBITING PARTICIPATION IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT CLICK. ON
PROVIDED IT IS GROUNDS FOR
TERMINATION FOR PEACE OFFICER
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
AND WILL FULLY PROMOTE. FURTHER
OR STEP THE CLICK IN ANY
ILLICIT ACTIVITY. AND FOR THESE
REASONS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I THINK- I LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THE MEETING TEAM
I CAN PICK. A BETTER TEAM
INTERESTED FILL I THANK THE
COMMON GIPSON GIPSON AS WELL.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU- I THERE ANY
WITNESSES WITHIN. FORTY TWO OH
TWO. SIGNON ARE ANY WITNESSES
ON THE TELESCREENS
TELECONFERENCE GREEN SEEN NONE
NOW WILL OPEN UP TO- PHONE UP
FOR AB NINE FIVE EIGHT GIPSON-
AT&T MAY OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY NINE FIVE THIS PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST PANEL COME FROM LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARGO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CONNECT COMMENT IS
FROM LINES FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS LI AND I
LIVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO. AND
EVERY SPENT ELEVEN YEARS UNITED
STATES ARMY LET ME TELL YOU
BEING THE ONE OF THE VERY FEW
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN THAT HAVE
DEALT WITH A LOT OF. SORRY NEED
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU ARE
YES- MEDIATION I'M JUST I'M
JUST I'M JUST A MOM AND A
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO. I
JUST WANTED A SUPPORT THIS- AB
NINE FIVE EIGHT- YOU. TOO TO
STOP POLICE GANG THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU GROUP. ONE NOW
BRING IT TO. ANY OPPOSITION I'M
LOOKING AT THE LIST I SEE NONE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION- WILL GO
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY
TWO- TO. NOT SEEN ANY AND I'LL
GO TO THIS DISCREET ART THE
TELECONFERENCE SCREEN ARE THERE
ANY. IN OPPOSITION. AND NOW
OPERATOR YOU CAN OPEN UP
OPPOSITION AB NINE FIVE EIGHT
GIPSON YOU CAN OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE. I WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE FIVE
IT IS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MAKE NO COMMENTS IN
Q. THANK YOU WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THIS IS
ZERO FOUR. FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON FOR BRINGING THIS
I HAD SOME INITIAL CONCERNS
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW BEING FIRED
LAW ENFORCEMENT I THINK MR
LACKEY AND MYSELF ON OF THIS.
YOU KNOW YOU GET ASSIGNED TO
SHIPS AND THEIR SHIFT SOMETIMES
ARE YOU KNOW YOU DEVELOP CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU WORK WITH ANY EVEN DO
THINGS OFF DUTY AND I WAS A
FIVE IT'S CONCERNED INITIALLY
THAT. THAT TYPE OF THING AND
THEN BEING FOCUSED. I MEAN
BEING. YOU KNOW HAVING PATTERNS
OF ARRESTING PEOPLE FOR CAR
THEFT OR WHATEVER ON DUTY
COULD. TAKE SOME ATTORNEY COULD
PUT ALL THAT TOGETHER AND USE
IT AGAINST THEM BUT I THINK
YOUR BILL IS NARROW ENOUGH AND
IT REALLY. FOCUSES IN ON THE-
THE CRIMINAL PART OF THIS AND
THAT MAKES IT A GOOD BILL AND-
SIDE INTEND TO SUPPORT IT AND-
THANK YOU FOR. BRINGING IT
BECAUSE WE ARE ALL CONCERNED
ABOUT ENSURING THAT. THESE
AGENCIES HAVE A CLEAN SHOPS.
AND THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
MAKE SURE IS THIS PEOPLE LISTEN
TO THESE. THEY MIGHT GET THE
IDEA THAT THIS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S PER VALENT
AMONG ALL DEPARTMENTS AND IT
REALLY ISN'T- I KNOW PLENTY OF
DEPARTMENTS WHERE- DID DID
MEMBERS THEMSELVES WOULDN'T PUT
UP WITH THIS. AND THAT IT THERE
IS A THERE IS THOSE IN IT A LOT
OF TIMES IT'S A- MUCH LARGER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
PROBLEMS KEEPING A LID ON THIS
TYPE OF THING. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS AND
ADDRESSING. IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING. OKAY YOU HOME
AND TO REQUIRE MR LACKEY. YEAH
FIRST OF ALL. LET ME SAY THAT-
OBVIOUSLY TRUST NEEDS TO BE
BUILT BACK IN THIS IS A
REASONABLE APPROACH TO THAT.
AND AND MY TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL I NEVER. WAS AWARE. OF
THIS BUT I'M NOT SAYING IT
DIDN'T EXIST. RIGHT AND SO THE
GOOD POINT IS. THIS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES. THIS ROBLEM IN A
VERY VERY- REASONABLE WAY AND
WILL HELP READ. THE THE TOXIN
THE RESULTS FOR THIS KIND OF A-
GATHERING- COLLECTION OF IDEAS
AND- HURTFUL PEOPLE. SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING AFFORD THIS IS
A KIND OF A REASONABLE APPROACH
IT THAT WE NEED TO BUILD BACK
TRUST THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING. OKAY ANYMORE COMMENTS
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT WAS MADE THUS
FAR- THIS IS A VERY PROACTIVE
APPROACH AND CERTAINLY THANK.
THE L. A. COUNTY SHERIFF- ALEX
BEEN A WEBER. FOUR ONE-
SPEAKING ONLY TRUTH TO POWER
BALLS OF STANDING UP HAS BEEN
EXAMPLE. SAYING THAT HE WOULD
NOT TOLERATE- THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR. AND THE L. A. COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I THINK
THIS WOULD BE A AGAIN AN
EXAMPLE. FOR ALL DEPARTMENTS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN IT'S A WAY
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE- MAKE IT
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE FOR BAD
APPLES TO BE IN THIS
PROFESSION- THIS PROFESSION WHO
HAS BEEN PAINTED BY WITH A
BROAD. BRUSH AND HOPEFULLY THIS
IS THE WAY TO TRY TO RESTORE
TRUST AND FAITH BACK IN THE
COMMUNITY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I BOOKED. THANK YOU-
TEACHERS RECOMMEND AND I VOTE
AND I WANT THANK MISTER GIBSON.
OF NOT ONLY FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL BUT ALSO I THINK IN YOUR
STATEMENTS- YOU MADE IT VERY
CLEAR. THAT NOT ALL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS PART OF THIS
WEBSITE AND I COMMEND YOU. FOR
SETTING THE RECORD STRAIGHT AND
THAT YOU REALLY WANT TO GET TO
THE CORE OF THE PROBLEM. WHICH
IS THE BAD APPLES THE SOURCE
SAID THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YEARS RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE.
THE BILL FROM HER MOVED
SECONDED ON A. B. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. HI JONES SAWYER
HI BLACKIE. BLACKIE AT A
BARRICADE HAND CORK. HIGH COURT
I SANTIAGO C. R. TELL HI THEY
ARE TOO HIGH WICKS. LI LI I.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW ITEM- NUMBER
ELEVEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
GIPSON JUVENILE FACILITIES
STORAGE AND USE OF CHEMICAL
AGENTS AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ELEVEN OF SIXTY FIVE
WHICH SEEKS TO BAND- TEAR GAS
IN JUVENILE FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO ALSO THANK
THE STATE COALITION OF
PROBATION ORGANIZATION FOR
WORKING WITH ME- AND MY OFFICE-
AND THE COALITION WE WERE UP TO
ONE. AM THIS MORNING WORKING
AND MAKING SURE THIS BILL IS
PRESENTABLE TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WE HAVE WORKED
OUT AN AGREEMENT WITH SCOPA AND
WE HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS AND I
WILL BE- THINK THOSE AMENDMENTS
YOU SHOULD ALREADY HAVE- I'VE
INTRODUCED ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BECAUSE BANNING I'M
TEAR GAS FROM THESE FACILITIES
IS A MATTER OF RACIAL JUSTICE
AND RESTORING THE DIGNITY FOR
YOUTH LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
TEAR GAS INSTANTLY MAKES IT
HARD. FOR A PERSON TO BRIEF
CAUSE INTENSE PAIN AND IS EVEN
MORE DANGEROUS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC COLBECK NINETEEN ANY
USE OF TEAR GAS CAN FACILITATE
THE SPREAD OF COVERT NINETEENTH
BOTH WITH IN THE FACILITY AND
OUTSIDE WHEN COMPARED TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA
IS THE OUT LIAR THIRTY FIVE
OTHER STATES UNDERSCORE THIRTY
FIVE OTHER STATES DO NOT PERMIT
THE USE OF TEAR GAS AGAINST.
YOU IN JUVENILE FACILITIES.
THERE ARE ALREADY SEVEN
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED
BANNING THE USE OF TEAR GAS IN
THEIR FACILITIES INCLUDING
MARIN NAPA. SAN FRANCISCO SAN
MATEO SANTA CRUZ- SANTA CLARA
SO NORMAL AND- YEAH THEY THEY
HAVE THIS HEAVILY THIS HEAVY
USE OF THIS PEPPER SPRAY
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT OUR-
BLACK AND BROWN AND INDIGENOUS
YOUTH THESE YOU'VE COME FROM
HISTORICALLY. OPPRESSED I'M
COMMUNITIES AND ATTEND
UNDERFUNDED SCHOOLS LACK ROLE
MODELS AND LACK ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THAT THERE APPEARS
HAVE IN OTHER AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES TEAR GAS IS ALSO
USED IN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AGAINST YOU WITH DISABILITIES
MANY WHO ARE SURVIVAL'S WHO ARE
SURVIVING OF SIGNIFICANCE FROM
THE ACLU REPORT REPORT FOUND
THAT JUVENILE FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA USE. TEAR GAS AGENT.
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND TIMES
BETWEEN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN AND MARCH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. S. IS NOT
USED IN ANY OF THE NINE
JUVENILE CAMPS IN LOS ANGELES
IT IS ONLY USE INTO JUVENILE
HALLS IN LA. N. LA COUNTY HAS
OUR L. A. COUNTY IS A LARGE
JUVENILE POPULATION COMPARED TO
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE THIS
CAN BE DONE BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
DONE WITH THIRTY FIVE OTHER
STATES AND SEVERAL- CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. THESE LIFE
THREATENING CHEMICALS CHEMICALS
HAVE BEEN- REPLACED- AND HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING DE ESCALATION-
PROCESSES IN PLACE TO DE
ESCALATE SITUATIONS WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO HOW DO YOU
APPROACH YOUTH AND SITUATIONS.
THAT IS WHY AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE CALL FOR THE END OF THE
USE OF THIS AGGRESSIVE MEASURE
THIS PEPPER SPRAY THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
ENJOY TEN CO AUTHORS JOINING ME
TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
ALONGSIDE. ME IS EDGAR E.
BONTA- GOOD THEATERS THE-
LEADERSHIP- PROGRAM COORDINATOR
AND MR ALBERTO. TO RECALL
REPRESENTING SCOPA. J. WE'LL GO
WITH ON THE LINE FIRST AND THEN
MISTER TO RICO IF YOU DON'T
MIND DO WHO'S HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WITH THIS. THE DOLLAR
HELLO CAN EVERYBODY HEAR ME YES.
GOOD MORNING. FIFTY BOB THERE
IS. I'M THE LEADERSHIP BOB
ORDER ME PAUL A GREAT BURKE
BAKED MINOR AND YOU SEE DAVIS
BUT. I'M HERE ENTERED BACK AB
LIVING UP TO ON THE CHEMICAL
THAT DOES NOT. AS A YOUNG NOT
EARTH WITH THE PART ON THE- AND
MUCH WITH THE PUBLIC THEY COULD
COULD COME THANK A LOT THE CARD.
WHILE THERE WILL BE ABLE TO
THEM BY ACTING. ON MY REPEAT
ABOUT LIFT YOU MIGHT NEED. I
AREN'T THIRTY AMICUS BRIEF. WE
DIVISION OF WE'RE NOT FIFTEENTH.
AND THEY EIGHTY EIGHT IT WILL
BE AN UNDERDOG I WAS GOING AT
IT I THOUGHT MOST OF. I WAS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT. AND
HOW TO CONDUCT MY. ASSEMBLY
SHAKING SO IN ANGER FONG THE
EVERYONE MOTIVATING ACTIVE THE
YOU CAN. YEAH LIKE NOTHING AND
OTHER PEOPLE WERE SUPPOSED TO
ACT OF BEAUMONT THANKS WOULD
RESULT EXPERIENCE AT THE BY. I
WOULD COOPER. IT BUT NUMBER OF
THE- MY LIVING YOU KNOW THE
GROUP DISTURBANCE RESPONDED BY
ADMITTING THAT CANISTERS
WORKING WITH THAT CAN NINETY
FIVE MEDICAL FACILITY FREDDIE.
EVEN IF YOU WERE NOT. WE AND
PEPPER. OKAY WHO ARE. AND YOUR
READING READING AND LET ME IT
EASIER. AND BURKE. IT LIKE WAIT
MY IT YEAH A REP AND. OKAY WE
GET IT WE- IT CAN GET A BETTER
LINE BETWEEN PROBABLY MISS MOST
OF WHAT HE SAW. LET OUT. ARE
YOU FOR THAT ON THE BACK FROM.
THANK YOU CAUGHT HELLO YEAH
THAT SHOULD KEEP UP WITH THE
TWO MEET EITHER SO. HELLO YOU
MUST OF THE CULTURE LOOKING YOU
MIGHT ONLY GET MULTI YEAH RIGHT.
THE OKAY I WOULD HELP LAKE IT
CAN WHICH IT ON THE- UPDATE AND
BUT THAT NUMBER OF COACH. OKAY
AT LEAST DEVELOPED EIGHT. EIGHT
UP ONE UP DON'T WITH THE BETTER
EIGHT LOOK WHAT VERSION. ABOUT
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT CAN HELP. THE
CARD IS BEING PUT LONG ENOUGH
THE WHAT YEAH BUT TO OTHERS HE
WILL CHECK SENATE DON'T THANK
YOU. AND IF YOU CALLS BACK WE
CAN TRY TO HEAR FROM. OUR
MYSTERY GIRL WHO'S IN THE ROOM-
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. LET ME START BY
THANKING A SEVEN MEMBER GIPSON
HIS STAFF THE SPONSORS FOR. THE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND-
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE BILL AS AS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
RECALL. THIS SUBJECT MATTERS
BEEN FOR THE COMMITTEE AT LEAST
THREE TIMES THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IF NOT MORE. AND I'VE
BEEN I'VE I'VE REPEATEDLY COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. IN AN
ATTEMPT TO SUCCESSFULLY MIND
YOU- TO STOP THE PASSAGE OF
SIMILAR BILLS. AS WE HAD THE
CONVERSATION THIS YEAR YOU KNOW
IT STRUCK THE MEMBERS OF THE
FECKLESS PROVISIONAL INNOVATION
THAT. THAT SOMETHING HAD TO BE
DIFFERENT THIS TIME. WE HAD TO
WE HAD TO FIND A BETTER WAY TO
DEAL WITH THESE KIDS QUITE
FRANKLY AND I THINK THAT- WHEN
THE SPONSORS AND- THE
REPRESENTATIVES COOPER MYSELF.
CAME TO THE REALIZATION THAT WE
ALL CARED ABOUT THE SAME THING
WHICH WAS BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
THESE. YOUNG PEOPLE AND- IN
CUSTODY I THINK. THAT REALLY
SET US ON OUR WAY. THE ELEMENTS
OF THE AGREEMENT I THINK TRY TO
BALANCE SEVERAL FACTORS FIRST
AND FOREMOST WITH THE SAFETY.
OF NOT ONLY THE JUVENILES BUT
THE STAFF IN THE FACILITIES.
ONE OF THINGS THAT WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IN THESE
FACILITIES IS. WHENEVER THERE'S
A FIGHT. THE STOPPING RACHEL'S
IN CALIFORNIA ARE INADEQUATE
AND I THINK THE SPONSORS AGREE
WITH THEM THAT'S WHEN THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL AND I
THINK AUTHORS STAFF ALSO WOULD
AGREE. WITH YOU MORE PEOPLE ARE
MORE STOP THEIR TO BILL A BREAK
UP FIGHTS QUICKER. THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO OFFICERS
IN JUVENILE FACILITIES ARE ARE
VERY FEW. AND OF A BREAK THE
FULL FIGHT BREAKS OUT NOT ONLY
TO STOP FURTHER IN A PART OF
TEN. KIDS IN THE TWO KIDS ARE
IN A FIGHT. THE TO STOP FOR A
JOINT. YOU HAVE EIGHT KIDS-
UNSUPERVISED. IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
A IT'S NOT A RECIPE FOR A GOOD
OUTCOME. AND ITS POTENTIAL FOR
ESCALATION OF THE VIOLENCE. THE
THING THAT I WOULD SAY THAT WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
FACT THAT. PROBATION OFFICERS.
DIFFERENT FROM RECORD FACULTY
THE PREACHER IF THEY ENTER THE-
PROFESSION. BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE IN REHABILITATION AND
REENTRY. AND THEY WANT IT WHEN
THEY WANT THESE KIDS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AS A RESULT OF THAT
I BELIEVE THAT. A LARGE NUMBER
OF WOMEN INTO THE PROFESSIONS
PROFESSIONALISM LARGE NOT NONE
OF THEM WORKED IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES. IN FACT MANY OF THE
GIRAFFE TOYS ACROSS THE STATE.
OVER. 50% OF THE OFFICERS AS
WOMAN. THE WOMAN. MANY OF THESE
WOMEN ARE SHORTER IN STATURE.
FIVE FOUR THREE FIVE FOUR GOING
TO HEAR FROM ONE OF THEM I
THINK LATER OF FOR LOCAL SIX
THIRTY FIVE. AND THE CHALLENGE
BECOMES IF YOU HAVE- YOU KNOW
OF IT INTELLECTUALLY A CHILD
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OR OLDER.
BUT PHYSICALLY THEY COULD BE
VERY IMPOSING SIX FOOT THREE
TWO ONE FOUR BUT I'VE SEEN THEM
I'VE VISITED I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE BECOMES A VERY
PRECARIOUS SITUATION SO WE TRY
TO BALANCE THE INTERESTS OF
THESE OFFICERS THESE BRAVE
OFFICERS THAT DO THIS WORK. SO
WE BELIEVE WE CAME UP WITH A
COMPROMISE THAT MAKES SENSE WE
WERE INCREASING STAFFING RATIOS
AS OF JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WE ARE BANNING THE
USE OF ALL CHEMICAL AGENTS. YOU
KNOW TEAR GAS WAS MENTIONED
REPEATEDLY. AS OF JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND WE ARE
DELAYING THE BAND OF PEPPER
SPRAY FOR ANOTHER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO GET THE L. A. ON
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
BEST PRACTICES NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT AROUND THE
COUNTRY. BEFORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A OF A BAND
OF PEPPER SPRAY AND FINALLY I
WOULD SAY THAT THE ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST CONCERNS WAS THE
MASSIVE CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA COMING
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS IT PERTAINS
TO EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS. IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS ALL EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLDS WILL BE HOUSED IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES. THAT IS AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT POPULATION
IT'S ENTIRELY NEW POPULATION AS
ALL OF YOU KNOW THE STATE IS
SLOWLY BUT SURELY NOT ONLY
GOING OUT OF GETTING OUT OF THE
BUSINESS. OF HOUSING. MINORS
UNDER EIGHTEEN BUT NOW THAT
THAT AGE LIMIT IS MOVED TO
TWENTY FIVE AND THAT'S BASED
ON. SCIENCE AND THE DEVELOPMENT
RATE SETTER WE DON'T DISPUTABLE
REDUCE WE DO BELIEVE IN THE
AUTHORS AGREED. AND THE
SPONSORS AGREE TO THE CREDIT.
THAT THE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD MAYBE SHOULD BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY. AND IF THE
BAN ON PURPOSE THEY WANT TO
PLAY TO THEM. WITH THE WITH ALL
THE SAFEGUARDS. WE'VE DONE THE
BEST WE COULD. UNFORTUNATELY
MEMBERS I CAN'T GUARANTEE THESE
OUTCOMES. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IS FACILITIES AND
I'M SCARED. I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU. I'M SCUTTLED CAN HAPPEN
WITH THE WOMEN. AND MEN THAT
WORK IN THESE FACILITIES. BUT I
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE PROCESS
BRING THE BEST PROCESS HAVE
COME FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
LOOKING AT THIS MAKING SURE WE
HAVE THE BEST OUTCOMES WERE
PROTECTING THE BEST INTERESTS.
OF NOT ONLY THE KIDS THAT ARE
IN OUR CUSTODY. BUT OUR
OFFICERS THAT BRAVELY. GO TO
WORK EVERY DAY AND WANT TO
CHANGE THEIR LIVES. SO ALTHOUGH
YOU HEAR FROM OTHER PROVISIONAL
CONCESSIONS THAT ARE NOT
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. I
RESPECT THAT. THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION BECAUSE
OF THE TOUGH TOUGH CALL BUT-
I'M HERE TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE APPRECIATE DAUGHTER SUFFERS.
THE SPONSORS EFFORTS. AND THE
FECKLESS PROVISIONAL
CONCESSIONS. WILL BE NOW IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION AS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND CAN WE OPERATE
LAST I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GOT A
BETTER LINE CAN WE BRING IN THE
FIRST WITNESS. TO SEE IF WE CAN
HEAR HIM BETTER. MR GUTERRES
YOU HAVE WHY DID OUR BACKEND.
HELLO YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME
DIDN'T IN A WORD THAT YOU'RE
TALKING HAS MUCH BETTER NOW IT.
THAT'S THAT'S MUCH BETTER
SORRY- FIRE FOR THAT PROBLEM IS
JUST YOU KNOW. COVALENT ROOMS
NOT THE BEST BUT A- I'M HERE I
REGARDLESS. OF BEFORE ANYTHING
LIKE TO LOOK AT THE ALLEY
QUALIFY YOU'LL WANT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHERRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THAT GETTING
BACK WITH THE UPDATE. ON THE
LEADERSHIP OF CHROME CORNER FOR
ME BY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION IN MONTEREY
COUNTY. AND ALSO UC DAVIS
STUDENT. AMERICAN CHURCHES
COMMITTED TO PASS LEVIN SB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE TO ELIMINATE.
CHEMICALLY DIDN'T JOIN UP TO
SEVENTY. I PERSONAL TERRIBLE
DECISION FOR HER K. IN THE- AND
I THOUGHT MYSELF THAT ONE WE
TICKET TO CAMANCHE THE COLOR.
CALL WELL THERE WERE ABLE TO
REFLECT ON MY- AND I DEFY. THAT
MY RELEASE THAT WOULD HELP TO
UPLIFT MY- TO UPLIFT AND HEAL
MY COMMUNITY. EXPERIENCE THE
HARMFUL EFFECTS OF CHEMICAL
SPRAY ONE CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE. AND ANY
TEENAGER EXPANSION PUBERTY AND
UNRESOLVED TRAUMA. I WAS GOING
TO BRING BACK THE SHIP IN MY
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT. I
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT A
MAN WAS AND HOW TO CONDUCT
MYSELF AS ONE. SEVEN SHAME.
GUILT AND ANGER FOLLOWED ME
EVERYWHERE. AND ONE MOTIVATING
FACTOR THE MAGNITUDE BEHAVIOR.
I WAS SPRAYED WITH OC FOR
DIFFERENT FACTIONS SUCH AS
WALKING OUT OF FORMATION COULD
TELL HOW MUCH THAT. NOT
SNAPPING MY FINGERS BEFORE
LEAVING MY IT LIFE EITHER
BETTER VIA. PHYSICAL
ALTERCATIONS AND BEING A
BYSTANDER DURING OTHER
DISTURBANCES. WITHIN THESE
MOMENT THAT AS A YOUNG PERSON I
COULD NOT UNDERSTAND HOW. THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE SUPPOSED TO ACT
AS ROLE MODELS ACCOUNTED. SHORT
SUCH EXTREME ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
I RECALL COULD IN. TO PLACE IN
THIS TWO. NINE MY LIVING UNIT
HAD A- THAT COULD DESCRIBE AND-
THE STAFF HAD RISK. BACK TEAR
GASSED. BRING WORK WORK. WHAT
M. CAIN NINETY FIVE OH FIVE AND
OTHER TYPE OF BOTH THESE PRE
WEAPON. EVEN IF YOU'RE NOT PART
OF THE GROUP DETERMINED YOU
WERE SPRAYED. AND AFTER THREE
BLUETOOTH ADVANCED INSULTING TO
OUR SHEETS AND BLANKETS. WE ARE
FORCED TO SLEEP IN A DORM
SATURATED THE CHEMICAL THAT
MAKES PEOPLE EATING AND
DRINKING AND TERRIBLE.
INCIDENTS LIKE THESE HAVE
REMAINED IN THE GREEN TO MY
MIND AND MADE IT CLEAR THEY
WERE NOT. BEING THAT YOU.
PROVIDE THAT DONALD. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE THAT
CULTURAL SHIFT NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE THEN YOU CAN
INSTITUTIONS. THAT ARE MEANT TO
HELP REHABILITATE ENTERPRISE
YOUNG PEOPLE. PROTECT HAVE UPON
RETURN RETURNING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY. THE INCOMING CALL
TRICKLE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
PUNISHES YOUNG PEOPLE FORGET TO
COMPLETELY. REMARKS CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA IMPACTED BY CALL
GROUND BEEF. IN HUMAN NEXT YOU
FROM THE MOMENT THEY ARRIVE TO
WHEN I FACILITY. THIS RELIED ON
CALLED. A MODELING. WILL WHICH
MAKES DO. THE CARE GOT UNDER
ABOUT. BUT DID CAN'T TAKE PLACE.
BANKWEST IN. OF CULTURALLY
RELEVANT AND FEELING IN POMPEO.
FOCUSED ON LEADERSHIP AND-
HIRED YOU. OF VOCATIONAL. THAT
WILL OUR YOUNG. TO BE BETTER
PREPARED DEAL WITH THE- MONTH.
DEVELOPMENT TO GETREADY. TO
SUCCESSFULLY RETURN HOME.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO A BETTER
JOB TO TAKE CARE OF THAT A
BLACK AND BROWN YOUTH WITHIN
THE FACILITY AND THEY HAVE THE
MOST IMPACTED. AND VULNERABLE
TO CHEMICALLY TO. A PAIR DAY
SHIFTING WHICH WE CAN. WITH
ANOTHER A LOT OF TECHNICAL TO
AS WELL OUR YOUNG. TO HEALTH
YOU CAN MAKE. WITH EACH OTHER.
ADULT AND REINFORCED THE IDEA
THAT THE IDEA THAT WE-
CALIFORNIA CARE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN ABLE TWENTY APRIL.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE ANOTHER THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU NOW.
YOU'RE FROM PEOPLE. IN THE
AUDIENCE. SEEING NONE- ON THE-
CALVET CONFERENCING SEEN NONE
AND NOW WILL OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
GIPSON. FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIND FIVE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL BROAD ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WILL PROBABLY
CO SPONSORED THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE FIVE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY SURE FOR
A YOU KNOW YOUR CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WESLEY SAVER
ON BEHALF OF BLIGHTED PROD CO
SPONSORED A BI LEVEL SIXTY FIVE
I'M ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
AND LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON NDP SHARE CAR WITH
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE THE SAYS HANNAH BETH
ALL SIGN ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST
MENNONITE CHURCH OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
RIGHT THEN- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SIX CLASS THANK.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARGO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY.
THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS GREG SO
INITIATE JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
WITH MEREDITH THAT THE PROBLEM
WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES
NATASHA CAMANCHE DOWN TO HALF
OF THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER AND SIXTEEN
HUNDRED SIXTEEN HUNDRED OTHER
JUVENILE ADVOCATES AND
ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH.
THINGS LIKE FORTY- AGENCIES
CALLING INTO SUPPORT AS STRONG
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR
EVERYBODY FOR COMING TO- AT.
COULD COORDINATE OVER THE PAST
WEEK TO COME TO A RESOLUTION.
AND I HOPE EVERYBODY OUT
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR SEVEN ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL DROP AND
I AM A PROBATION OFFICER AND I
AM CALLING IN REGARDS TO AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE- READY ONE
FIFTY YEARS OLD NOW. THANK YOU
NINE ONE NINETY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RETURN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AYE TO ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I NEED TO ONE WHY NOT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE TWO
MORE LINES THINK UTILITY ONE
MOMENT TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
HELLO
WE DON'T. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT TO THE NEXT COMMENT.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NEWMAN WAS GOODNIGHT
A PROBATION OFFICER AND I
OPPOSE AB. ONE ONE SIX FIVE.
RIGHT FIVE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE-
INTIMATE FRIEND OF THE BAND
FROM GREECE KNOCKED THERE AND
BRAVE ONE APP VOTE NO ON AB ONE
SIX RIGHT THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
FURTHER I THINK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU NOT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE IS
SHANE LEVINE AND. PONTELAND FOR
THE- LAW SAYS PROBATION
OFFICERS UNION AND SHANE LEVINE
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS. ON THE PHONE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF THE
FUTURE MEMBERSHIP LEVINE I WAS
GONNA DEFERRED L. A. COUNTY FOR
THEIR ON. OKAY SO SHARE MEMBER
SHANE TO ME ABOUT THE SITUATION
ON COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS WHICH
REPRESENTS YOUR COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICERS- BUT ALSO
SHARPLY BENEFITS ASSOCIATION
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY WHICH
REPRESENTS THE CUTS THE
PROBATION OFFICERS OF SAMPOERNA
DINO. TO BE A PART FROM L. A.
COUNTY WERE TWO OF THE BIGGEST
PROBATION APARTMENTS IN THE
STATE. I PICKED UP REAL QUICK-
I JUST WANT TO SAY I ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH MR TO RICO WE TOO
ARE SCARED ABOUT THE OUTCOME.
OF POTENTIAL IS THE AS A RESULT
OF. YOU KNOW THE DISTILLATION
OF GOING TO MOVE FORWARD I
THINK A COUPLE POINTS OF
CLARIFICATION FIST- WHAT WE'RE
REALLY DISCUSSING HERE IS OC
SPRAY OR PEPPER SPRAY NOT
DEBATING AT LEAST ON OUR
BEHALF. TEAR GAS BUT TO
SEPARATE ISSUE FOR US THIS IS
SIMPLY ABOUT OUR OFFICERS
ABILITY TO CARRY PEPPER SPRAY.
TO DEFEND OTHERS OR THEMSELVES.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE TO THE POPULATION WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE IS.
PREDOMINANTLY HIGH RISK
POPULATION ALTHOUGH YOU
pALTHOUGH NOT IRREDEEMABLE.
ABOUT HIGH RISK SO FOLKS WHO
HAVE. GONE THROUGH THE SYSTEM
AND BED CONVICTED- FOR MURDER
RAPE ETCETERA- SO WE MUST
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE FOR ONE SIMPLE
REASON AND THAT'S JUST SAFETY.
FOR THE SAFETY OF THE JUVENILE
BUT THE PERSONALITIES AND THE
SAFETY OF OUR OFFICERS ARE
FACILITIES ARE BASICALLY STAFF
ANYWHERE BETWEEN 5270% BY
FEMALE OFFICERS. UNDER THIS
BILL WE'RE GETTING TO A PLACE
WHERE THESE OFFICERS WILL BE
LEFT WITHOUT ANY SAFETY RECORDS
OTHER THAN THEIR BARE HANDS TO
DEFEND JUVENILES BEING ATTACKED
IN THE FACILITY. FOR DEFENDING
THEMSELVES PROPER SPRAY AT THE
POLICY MAY ONLY BE USED WHEN
THERE IS AN IMMINENT THREAT TO
THE SAFETY. OR THE SAFETY OF
OTHERS AND ONLY ONE DE
ESCALATION EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
UNSUCCESSFUL OR NOT REASONABLY
POSSIBLE. UNDER ALMOST EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE UNLESS THERE'S
IMMINENT DANGER A WARNING IS
ISSUED OF COURSE PHRASE USED.
AND OFTEN THIS ONE ALONE IS
ENOUGH TO DETER OR STOP
PHYSICAL ALTERCATIONS. WE DO
NOT BELIEVE BANNING PEPPER
SPRAYS PRUDENT PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO VIABLE SAFE
ALTERNATIVE. THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSION TODAY IMPROVE RATIOS
IN THE FACILITY THAT'S A
LAUDABLE GOAL. ARE THERE YOUR
RATIOS ARE WELL INTENDED BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE SELDOM
FUNDED. IF THE REAL ISSUE HERE
IS MISUSED TO PEPPER SPRAY
WE'RE COMMITTED TO LOOKING OR
STUDYING THAT ISSUE. THAT
THERE'S A BETTER WHERE SAFE
AWAITING YOU THAT MUCH THAT
NIPPLE NOW IN BETTER WAYS. IN
ORDER FOR US TO CAN TO A PART
SAFETY. AND THE SAFETY OF
OTHERS YOU HAVE OUR- TO THAT
BUT IT OUT RIGHT BANS DOESN'T
WORK- FOR THOUSAND BOXER TO GO
EVERY DAY. TO PROTECT YOU CAN
PROTECT. OKAY THAT WE ASK OUR
NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AFP NONE OF. AND NOW. HANS LAN
PRESIDENT LOST HIS PROBATION
OFFICERS ARE YOU ONLINE. I
DON'T SEE THEM DIALED IT OVER
THE PHONE IF YOU ARE DIALED IN
PLEASE PRESS STAR. ZERO MARING
GO. ALL RIGHT IT INSIDE. ARE
THERE ANY ONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO SCREAM AT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. CNN AND WE'LL GO TO
PHONE LINES AND MAYBE HANS WILL
COME IN AFTER WE GO TO HE
PHONE LINES SO OPERATOR COULD
YOU OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE GIPSON.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS WIDE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIVE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS- SENIOR
DID SO ERIC WALTON WITH LOCAL
SIX EIGHTY FIVE- LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT-
THE INSTITUTION VICE PRESIDENT
FOR THE JUVENILE HALLS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THIS IS A
DANGEROUS BILL IT IS UNSAFE FOR
OFFICERS IT FINALLY I'M SORRY
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. ERIC
WALTON LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROBATION APARTMENT IN BRITISH
INVITE PREGNANT. THANK YOU FOR
AND AGAINST I GOT NEXT DAY
ORGANIZATION. AND THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M NOT A ROBOT
AND I AM A PROBATION OFFICER UP
WE'VE GOT LOYAL FOR EVERYONE'S
SAFETY ON AB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT FIVE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL HELLO MY NAME IS
LAWRENCE JOHNSON I'M A SENIOR
DELEGATE THE PROBATION OFFICER
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY AT
THE JUVENILE HALL CHINA OPPOSES
BOTH ON OUR JUNE BY OUR SAFETY
AND THE SAFETY OF THEM ALL USE
THAT WE SUPPORT AND A VOTE NO
ON AB. ONE ONE SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
LAURA SAID GOOD OFF ON BEHALF
OF MONARCH SERVICES IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THE- THANK YOU IDEA FOR
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT FOUR NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MINIMAL NO
SOME OF THE VISION OFFICER FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT FIVE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS
RANGE FROM OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OUR COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICERS WERE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE FOUR OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RAYMOND CORMIER I AM
A PROVISIONAL CENTS FOR EVERY
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ELEVEN SIX FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
FOR NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY IN FOUR NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT TO FIVE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KELLY
READ WITH KEEP CALIFORNIA SAFE
IN OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIDE FOR NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE ARE YES I'M A
PROBATION OFFICER FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ONE ONE SIX FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU I FIVE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRIAN
JOURNAL I'M A PROBATION OFFICER
FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE
VOTE NO ON AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FIVE
FIVE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARK OVER THE PROBATION
OFFICER ORANGE COUNTY BERMAN
FIFTY PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS STACY FORD L. A.
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT. ON
BEHALF OF ASKED ME LOCAL SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS IT IS WRITTEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY THREE FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T
MANUALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AT WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS WRITTEN BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE DEAL THAT
WAS REACHED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIDE FOR THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JASON BAKER PROVISIONAL
PERFORMED COUNTY BERMAN SAFETY
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB ONE ONE
SIX FIVE THANK YOU. LIGHTSOURCE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COMMANDER
FARA AND PROBATION OFFICER FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ONE SIX ONE ONE SIX
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE
FOUR OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND FOUR ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS A PROVIDER OF INFORMATION
OFFICER FOR EVERYONE FIFTY
THREE VOTE NOW ON EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIVE
EIGHT THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO RIGHT YES PLEASE. OKAY MY
NAME S JONATHAN BYRD IMAX
CORPORATION OF. THE COUNTY
TWENTY NINE YEARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT WORKING STRICTLY
WITH JUVENILES IN THE
INSTITUTION IN LIEU OF PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR BOTH THE CLIENTELE
AND STAFF SOME LEASES BILL CAME
YOUR INSTITUTION IN YOUR
POSITION. JOHN DONVAN BURKE
DEPUTY PROBATION OFFICER TO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CHIEF STEWARD
SECOND VICE PRESIDENT OF ASKED
ME LOCAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU. WINDS FIVE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARCUS WILLIAMS I'M A
PROBATION OFFICER IN CLEVELAND
SAFETY PLEASE VOTE NO ON THE
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
JEFF. THANK YOU I FOR THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GIVEN THE
CLEARANCE ON CONFIRMATION FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ONE ONE SIX FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN STRIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONIES BARNETT
IS WORRIED SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB. ONE TWO ONE SIX FIVE.
THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VICTORIA
BAMBERG I'M A PROBATION OFFICER
FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT FOR EVERYONE'S
SAFETY PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE FIVE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FOUR FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME TO THE
CROWN THAT EMBRACE AN OFFICER
FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY YOU VOTE
NO ON THE V. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE FIVE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON THE
CONFERENCE CALL WAS FOR
MULTIPLE TIMES BUT MY NAME IS
PRISCILLA MARTINEZ- WITH BUT
NOBODY OF THE MEALS AND I'M
ACTUALLY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIVE TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL I'LL BE A LOT MORE
POLLUTION OFFICER WITH ORANGE
COUNTY PROBATION FOR
EVERYBODY'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME TWO MILES ON
A PROBATION OFFICER WITH ORANGE
COUNTY PROBATION AND I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN VOTE NO ON AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LINE FIVE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAWANA
LEAD I'M A PROBATION OFFICER
FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE
VOTE NO ON. EIGHTY ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE
FIVE SIX OR HAD FORTY FIVE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GENET
YEAH I AM A PROFESSIONAL
OFFICER AND VERY LUCKY YOU
PLEASE VOTE NO ON A. B. ONE ONE
SIX FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE FOR SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS THAT IT'S ONLY GOOD MEN
REPRESENTING FAIRFIELD OF OURS
AND YOU BREAK IN MY DOT'S AND
KENDRICK WHITE I AND MY
PROBATION OFFICER WE ALL ARE
ORANGE COUNTY PROBATION FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID
MOORE I'M A PROBATION OFFICER
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON A. B. ONE ONE SIX FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I TRY FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DENISE HERNANDEZ PROBATION
OFFICER PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB
ONE ONE SIX FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARRIE
WILLARD ST A PROBATION OFFICER
AND FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIDE FOR NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MELISSA GOVERNMENTS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY PROBATION
FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE
VOTE NO ON AB ELEVEN SIX I.
THANK YOU RIDE FOR SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
WAS APPREHENDED PROBATION
OFFICER FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB ONE ONE
SIX FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SHAWN
EVANS AND I AM A PROBATION
OFFICER WHO WINS COUNTY- PLEASE
VOTE NO ON AB ONE SIX FIVE FOR
EVERYBODY'S SAFETY. THANK YOU
BYE THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A COOKIE
LA MAIL I'M WITH AFTER THE
LOCAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE AND
PLEASE PLEASE VOTE NO. THANK
YOU RIDE FIVE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ARGHA CM A PROBATION
OFFICER BYRD WAS SAFETY PLEASE
VOTE NO ON A. B. YOU HAVE A
FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I AM I AM
MY OWN RIGHT NOW. TO NEARLY.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS ELSA BUSING WAS LOW AND
I AM A RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO
AREA AND I JUST FELT STRONG NO.
FOR ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
UP AT THE COACHELLA ORANGE
COUNTY PROBATION ALSO ABLE TO
GET BOARD MEMBER I'M A
PROFESSIONAL DO SO PLEASE FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB. ONE ONE TWO FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIVE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LIZA ALCON TARA AND
I AM A PROBATION OFFICER AND A
MEMBER OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROBATION. AND LOCAL EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE AND AYE OPPOSED UP.
A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE YEAH
AND I ACTUALLY TALK TO THE
PEOPLE. NINE FIVE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD OPERATOR
KILOMETER LINE THEY WERE HERE
IDEA OVER THE SPEAKERS. AB IT
NEVER GAVE ME A NUMBER JUST
MOMENT WITHOUT DESKTOP WE GET
OUT OF THE LAND HOW WE NORMALLY.
ARE YOU STILL ON THE LINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE I'M. ALLIED FIVE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME AND IT LOOKS
LIKE OUR OTHER WITNESS TIMES IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. THANK YOU GREETINGS
MY NAME IS KHAN LEON I'M A
TWENTY THREE YEAR PROBATION
OFFICER AND PRESIDENT OF THE L.
A. COUNTY PROBATION OFFICERS
UNION ASKING LOCAL SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED PROBATION OFFICERS
HERE IN ALLENTOWN. I ALSO
SERVED NOT A MEMBER OF THE CITY
OF MONTEREY PARK I'M SPEAKING
YOU TODAY IN REGARDS TO EIGHTY
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE WHICH ARE
UNION STRONGLY UPHOLDS. FIRST
LET ME SPEAK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
SAFETY. AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
ONE DANGER THE YOUTH ARE
CUSTODY. THE CIVILIANS WHO
PROVIDE REHABILITATIVE SERVICES
INCLUDING COUNTY EMPLOYEES
TEACHERS. AND COMMUNITY AND
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE PROBATION PEACE OFFICERS
RESPONSIBLE. FOR PROVIDING
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. IN JANUARY
THIS YEAR A YOUTH COUNSELOR AT
WAY FINDERS FAMILY SERVICES IN
L. A. COUNTY. WAS ATTEMPTING TO
BREAK UP A FIGHT. WAS BRUTALLY
BEATEN TO DEATH BY SEVEN YOU
RESIDENTS. IS FEMALE CO
COUNSELOR REPORTEDLY SUSTAINED
A CONCUSSION TRYING TO ASSESS.
NEITHER AT OC SPRAY AND THE
PHYSICAL ATTACK COULD HAVE BEEN
QUICKLY DIFFUSE THE DOES HE
SPRAY WHETHER ACCESSIBLE. IN
ANOTHER CASE KABC CHANNEL SEVEN
LOCAL NEWS REPORTED THAT WITHIN
A THREE. MONTH PERFORMANCE
STAND POLITICALLY SAID
RESPONDED TO CALLS FOR SERVICE
AT THE- FLORENCE CRITTENTON
FACILITY FOR GIRLS A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TIME. WHEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SHE DID NO FEEL.
SAFE SERVICING THE RESIDENTS. I
UNDER NINETY TWO DJJ SO IT IS
ALSO A LONG NO LONGER NEW IN
CASE. MANIFOLD MELODIC AS WILL
USED. FOR HOUSING AND
SUPERVISING BEEZY BEEZ DJJ YOU.
IF AB ELEVEN SIX FIVE IS BY THE
GUY WE WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO
USE THE PEPPER SPRAY TO PROTECT
THESE COMMIT. TO CIVILIAN TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THOSE OF
US DEPUTIZED TO MAINTAIN ORDER
AND PROVIDING REHABILITATIVE
TREATMENT. WORKING OUT FOR US
HERE IN L. A. COUNTY IS THAT
50% OF THE STAFF THAT WORK IN
THE FACILITY YOU ARE FEMALE.
LOCAL THIRTY FIVE HAS BEEN IN
CONTINUOUS DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING THE SAFETY AND THE
JUVENILE HALLS AND CAMPS. AND
THE DOCTOR GIVING A RATIO
NEEDED TO PROTECT THE YOUTH IN
OUR CARE. THE CIVILIAN TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AND OUR
MEMBERS. THE SAFETY OF ALL WHO
WORK AND VOLUNTEER PROBATION
SERVICES. WE URGE YOU TO AMANDA
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE TO CONDUCT A
MEANINGFUL STUDY OF CURRENT
PROTOCOLS REGARDING OC SPRAY.
AND POSSIBLE ALTERNATIVES TO
ENSURE SAFETY OF ALL PARTIES
BEFORE AN OUTRIGHT BAN HAS BEEN
ENACTED. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE STUDY
INCORPORATE CURRENT POLICIES IN
SMALL MEDIUM LARGE URBAN AND
RURAL COUNTIES AS A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH MAY BE SUB
OPTIMAL. WE FURTHER RECOMMEND A
PILOT PROGRAM TO TEST THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF THE JUVENILES IN OUR
CHAIR THE TEACHERS SOCIAL
WORKERS NURSES MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND OTHERS ENTER
JUVENILE PROBATION FACILITIES
EACH AND EVERY DAY. AND THE
DEDICATED PROBATION PEACE
OFFICERS WHO WORK HARD TO
PROVIDE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
WE'VE GOT NINE ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT'S IT FOR OPPOSITION- NOW
WE'RE GOING BACK TO COMMITTEE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER SEA HER UP TO TALK ABOUT
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES. NEED TO
BEAT TOP AND BOTTOM- AND I KNOW
IT'S LATE AND I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
HERE A LONG TIME BUT- THESE
THESE HAVE TO BE EXPLORED SO I
APOLOGIZE THAT I'M ALWAYS
ASKING QUESTIONS BUT HERE'S MY
QUESTION. SO WITHOUT THE USE OF
THIS IS ONE OF THE METHODS OF
THE LESS THAN LETHAL FORCE OF
BREAKING SOMETHING UP WHAT'S
LEFT. HOW DO HOW DO THEY
CONTROL A GROUP OF TWENTY FIVE.
LARGE JUVENILES. I HAVE IN A
BRAWL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR QUESTION- ONE I WANT TO-
CAL RECOUNTS THIRTY FIVE OTHER
STATES HAVE BANNED THE USE OF
THIS SPRAY PEPPER SPRAY BEING
USED SEVEN. COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
BANNED IT BY UTILIZING OTHER
METHODS IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE
TO CONTROL THE SITUATION AND SO
WE LOOK AT THESE BEST PRACTICES
ALREADY BEEN IMPLEMENTED RIGHT
NOW. IT IS NOT OUR DESIRE
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THIS IS NOT
OUR DESIRE TO PUT ANYONE IN
HARM'S WAY. BUT CALIFORNIA'S
OUT LIAR CALIFORNIA HAS NOT LED
INTO SPACE. THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE OTHER STATES IN THE UNION
HAS ALREADY BANNED IT BUT
UTILIZING OTHER METHODS TO
CONTROL THE SITUATION WHAT ARE
THOSE OTHER METHODS THAT'S WHAT
I NEED TO UNDERSTAND. WELL SOME
OF THOSE MATH THAT SOME THOSE
METHODS ARE BEHAVIORAL MEET.%
OUR BEHAVIOR CONTROL- SOME OF
THEM ARE ABSOLUTELY- TESTING
AND SPEAKING TO THE U. R. RAISE
THEIR VOICES AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE- THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER.
LET ME JUST GET REAL QUICK I'M
USED IPAD TRYING TO USE THAT
PHRASE OF THE MODERN TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US- TODAY.
WE HAVE YET THEY HAVE USED AND
I DON'T. SEE IT HERE IN MY
NOTES PROBABLY MORE THAN HAPPY
TO GIVE YOU THE INFORMATION
THAT WHAT THE OTHER THIRTY FIVE
AND THE OTHER SEVEN COUNTIES IN
THE STATE ARE USING THOSE KINDS
OF METHODS TO DE ESCALATE. THE
SITUATION NOT LET THEM HAPPEN
IN THE FIRST PLACE. NOT AT
LAMPEN FIRST WHEN THEY DO
HAPPEN. I'LL TELL YOU WHAT THE
MASS CASUALTY LOOKS LIKE IT
LOOKS LIKE IT'S ABOUT THE KIDS
WITH BROKEN ARMS KIDS WITH
CONCUSSIONS KIDS WITH
LACERATIONS- IT RUNS THE GAMUT
AND GET KIDS TO. AND THAT'S NOT
SAFE FOR THEM AND IT'S NOT SAFE
FOR THE OFFICER IS THE DECADES
OF DEAD KIDS YEAH THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN IT GOES TOO FAR
AND THEY GET A HEAD INJURY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND THEY
CAN THEY YOU KNOW. TWENTY SEVEN
LASTED CANNOT KIDS WHO KILL
HERE AND- SO I ASK A QUESTION
OR MAKE A STATEMENT AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M TALKING TO EACH YEAR.
I AM TRYING TO- WHEN YOU GET
HIT ON THE HEAD WITH A CHAIR.
THAT CAN RESULT IN YOUR DEATH.
I HAVEN'T DONE THE
INVESTIGATIONS TO SEE WHERE THE
WHERE THAT'S HAPPENED- BUT I
KNOW WE HAVE HAD THOSE TYPE OF
INCIDENTS OR RESPOND TO A
PRESENT. AND THERE IS A MASS
CASUALTY BASICALLY THAT MEANS
MORE THAN. A COUPLE OF
PATIENTS. AND THERE BECAUSE OF
THESE INCIDENTS. AND WE DO HAVE
OFFICERS THAT ARE FIVE SIX AND
HUNDRED TWENTY POUNDS. THAT ARE
FACED WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE
TWENTY TWICE THEIR SIZE. AND IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR MAYES TO
PROTECT THEM. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEIR VOICE TRYING TO TALK
SOMEBODY OUT OF. BEATING THEM
UP OR IN YOU KNOW FOR
INFLICTING HARM ON THEM IS
GONNA TO SOLVE THAT. SO WITHOUT
WITHOUT SOME OTHER MEANS OF
IMMEDIATELY CONTROLLING AN OUT
OF CONTROL EVENT OTHER THAN
JUST YELLING HEY YOU GUYS STOP
IT. THAT'S NOT EFFECTIVE IN
THOSE ENVIRONMENTS THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS THOSE KIDS ARE
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
BECAUSE WHAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS TRYING TO KEEP THEM
SAFE REHABILITATE THEM BUT ALSO
WE HAVE TO HAVE METHODS THAT
ARE LESS THAN LETHAL METHODS.
TO MAKE THAT ENVIRONMENT SAFE
ENOUGH FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THE END GOAL WHICH IS
THEY GET OUT AND THEY'RE BETTER.
SOME OF THESE ARE THINGS THAT
THEY TALKED ABOUT EARLIER-
THEY'VE WITNESSED TALKED ABOUT-
I APPLAUD THOSE EFFORTS AND I
HOPE THEY WORK. AND IF THEY DO
WORK THEN EVENTUALLY. THERE
WON'T BE A NEED FOR ANYBODY TO
USE. THE PEPPER SPRAY. BUT
UNTIL WE HAVE THAT IN PLACE
UNTIL WE KNOW THAT WORKS I
CAN'T IMAGINE TAKING AWAY ONE
OF THE TOOLS THAT IS SUCCESSFUL
AND HELPING CONTROL THAT TYPE
OF INCIDENT. AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK THIS PEPPER SPRAY YES IS
IT UNCOMFORTABLE YEP. I'VE BEEN
EXPOSED TO PEPPER SPRAY BUT I'M
GLAD I WAS BECAUSE THE
ALTERNATIVE WAS WHATEVER
INCIDENT WERE AND GETS OUT OF
CONTROL. AND I AM I AM I LOSE.
AND SO- YES IT'S VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE AND YES YOU CAN
YOU CAN GET IT WASHED OUT YOUR
EYES. AND IT'LL GO ON- BUT
WITHOUT A TOOL IN THEIR TOOL
BELT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THESE WITHOUT FURTHER INJURING
ANYBODY BY RESTRAINING OR DOING
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S LEFT FOR THEM
SURE AND IT'S NOT SAFE. GOOD SO
THAT'S WHY I HAVE TO OPPOSE
THIS ONE BECAUSE IT'S JUST.
IT'S NOT INTERESTED OF SAFETY.
NOW IT'S NOT FAIR BUT IT'S NOT
SAFE AND SAFETY TRUMP'S
FAIRNESS TO ME. AND IF I CAN
KEEP. IT OUT. BILL THANK YOU
YOU CAN RESPOND TO IT NOW ARE
YOU CLOSE BUT OKAY OKAY YOU.
ALTHOUGH MY CLOSER YOUR PLAYERS
OKAY OTHER MY CLOSE THANK YOU
AND- JUST FOR THE RECORD MISTER
SUCH CHARACTERS YOUR MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE YOU CAN SPEAK AS
MUCH AS YOU WANT AS LONG AS YOU
WANT. MISTER WORK STILL HAS THE
RECORD FOR THE MOST QUESTIONS
SO YOU GOT SOME TIME. FIVE NINE
YEARS. I DO WANT TO MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU AND JUST SAY
THAT IN TALKING WITH THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY SAID OF THE PEPPER SPRAY
IS THERE IT WILL BE USED AND
SHE WANTS SHE TOLD ME SHE'S
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THIS AND
IF THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES AND
SIX GUYS CAN DO IT ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND OTHER COUNTIES CAN
AS WELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER REBEKAH PARKADE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND I WANT IT
I WANTED TO GO OVER FOR A
COUPLE THINGS ONE IS THAT. YOU
KNOW I KNOW THAT ALL OF US HERE
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT BOTH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE REHABILITATION
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS IN THESE
FACILITIES AND ESPECIALLY OF
OUR JUVENILES. AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE- MR KIRK'S POINTS
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
SYSTEM TO ACTUALLY GET WHAT WE
WANT OUT OF IT AND WHEN. THESE
YOUTH ARE BEING HELD IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY ARE BEING
SPRAYED WITH PEPPER SPRAY BY
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE EDUCATING AND REHABILITATING
THEM. THAT'S NOT THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY'RE
HAVING AND I REALLY ACTUALLY
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
MR TRIGO BOTH FOR BEING HERE IN
PERSON. AND FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS BECAUSE I DO THINK WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE WAY WE'RE DOING
IT I THINK WE NEED TO GET AND
WE YOU KNOW WE MOVED THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM BECAUSE
WE WANT TO CHANGE IT. GOING TO
MAKE IT ONE OF REHABILITATION
EDUCATION AND THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF CHANGES WE NEED TO
MAKE AN HEARING THE THIRTY FIVE
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE IT
BEFORE US. AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT HEARING THAT THE WORLD IS
FINE I THINK IT'S GREAT BUT I
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUING AN ONGOING WORK
YOU AND I SPOKE BEFORE THIS
HEARING ABOUT HOW. YOU ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN THESE
FACILITIES TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN FEEL SAFE WHERE
THEY HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED.
AND READIES JUVENILES ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY WILL BE
REHABILITATED AND FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN BE AND I KNOW YOU WILL
CONTINUE THAT WORK AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND AS A RESULT
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE OTHER.%
IMAGE IF YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MEMBERS AND
CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR THEIR
ROBUST CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD
ON THIS BILL I WANT ALSO THANK
EDGAR- GUTERRES WHOSE THE YOUNG
MAN WHO SPOKE WE TALKED ABOUT-
HE'S DONE THE BAD THINGS AS
WELL LET HIM INTO- ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES BUT ALSO WE
DESCRIBE- BEING USED- UNJUSTLY
FOR MINORSITUATIONS THAT MAY
HAVE OCCURRED THERE AND THAT'S
WE WANT TO TRY TO STOP WE WANT
TO PROHIBIT- INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN THESE FACILITIES FROM
BEING FURTHER TRAUMATIZE SO
THEY CAN START THE ROLE IN
THEIR JOURNEY IN TERMS OF
REHABILITATION. IT WAS ASK THE
QUESTION WHAT OPTIONS DO WE
HAVE IN TERMS OF IF PEPPER
SPRAY IS REMOVED WELL THERE ARE
CERTAINLY PHYSICAL- FORCE-
TECHNIQUES- THAT ARE PROVED
THAT YOU CAN USE TO RESTRAIN IT
AN INDIVIDUAL- THERE ARE THERE
ARE CRISIS METHODS THERE ARE
CONFLICTS- MANAGEMENT
RESOLUTIONS THERE'S DE
ESCALATION TACTICS ALL THAT ARE
TRAINED BY PROBATION OFFICERS
TO USE SO THEY WON'T HAVE TO GO
TO THESE PARTICULAR STRINGS TO
TRY TO RESTRAIN AND TRY TO
CONTROL THE SITUATION UNDER
CONTROL HOLES THEY ARE TAKE
DOWN MATHIS AND RESTRAINT
METHODS METHODS THAT CAN BE
USED AND HAVE BEEN USED TO UP
TO BE IMPLEMENTED TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THEY CONTROL THE
SITUATION. AND REDUCE THE HARM
TO THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE MINOR
BUT ALSO TO THE PROBATION
OFFICER AS WELL I UNDERSTAND
THIS THIS IS NOT AN ATTEMPT TO
PUT ANYONE IN JEOPARDY I HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR A
LONG TIME UP UNTIL ONE O'CLOCK
IN THE MORNING AND SO- WE JUST
LEARNED OPPOSITION ON YESTERDAY
AND I ASKED FOR LANGUAGE I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- SIX
EIGHTY FIVE REPRESENT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY- WE INVITE THEM
TO THE TABLE- TO HELP US MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A LANGUAGE
THAT THEY FEEL THAT IS SUITABLE
THAT CAN NOT PUT ANYONE IN
HARM'S WAY NOT ONLY- THE
JUVENILE BUT ALSO THE PROBATION
OFFICER AS WELL. AND SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK EXTREMELY.
HARD IN ORDER TO GET PEOPLE- TO
A POSITION. OF THE THIS THIS-
THIS BILL- ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU AND I BELIEVE YOU YOU
GENERALLY WANT TO GET TO A
PLACE. WHERE THE NEW TECHNIQUES
AS MY- COLLEAGUE SAID STARTS TO
TAKE ROOT IT'S HARD. TO DO
SOMETHING NEW IT'S JUST.
ANYTHING YOU DO WHICH IS HARD
AT IT WHAT I WOULD RECOMMEND TO
YOU MISTER GIBSON IS I KNOW YOU
NAME SOME THINGS THAT COULD
REPLACE IT WE YOU MAY HAVE TO
HAVE DEMONSTRATIONS YOU MAY
HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
SEE IT FEEL IT TOUCH IT.
ESPECIALLY ARE FOR BASED I JUST
SAY OUR PROBATION OFFICERS IN
LA THEY NEED TO ACTUALLY SPEAK
MAYBE ME ATHLETES SEE IT. AND
GET FELLMAN AND TALK TO THOSE
PROBATION OFFICER OUT OF STATE
OR AROUND WHO ARE USING IT SO
THEY CAN GET SOME COMFORT LEVEL
BECAUSE YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
NEW TECHNIQUES SO- THAT NEVER
DO AND- I ALSO WOULD SAY. IF WE
NEED TO RE EXAMINE STAFFING
RATIOS- WE SHOULD IS IT IS
SOMEBODY ELSE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET IF STAFFING RATIOS ARE
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE USED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE SAFE
THEN IF WE NEED TO INCREASE
THAT. BUDGET RISE WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION TOO SO
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO ADD TO IT
TO MAKE THE SYSTEM BETTER AND
ALSO JUST KIND OF- YOU KNOW I
GOT THIS DISCUSSION OF PEPPER
SPRAY NOT TO PURPOSE RAY-
WHETHER NOT IT HURTS YOUTH. N.
AS AS SOME DETRIMENTAL OR IS IT
OVER USE IS AN AMOUNT OF
TRAINING AND TECHNIQUES LET'S
HAVE THAT TEXT DISCUSSION
BECAUSE IF IT. JUST COMES DOWN
TO- INDIVIDUALS YOU IT AND- OR
OVER USING NET. AND THAT'S IT
THAT'S A DIFFERENT DISCUSSION.
THAN ALL OF ITS BAD SO WE
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE THAT. THAT
DISCUSSION AND SHOW WHAT CAN BE
DONE SO I. I THINK WE DO YOU
WORKED ON IT HE WORKED AT UNION
ANYONE TO BRING EVERYBODY IN
THE TAP- I THINK WE SHOULD. BE
FAIR TO BOTH THE PROBATION
OFFICERS. TO THE KIDS AND TO
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE THAT WE
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION DID
EVERYBODY COME TO THE TABLE
LIKE YOU WANT ABSALOM TO IT TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN ABSOLUTELY.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE COMMITTED FOR
THE PURPOSES OF CLARIFICATION-
THESE DAYS. AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
SPOKE ABOUT WILL NOT BE TAKEN.
IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT AS IT
MOVES FORWARD SO. THE GOOD PART
IS YOU CAN ADD THOSE AMENDMENTS
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD- TO THE
NEXT LEVEL WHICH IS
APPROPRIATIONS. SO IF YOU HAVE
SOME TIME AND THE PROBATION
OFFICERS AFTER TIME. WILL MAKE
IT TO WORK IT OUT WILL MAKE
TONS OF CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I
GO. THANK YOU. THE BILL'S BEEN
PROPERLY MOVED AND SECONDED ON
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE BY SEVEN
MEMBER GIPSON THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY. LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAN PARA QUE HAN HI
CORK. CORK BY SANTIAGO.
SARATOGA. SENIOR TO NOTE WICKS.
LEE LI I. MEASURES ARE CALLED
NEEDS ONE MORE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DAVID CHIU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE CHIU
AND- AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE AND
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO GO TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MILITARY
EQUIPMENT FUNDING ACQUISITION
USE OR CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
MOTION TO VACATE IF IT'S OKAY
I'D LIKE TO START WITH AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE BECAUSE- I
THINK MY WITNESSES SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT THEY'RE GONNA GO IN
THE TWO O'CLOCK HOUR AND
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING FOR OUR
SEPARATE SHEET- APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE APPRECIATE THERE'S- AB
TWELVE. FIFTY NINE IS A BILL
ABOUT. THANK YOU I'LL KEEP IT
REALLY SHORT IT'S A BILL ABOUT
KEEPING CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
WHOLE BY PREVENTIVE DETENTIONS
AND DEPORTATIONS. BASED ON
FAULTY GROUNDS- CURRENT LAW
ALREADY SAYS A SOMEONE'S
UNAWARE OF AN ADVERSE
IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES A
CHARGE. THAN THAT CONVICTION IS
LEGALLY INVALID AND OUR
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW A FEW
YEARS AGO- FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS BUT THAT PROCESS IS
ONLY AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WHO
WERE CONVICTED BY PLEA BARGAIN.
NOT FOR THOSE WHO ARE CONVICTED
BY TRIAL- I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE PUNISHING PEOPLE FOR
PURSUING THEIR JURY TRIAL. AND
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A
JURY TRIAL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND WE WILL NOW GO TO
OUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU- AND
YOUR WITNESSES. TO ROAST CAL
AND MY NAME IS HELLO MY NAME IS
ROSE HI AND I AM THAT SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE IMMIGRANT
LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER WHERE I
SPECIALIZED IN POST CONVICTION
RELIEF FOR IMMIGRANTS. I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU AND HIS AMAZING
TEAM FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED TELLING JONES
SAWYER AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
THANK YOU ALSO TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY FOR PASSING A
BE THIRTEEN AND SUBSEQUENTLY AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN. FEET
LAST CREATING AND CLARIFYING
PENAL CODE SECTION FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE POINT SEVEN
HEADBANDS QUITE LITERALLY LIKE
FADING FOR THOUSANDS OF THE
DEFENCE STAND NONPARTISAN. WHO
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE SEPARATE
THAT INDELIBLE IMPACT. OF AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL CONNECTION.
NOW IT'S TIME TO CLOSE THE
FINAL LOOPHOLE LEFT IN FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE POINT SEVEN AND
EXTEND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHALLENGE ALL THE ILLEGAL
CONNECTIONS TO ALL PEOPLE
INCLUDING THOSE CONVICTED BY
TRIAL. THE ONLY 2% OF PEOPLE
ARE CONVICTED BY TRIAL IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN SMALLER
PERCENTAGE ELIGIBLE KERR
RELEASED UNDER THE FACT YEAR I
AM CONFIDENT THAT YOU LIKE ME
BELIEVE THAT NO PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE NO MATTER HOW SMALL
SHOULD SUFFER FROM AN OLD
ILLEGAL CONNECTION. K.
INDIVIDUALS LEFT OUT REPRESENT
VERY REAL PEOPLE INCLUDING THAT
GRAHAM A FATHER OF THREE WHO
HAS LIVED IN THE UNITED STATES
AS A GREEN CARD HOLDER SINCE HE
WAS THIRTEEN YEARS OLD.
SACRAMENTO CURRENTLY IN
DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS BASED
ON A SINGLE MARIJUANA
CONVICTION FROM SIX YEARS AGO.
THAT HAS SINCE BEEN REDUCED TO
A MISDEMEANOR. BUT FOR THE FACT
THAT HE WAS CONVICTED BY A JURY
TRIAL. GRAHAM WOULD HAVE A
CHANCE TO PRESENT EVIDENCE THAT
HIS CONVICTION WAS ILLEGAL AND
STOP HIS DEPORTATION. HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT LOOPHOLE
IN FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE POINT
SEVEN HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
CHANCE AND IT'S TAKEN MANDATORY
PERMANENT AND LYFT HAD
SEPARATION FROM HIS FAMILY.
THIS CLEAN UP IS SIMPLE THERE
IS NO WBC. WHICH IS WHY IT HAS
TO DATE ENGENDERED NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS DRAWN
SUPPORT FROM DA OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
THE ALTHOUGH COUNTY SANTA CLARA
SAN FRANCISCO THE PROCESS IN
THE PROSECUTOR'S ALLIANCE. IN
ADDITION TO MORE THAN THIRTY
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS FROM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. ACTUALLY
REQUEST YOUR BILL BY. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER. REDUCES AND SUPPORTS
SEEN NONE- WILL GO TO ROOM ANY
WITNESSES WITHIN FORTY TWO OH
TWO IN SUPPORT. GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE GREEN ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND AT&T
OPERATOR- OPEN UP FOR MR
CHOOSE- AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE-
AND IF YOU COULD THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WHAT TRIED ONE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARGO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADISON
DO COME UP WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I WON NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CANACCORD DONE ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIDE FIVE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS GREG GREG THAT WOULD
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VICE TRY FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT TO TRY FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DESPITE SIX
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JULIA CHARLIE
SECTOR COMBAT LADYBUG IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT SIX
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CARD DOES NEED- STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINE I'M SORRY FIVE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
FIVE NINE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN SIX TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT SOME
OUTSIDE ON ARMONK PARTICIPANTS
SO. THANKYOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ABOUT. BUT NOW FOR
OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY ON
THE CHART ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION WITHIN THE ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION TO
TELECONFERENCE CNN YOU COULD
NOT OPEN FOR AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
NINETY TWO OTHER IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION YOU CAN OPEN UP THE
LINES ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHY IVE EIGHT TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I WOULD IN SUPPORT
BUT DIDN'T GET CALLED ON KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACCENT ONE OF THE PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKYOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY.
JURORS RECOMMENDED I BOTH
CALDERON. THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY
MOVED INFECTED AB TWELVE FIFTY
NINE BY THE MEMBER CHU THE
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASSED YOUR
PREPARATIONS JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD I
WORK. WORK AT A SAN DIEGO. CA
OUR TOWN THEY ARE TEN NO WICKS.
LI LI I. MATCHES ARE CALL NEED
TO AND MORE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MOVING TO AB FORTY ONE AB
FORTY WOULD ANYONE WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. AS A FORMER
CRIMINAL PROSECUTOR I KNOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. BUT IN A POST GEORGE
FORD WORLD WE NEED TO CONSIDER
HOW EQUIPMENT AND TACTICS
IMPACT THAT PARTNERSHIP.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AMONG THE
TOP STATES WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AMOUNT OF MILITARY WEAPONRY OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
PROCURED INVOLVING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN A SIGNIFICANT LINK
BETWEEN THE LEVEL OF SURPLUS
MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND WEAPONS
OBTAINED BY POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE NUMBER OF POLICE
SHOOTINGS. LAST SUMMER WE ALSO
SAW AN ALARMING RANGE OF
EQUIPMENT IN ACTION DURING
PEACEFUL PROTESTS WHEN POLICE
SPRAY TEAR GAS FOR MILITARY
GRENADE LAUNCHERS AND SHOT
RUBBER BULLETS FROM ARMORED
VEHICLES. THE DECISIONS OF HOW
TO IMPROVE TO DEPLOY THE
SENSITIVE EQUIPMENT WERE LEFT
UP TO INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS AT
THE SCENE WITHOUT UNIFORM
PROTOCOLS WHICH WOULD BE
UNACCEPTABLE. IN IRAQ OR
AFGHANISTAN. THIS BILL ASKED
POLICE TO WORK WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND GOVERNING
BOARDS TO COME UP WITH
APPROPRIATE MILITARY EQUIPMENT
POLICIES THAT CAN BE
DELIBERATED AND APPROVED IN A
PUBLIC SETTING. NOTHING IN THIS
BILL WOULD PREVENT ANY MILITARY
EQUIPMENT FROM BEING USED IF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND GOVERNING
BOARDS WERE TO DECIDE THAT WITH
OUR LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHEN AND WHY POLICE BELIEVE
THEY NEED MILITARY CALIBER
COMMITMENT. ESPECIALLY WHEN
PUBLIC DOLLARS BEING USED TO
PURCHASE AND MAINTAIN THAT
EQUIPMENT AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES. K. I HAVE A
DOMINIQUE ARCHIBALD. NOT THAT
DANIEL HARRIS- PICKET TO
PROBATION ON THE PHONE AND
CONSUELO MARTINEZ CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER OF THE CITY EVEN SEND IN
ESCONDIDO AND DEPUTY MAYOR OF
ESCONDIDO. NOT ALMOST SEVENTY
RETIREMENT PEOPLE ALL THREE OF
YOU ONLY HAVE FIVE MINUTES SO
MY UNDERSTANDING IS CONTROL
MARTINEZ AND DOMINIC ARCHIBALD
WILL BE TESTIFYING OKAY. MR
ARCHER BOULDERS. ARCHIBALD CAN
YOU HEAR ME- MS AFTER. GOING
YOU MAY BE HERE TILL. ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DOMINIC ARCHIBALD AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE NATHANIEL H.
TICKET TO FOUNDATION I AM THE
MOTHER OF NATHANIEL H. MAKE
CRICKET TEAM WHO WORKED FOR SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY CALIFORNIA
SHERIFF CALL WOULD DELIVER
NINETEENTH TWENTY FIFTEEN. MY
SON WAS WALKING HOME FROM THE
STORE AND ON THE PREMISES OF
HIS RESIDENCE IS NOT ARMED HE
HAD NOT COMMITTED A CRIME
MEDICAL AID WAS NOT RENDERED HE
WAS BILL NYE'S IN THE OFFICIAL
REPORT ISSUED WAS REVEALED IN
THE CIVIL COURT OF LAW WITH THE
EVIDENCE PROVIDED BY SIXTEEN
WORKING CAMEL. ENCOUNTER EXPERT
WITNESSES WHO TOLD THE TRUTH
AND WE'LL GET A WITNESSES
PARKING THEN FOR THE COUNTY
GETTING WOULD TO NOT GO ON AS
MUCH AS A MINISTRY LEVINE WAS
NOT REQUIRED TO PAY ANY OF THE
JUDGMENT AND SHOT ANOTHER
PERSON FIX TIME SHORTLY
THEREAFTER. I HAVE SPOKEN
BEFORE YOU BEFORE REGARDING
EIGHTY THREE NINETEEN THIS BILL
SPOKE TO DE ESCALATION
REQUIREMENTS. I HAVE FILED
REQUESTS UNDER SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE AND HAVEN'T RECEIVED
REQUESTED INFORMATION YET WITH
NO ACCOUNTABILITY POLICE
OFFICER BUILT RIGHT POLICE
UNION QUALIFIED IMMUNITY THE
ISSUES AN THESE ARE APPARENTLY
STRONGER MORE POWERFUL THAN
LEGISLATION. CIVIL RIGHTS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE. PLEASE CALL
GOLD STAR. I'M ALSO RETIRED ON
OFFICE. I WOULD. CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL FOR THE MY NINETY TWO
WRITES I WOULD HAVE PENTAGON TO
WITH HIS I HAVE THE TO KUWAIT
IRAQ AND AFGHAN. I HAVE
MANAGING EXCESS EQUIPMENT
PROGRAM ONE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS KNOWN AS THE TEN THIRTY
THREE PROGRAM THE GOVERNMENT
WILL TAKES DIFFICULT. NOT OF
THE INVENTORY FOR MANY REASONS.
MORE SO- OVER MAINTENANCE COSTS
ARE. STORAGE EXPANDABLE.
ANOTHER REASON VERY QUICKLY
BECOMES INEFFECTIVE. WE CREATE
FIVE INCH ARMOR THE WE CREATE.
OUR OWN. CAPABLE OF PIERCING
THAT OUR BATTLES ESCALATE THEY
DON'T DE ESCALATE THE
REGARDLESS OF ANY TACTICS WE
HAVE LAWS OF WAR GENEVA
CONVENTION SOLDIER RULES THINGS
LIKE SOLDIERS DO NOT KILL OR
TORTURE ANY PERSONNEL IN THEIR
CUSTODY. SO JUST COLLECTING
CARE FOR THE WOUNDED WHETHER
FOR IN THE FALL I HAVE OFTEN
SAID THAT WE HAVE MORE MOVING
GAUGE MINT IN A COMBAT ZONE
AGAINST KNOWN ENEMY IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS ON THE STREETS
OF AMERICA THE STREETS OF
CALIFORNIA. ALL STOCK. NOW IF I
CAN GET IT THOUGHTS THAT I ASK
YOU TO HOLD AMERICA TOOK TO THE
STREETS FLASHING TO THE MURDER
OF GEORGE FLOOR GEORGE FLOYD IS
NOT AN ANOMALY SINCE HIS DEATH
HUNDREDS HAVE DIED AT THE HANDS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT ACROSS
COUNTRY READ THE CURRENT
HEADLINE MORE HAVE BEEN KILLED
SINCE THE VERDICT WE KNOW THE
POLICE MILITARIZATION LEADS TO
INCREASED POLICE KILLING. WHEN
THE POLICE MORE OFTEN DEPLOYED
MILITARY EQUIPMENT IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES DO WE NEED MILITARY
EQUIPMENT ON THE STREETS OF
AMERICA IN CALIFORNIA WHAT IS
THE GOAL ESCALATION OR DE
ESCALATION PROTECTING AND
SERVING. OUR WE WAGING WAR ON
OUR OWN. HOW CAN THERE BE SO
LITTLE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WHEN ARE AND
HOW WILL THAT CHANGE OR HOW WE
CONTROL THAT WHEN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE POLICED WITH
WEAPONS OF WAR ASKING AB FORTY
ONE WILL ENSURE COMMONSENSE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND MAKE ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER. THANK YOU. NOW FOR TO GO
TO A CONSUELA TENNIS CONSUELO
MARTINEZ. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS COMPLEMENT **** I AM A
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF
ESCONDIDO. THEY AYE I HAVE
CLIENTS WHO EXPRESSED MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE. AS A LOCAL POLICY WITH
WHERE I AM OFTEN SURPRISED AT
THE GRANT APPLICATION
APPLICATION BURIED IN MY
COUNCIL CONSENT AGENDA THAT
PROVIDE LITTLE DETAILS ABOUT
GRAHAM'S RELATED TO OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SH I AM A COUNCIL
MEMBER THAT REGULARLY CALL
THESE ITEMS OFF OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TASK FOR MORE
INFORMATION. USUALLY OTHER
GRANT ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA
INCLUDE AT THEIR OWN STAFF
REPORT WITH DETAILS ABOUT WHAT
THE FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE WITH MANY
OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY GRANT.
LAST MONTH THE VOICE OF SAN
DIEGO PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE
QUOTE AT NAME. YOU CAN FIND
WORKING GROUP ADMIT IT YOU NEED
TO BE PUBLIC. AND WHEN I READ
THIS ARTICLE INVALIDATED MUCH
OF MY CONCERN. INVENTION BUT
URBAN AREA WORKING GROUP AND
HOW THE GROUP OF VERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
BEEN HOLDING MEETINGS THAT WERE
NOT PUBLIC. IN FACT THESE
MEETINGS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ADHERING TO THE GROUND. WE'VE
MEETINGS HAVE TAKEN IN THAT
MANNER FOR YEARS ALTHOUGH GRANT
APPLICATIONS MUST BE APPROVED
BY CITY COUNCIL LITTLE DETAILS
ARE GIVEN AND THE PROCESS SEEMS
TO HAVE BEEN THE NORM AND IT IS
RARELY QUESTION ON THE DIET.
THAT IS WHY I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE MANY SMALLER
CITIES LIKE MINE DON'T HAVE OUR
OWN YEAH. AND WE HAVE LIMITED
SUPPORT AND CAPACITY TO DO DEEP
DIVES ON POLICY. WE RELY
HEAVILY ON CITY STAFF OF OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION AND THEIR- REPORT.
AB FORTY ONE IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY INCLUDING ALL
DEPARTMENT EQUALLY WHEN I CITY
PURCHASES POLICE FOR EXAMPLE WE
KNOW THE PROJECT COST THE
LIFESPAN. AND WHAT IT COSTS TO
MAINTAIN AND REPLACE THE
EQUIPMENT. THE SAME CANNOT BE
SAID THE MILITARY EQUIPMENT
ACQUIRED BY A POLICE
DEPARTMENT. THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THOSE GAPS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY I'M GRIEF SUPPORT
PLEASE VOTE YES ON EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE MOVED TO ROOM FOUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT C. NINE.
EIGHTY NINE OPERATOR AB FOUR
EIGHT ONE TWO COULD YOU OPEN IT
UP FOR THE TELEPHONE LINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHT ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE MOTEL LINE AT
FIVE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD OH SORRY- HI GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS ELLIE I AM- WITH THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION NOT
GOING TO BE READING OFF A LIST
OF ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT-
FIRST OFF WE HAVE THE IF YOU
KNOW YOUR CALIFORNIA THE LINE
BEFORE THE MEN OF COLOR- ENSURE
CALIFORNIA FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR A RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET. THANK YOU FOR
EMPOWERING REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS THAT OLYMPIC A
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
EMPOWERING- PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY TO EPIC- PRESS NOBODY
LEGAL INDIVISIBLE ON VENTURA
INITIATE JUSTICE. SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN THE ON
MAR IN COMMUNITY HEALTH
SERVICES. OAKLAND PRIVACY.
LLOYD'S'S OAK. PARENTING
RIVERSIDE SIMPLE- AND REBOUND
SECURITY CHECK SOCIAL WORK FOR
EQUITY LEADERSHIP STARTING-
OVER EATING THE TWENTY THANK I
CALL. YOU SEE S. BUT HAYWARD
BRENT IF YOU UTILIZE- YOU
DIFFICULT AND- YOUTH ORGANIZED
CALIFORNIA ON ON THE PORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
TO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ERIC
PORTER BUT I'M WITH AWFULLY CAN
BE A LOT OF THE BOYS IN THE
FOLDER EYE WE'RE CLOSE OFFICE
AN INSTRUCTOR FOR OF AB. FOUR
EIGHT ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO
YES GO AHEAD. HELLO IS IT ME
YES YOU CAN óRDENES ALL HAD-
I'M SORRY HI MY NAME IS MAN
LIVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M A
MOM I RESIDENTS ACTUALLY I
THINK I MUST RESTAURANT NUMBER
BECAUSE I OPPOSE THIS BILL I
MEAN THERE'S SO MANY THANK YOU
CAN GO OUT THERE. THANK YOU
WATER LINE AT SIX THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION A CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
FORTY THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
MY NAME IS JOHN LINDSAY POLAND
WITH THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE PROPONENTS OF
SIMILAR LEGISLATION IN OAKLAND
AND BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX TWO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND SIX
TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE
SIX FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT LITTLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN SIX THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
RYAN SIX THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT PEOPLE ARE
STARTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'VE SIX FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD EVENING
KAREN MCDANIEL ON BEHALF OF THE
PLACE FOR GRACE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SIX I'M SORRY WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- AND NOW
WILL GO TO- RUSSIA MATURE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER JACK CONDITION OF
MILITARY SURPLUS PROPERTY.
OFTEN REQUIRES BIDDERS TO
RESPOND QUICKLY WITHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE A
LEGISLATIVE BODY REGARDING EACH
PURCHASE. EVEN IF THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES FIRST HìNH AGENCY
SEEKS TO ACQUIRE CERTAIN
EQUIPMENT EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE WOULD FEEL SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES IN THEIR ATTEMPT AT
PARTICIPATION ADDITIONALLY THE
TYPE OF PROPERTY CONTEMPLATED
BY THIS BILL IS EXTREMELY FAST
AND INCLUDES ITEMS COMMONLY
USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK
YOU HELLACOPTERS COMMAND AND
CONTROL VEHICLE REACHING
APPARATUS AND RIDE HOME MAKING
SHIELDS HOWEVER EVEN IF THE
MEASURE LACKS IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES IN TERMS OF WHAT
EQUIPMENT IS INCLUDED WE WOULD
REMAIN OPPOSED EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE INTERFERES WITH THE
ABILITY UP INDEPENDENTLY
ELECTED CONSTITUENT
CONFESSIONAL OFFICERS TO
ACQUIRE EQUIPMENT AT A COST
SAVING. FOR THE APPOINTMENT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES NEARLY
ELECTED SHERIFFS ARE CERTAINLY
CAPABLE OF RESPONDING TO THE
CONCERNS OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PURCHASING
AND DEPLOYMENT OF APPROPRIATE.
EQUIPMENT SHOULD THEY ARISE.
FURTHER THE BILL ABOUT REQUIRE
MAN THAT LONG FOR AT ONLY
DESCRIBE HOW AND WHERE SAID YOU.
WAS USED THAT ALSO AND NOW IT
UP ANY CRITICAL. IT'S VERY IN
OTHER WORDS BURST INTO. THAT
THE USE OF KNOWLEDGE EQUIPMENT
MAY HAVE HAD ON THE PUBLIC
SAFETY WELFARE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES AND ON ANY
COMMUNITY OAKLAND THESE
PROVISIONS ARE UNNECESSARILY
BURDENSOME AND PRESUPPOSES
INAPPROPRIATELY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE THAT DECIDED
QUIT MEANT AND TECHNOLOGY
NECESSARILY NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES- AS YOU ALL KNOW IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN VETOED. EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE IT
SIMILAR BILLS THAT DID NOT GO
SO FAR AS TO REQUIRE GOVERNING
BODY APPROVAL FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT IN HIS VETO MESSAGE
SHE STAYED AT THE CURRENT LET'S
NOT ONLY INCLUDE ITEMS THAT ARE
CLEARLY MILITARISTIC IN STYLE.
THAT MANY THAT ARE COMMONLY
USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND DO
NOT MAIL ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
THEIR ACQUISITION- IN MY VIEW
THIS BILL CREATES AN
UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRATIC HURDLE
WITHOUT COMMENSURATE PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND I CANNOT FIND IT.
FOR THESE REASONS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THAT'S RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IT'S NOT
IN THE ROOM EITHER A OTHER- ANY
OTHER PEOPLE THAT HAVE A-
OPPOSITION SHE NONE IN FORTY
TWO OH TWO NOW TO THE
TELESCREENS IS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR ON A B. FOUR EIGHT ONE
TWO- LET'S GO TO THE PHONES. Q.
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR EIGHT
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CAME OVER
TO LINE FIVE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AS CHAIR MEMBERS RUN
SHIPMENT WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ON
SAMPLES DOCTORS BOTH THE ASIAN.
ONE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE FORT SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOHN LEGO PRIMARY PHONE
AND I VOTE NO FOR THIS PLEASE
VOTE NO TO KEEP US SAFE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE
FOR SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. YOUR
ORGANIZATION. HELLO THIS IS
RANDY. IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
FIVE I'M NOT- I'M I'M A
RESIDENT AND A MOM OF SAN
FRANCISCO I OPPOSE THIS- THIS
ASSEMBLY BILL THERE ARE MANY
STREET GANGS AND CRIMINALS WITH
PLENTY OF WEAPONS FROM ANOTHER
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS DOCTOR
REAMING HIM WITH ASIAN AMERICAN
GUN OWNERS A CALIFORNIA. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FORTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF ALL LAW ABIDING GUN
OWNERS A T. W. HOLDERS.
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPROVING OUR ODDS AGAINST
VIOLENT ARMED CRIMINALS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT SIX OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRANDED UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SIX FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES BANDEIRA
GLOWING CONSTITUENT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ALSO WELL I'M A
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO AREA.
AND I SAY NO TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. SHE. WHICH THANK YOU VERY
ONE MY LAST IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MORE MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT.
RYAN SIX SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANY TO GET INCOME UP
FROM NOTHING IS COMING ON
STRONG THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
ANY WITNESSES IN CHAMBER. IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE COLOR OF.
CONFERENCING IN OPPOSITION STE
SENAD LOOK. THIS WOULD. AND WE
ARE WITH DEFAULT SO NOW BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MR LACKEY.
YEAH UNFORTUNATELY I AGREE WITH
THE- THE VETO MESSAGE THAT WAS
SHARED BY. THE THE MEMBERS OF
THE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SHE
ALREADY READ THE QUOTES I WON'T
READ IT AGAIN. BUT ESSENTIALLY
OF THE TYPE OF PROPERTY THAT'S-
CONTEMPLATED BY THIS BILL-
INCLUDES ITEMS COMMONLY USED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. SO THREATEN
THE BILL DOESN'T CENTRALIZES
THE FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE
ACQUISITION OF EQUIPMENT BY STE
ACTUALLY STALI LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO APPLY
FOR TOOLS AND SUPPLIES AT NO
COST AND THE DEFEND THEM. SO I
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU TO SIT THERE SHERATON
THANK YOU. SORRY YOU KNOW IF WE
DID HAVE A GENEVA CONVENTION
FOR CALIFORNIA THEN BOTH SIDES
WOULD AGREE TO NOT DO IT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT THE
SITUATION HERE- ONE SIDE DOES
NOT AGREE TO ABIDE BY THE RULES
OF ENGAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO- SO THAT THAT ARGUMENT
FALLS KIND OF SHORT ON ME-
HAVING WATCH THIS INVOLVED OVER
THE PAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS OR
SO- I CAN TELL YOU ARE COMES
FROM IT COMES FROM POLICE
SHOWING UP. BEING BADLY
OUTGUNNED AND OUTMANNED BY ARE
JUST OUTGUNNED. BY CRIMINALS
WHO HAD FAR SUPERIOR WEAPONS
THAT THEY OBTAINED ON THE
ILLEGAL MARKET. AGAIN THE
POLICE OFFICERS HAD TO BE ABLE
TO DEFEND THE PUBLIC AGAINST
THEM. AND SO THEY STARTED GOING
INTO GETTING- BETTER EQUIPMENT
AND THAT BETTER EQUIPMENT COMES
WITH THE COST FORTUNATELY THE
MILITARY ALREADY HAD A LOT OF
THAT BETTER EQUIPMENT AND SO
THEY WERE ABLE TO TAP INTO
THOSE. AND THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
THIS STARTED- THEY WOUND UP
WITH SWAT TEAMS AND THEY WOUND
UP WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT-
DIFFERENT TYPES OF. SPECIALTY
TEAMS THAT DEALT WITH SPECIALTY
ISSUES. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY A LOT OF THE THIS EQUIPMENT
IS USED FORCE. SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT THE POLICE
NEED TO BE AS WELL EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE AS THE CRIMINALS. AND
YOU KNOW IT HAVING BEEN ON A
CITY COUNCIL FOR A LONG TIME
WITH A BRAND NEW POLICE
DEPARTMENT. I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THEY THEY PURCHASE SOME
EQUIPMENT. AND NOT ONE TIME WAS
THAT- SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT BY
THE CITY COUNCIL- IF THEY'RE
SOMETHING ON CONSENT CALENDAR
YOU SIMPLY PULL IT OFF CONSENT
CALENDAR AND GET MORE
INFORMATION- SO. YOU KNOW IF I
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY WE
KEEP HAND COPPING. OUR POLICE
OFFICERS AND TRYING TO KEEP US
AS A PUBLIC SAFE. AND IN THIS
IS JUST ONE MORE. TOOL THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SAVE US
MONEY. AND HAVE THE EQUIPMENT
THAT THEY NEED IN THE MOST
EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND US AGAINST THE
BAD GUYS. AND THERE ARE BAD
GUYS OUT THERE AND- AND THEY
DON'T CARE WHAT WE THINK SO. I
AM GOING TO HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS
BECAUSE OF THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. UP WITH PARQUET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
QUESTION- SO THE BILL THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT I HAVE TO
SAY THAT I THINK TRANSPARENCY
AND THE ABILITY FOR THE
GOVERNING BODIES TO DECIDE WHAT
THE COMMUNITY WANTS SENATE'S-
OWN RANKS MAKE SENSE TO ME. BUT
THE BILL HERE SHOULD DO TWO
THINGS WHICH I PUT FORTH A
POLICY THAT THEN THAT THE LAWN
FIRST NEED TO ABIDE BY BUT ALSO
CONTAINS THAT EVERY TIME THEY
ENGAGE IN OUR OF P. THAT THEY
GOT TO GET THAT THINK IT ALSO
NEEDS TO BE APPROVED AND IT
SEEMS TO ME IF THERE'S A POLICY
IN PLACE THAT. DRAWS THE
CONFINES OF WHAT IS AND IS NOT
APPROPRIATE I'M SORT OF FEELING
THE SHERIFF HERE THEN WHY DO
THEY NEED TO STALL THE PROCESS
TO GO GET THAT HELICOPTER HE
WILL. EXPLAIN THAT YES SO FIRST
OF ALL LET ME LET ME JUST AGREE
WITH SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE NOT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
TODAY'S BILL- THAT- THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH ON THE
STREET TO CALIFORNIA WE WANT-
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE AS
WELL EQUIPPED TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THE SITUATION I JUST
WANNA MAKE IT VERY CLEAR. THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT FORBID. THE
BILL FOR ENFORCEMENT TO OBTAIN
THAT EQUIPMENT- WHAT THIS SAYS
IS THE- CONCEPT OF THIS BILL
IS. LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A PUBLIC PROCESS WHERE
THERE IS A DECISION MADE ABOUT-
HOW THOSE WEAPONS ARE OBTAINED
AND WHEN THEY'RE GONNA BE USED
AND LET'S HAVE A PROCESS. AND
UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY'RE GOING
TO BE USED- SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE CORE OF THIS- WE HAVE PUT
IN SOME PROCESS HERE AND- TO
OUR OUR COLLEAGUES POINT- WE'RE
WE'RE WILLING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND EXACTLY HOW THAT GETS
STRUCTURED. BUT I THINK FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE WE WANT TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE WANT TO
HAVE TRANSPARENCY BOTH AND WHEN
THIS EQUIPMENT IS OBTAINED AND
WHEN IT'S USED WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOME VALUATION
THAT THAT'S- FUNDAMENTALLY AT
THE CORE- AND- AND AGAIN WE'RE
WILLING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
ABOUT THAT APPRECIATE- THAT
THERE ARE SOME- REPRESENTS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT WE ARE
ENGAGING WITH TO REALLY TIGHTEN
THIS UP- BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
THERE ARE SOME WHO THINK THAT
THERE OUGHT TO NOT BE.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WITH REGARDS TO THIS AND
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT- THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO THINK
THAT YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL
AGREE OUR STREETS SHOULD NOT BE
WAR ZONES CITIZENS ARE NOT
ENEMY COMBATANTS- AND THERE ARE
FOLKS WHO. WOULD LOVE TO BAN
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT IS
AGAIN NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
WERE ESTABLISHING ESTABLISHING
PROCESS. THANK YOU M. SO I MEAN
I. AGREE WITH YOU THAT I THINK
THIS BILL IS. IS NARROWED IN
SCOPE IN A WAY THAT'S
APPROPRIATE I MEAN THE PART
THAT SAYS THAT THE GOVERNING
BODY SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
PURCHASE IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE OF ALTERNATIVES WE
SHOULD DO THAT WITH EVERYTHING
THAT. I THOUGHT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT PIECE OF IT. I
DON'T THINK WE DO THAT OFTEN
ENOUGH. IN USING HARD EARNED
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT BUT I DO THINK
THERE IS A WAY TO NARROW IT TO
ENSURE THAT THE GOVERNING BODY
CREATES THIS POLICY BUT ALSO
ENABLES. THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO GO OUT AND GET
THESE PIECES WILL COME WHEN
THEY ARE AVAILABLE ON SHORT
NOTICE I DON'T THINK THOSE TWO
THINGS ARE INCONSISTENT AND SO.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WORK WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S EASILY
FIXED AND THE STUFF. AND I
WOULD SAY BECAUSE THIS WAS A
PROBABLY THE ONE MAIN ISSUE
RAISED BY. THE SHERIFF'S AND
THEIR OPPOSITION THAT I ALSO
SUPPORT WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE
POLICY PROCESS THAT DELAYS THE
ABILITY TO GET IT. WHAT WE ARE
ASKING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
THOUGH IS. IF YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE MIGHT.
BECOME A PROCUREMENT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS GET
PRIOR APPROVAL SO THAT YOU'RE
READY TO GO WHEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY COMES UP. IF IT
TURNS OUT. THAT THERE'S AN
UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITY TO
OBTAIN THAT EQUIPMENT LET'S
HAVE A PROCESS TO DEAL WITH
THAT EXISTENCE CIRCUMSTANCE I'M
OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION. BUT
THE IDEA OF NOT HAVING A
PROCESS- TO CONTEMPLATE THIS
THAT'S WHAT. THAT'S THAT'S NOT
WHAT I THINK. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. K. YOUR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. MISTER MISTER TO
MAKE I JUST WANT TO FIRST
APPRECIATE- ALL OUR COALITION
FOR WAITING FOR A COUPLE OF
HOURS I REALLY DO ALSO
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE FOR
HOW MANY HOURS YOU WORK IN- IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES- I LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS AND I WILL SAY TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT- WE ARE OPEN TO
A CONVERSATION OF HOW TO DO
THIS IN A REASONABLE WAY BUT
AGAIN. THIS IS ABOUT INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND THE
REASON WE'RE DOING THAT IS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO REBUILD
COMMUNITY TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS TYPE
OF TRANSPARENCY THIS TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY WILL HELP TO
FURTHER THAT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT. IT
THANK YOU MISTER. MR CHEW UP I
THINK- MY COLLEAGUES ON THIS
COMMITTEE YOU ARE WORKING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M GLAD THEY
GAVE ME TO HISTORY. OF WHY THEY
NEEDED THE EQUIPMENT I THINK
IT'S REALLY GOOD THAT WE
ACTUALLY KNOW. ABOUT THE WHO
WHAT WHERE WHY IT I THINK WILL
HELP WITH YOU COMING TO A
LANDING SPOT. WHAT I WANT THEM
ALSO TO REMEMBER. DURING MY
TIME IN LA IN A CRACK COCAINE
TIME IN LA THE MILITARY. THE
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT WAS
USED IN MY AREA WHERE I LIVE
THE BATTERY AMENT OTHER THINGS
WAS OUT OF CONTROL. AN INNOCENT
PEOPLE. WERE HURT INNOCENT
PEOPLE WERE KILLED. IN RAIDS
AND THAT'S WHERE THIS COMES
FROM ESPECIALLY WHEN THE LOS
ANGELES CITY COUNCIL DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW. LAPD HAD THIS
EQUIPMENT AND I THINK
DELEGATION EVEN PROBABLY SAID
IT WAS NOT IN YOUR BUSINESS HE
PROBABLY SAYS SOMETHING ELSE A
LITTLE HARSHER SO THAT'S- WHY
YOUR BILL IS SO IMPORTANT AS
FAR AS TRANSPARENCY SO THAT
SAID THE CITY COUNCIL AND LARA
FORCE WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT.
MAKE A DECISION. ONE MAKES
THEIR CASE THE OTHER MAKES
THEIR CASE AND HOPEFULLY CAN
LAND IN A PLACE WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN BE SAFE THE
MOST IMPORTANT TO RESIDENTS CAN
BE SAFE ALSO AND THAT WE WORK
OUT A SYSTEM WHERE DOES
MISTAKES THAT WERE MADE BACK
DURING THOSE BAD CRACK COCAINE
DAYS- WILL NOT REOCCUR AND I
THINK THAT'S- THIS PUSH. FROM
THE OTHER SIDE THOSE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO REMEMBER THOSE
DAYS AND REMEMBER THAT A
MILITARY EQUIPMENT ON THE
STREETS IN POOR NEIGHBORHOODS-
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN
AGAIN. AND SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT BECAUSE THIS THIS
IS A GOOD DISCUSSION THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE AND- AND RECOMMEND
A AYE VOTES WE CAN MOVE THIS
FORWARD. IF BACK MOTION.TO
MOVED TO BILL. OUR SECOND. THE
BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED IN
SENATE ON EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE BY SEVEN MEMBER CHU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER
GENSER IRAQI BACKING NOW
BARRICADE HAND BAKKIE HAD AYE
CORK. QUICK I SAN DIEGO SAY OUR
TENT OUT THERE TO KNOW WICKS.
WICKS I BELIEVE WE I. THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES MISSED DERIDE
TREATISE. MISTER RODRIGUEZ AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EMPLOYERS
PROHIBITED DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION ARREST OR DETENTION.
SH YOU MAY BE GIVE MR RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
WHICH WOULD ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REQUEST
AND RECEIVE ARREST INFORMATION
FOR SPECIFIC NON SWORN
EMPLOYEES A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO FROM
LAST SESSION WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED ON CONSENT
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCY TO COMPLETE A
BACKGROUND CHECK ON APPLICANTS
FOR NON SWORN POSITIONS AND
ASKED INDIVIDUAL ABOUT PRIOR
ARREST. HOWEVER DUE TO A
LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW ONCE AN
APPLICANT IS HIRED THE AGENCY
CANNOT REQUEST OR RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT A NON SWORN
EMPLOYEE ABOUT ANY FUTURE
ARREST THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
WOULD ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO INVESTIGATE WHEN
NON SWORN EMPLOYEES ARRESTED
WHICH WOULD HELP SAFEGUARD THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE SHOP.
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. RUSSIA
WHICH WOULD BE READY TO GO.
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. I'M NOT SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION- SPONSORS
OF ASSEMBLY BILL. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY. LOW DO WE LOSE THEIR.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
OFFERING THIS AT ALL AND- HE
WANTED TO- JUST CANNOT THINK OF
TIME I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT-
MADE FOURTH THREE. POINT SEVEN
PROHIBITS ASKING EMPLOYEES
ABOUT ARREST RECORDS THAT DID
NOT RESULT IN A CONVICTION
HOWEVER PERCENT ALREADY
EMPLOYED ACT PEACE OFFICER THE
PERSON SEEKING EMPLOYMENT FOR
POSITIONS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OR OTHER CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCY AS DEFINED IN
PENAL CODE. THIRTEEN ONE OH ONE
ARC LAMPS FROM LABOR CODE FOR
THIRTY TWO POINT SEVEN THESE
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
COMPLETE A BACKGROUND CHECK ON
APPLICANTS FOR NON SWORN
POSITION AND ASK ABOUT. PRIOR
ARRESTS BUT ONCE THEY ARE HIRED
A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY DO YOU
DRAW THE POLE INTO LAW CAN NO
LONGER QUESTIONED. THEM ABOUT
THE FUTURE- LAST. THERE IS A
COMPANION IN PENAL THIRTEEN TO.
THAT L. SIX WOMEN JUSTICE
AGENCY TO IF CONCERNING
UNDERGRAD WE'LL GET PENSION TO
THE EMPLOYEES OF THE PEACE
OFFICER BUT NOTHING ADDRESSES
NONCHALANT EMPLOYEES UP THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND OF
COURSE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
HAVING ETHICAL AND
CONSCIENTIOUS PERSON NOW IS
PIVOTAL. TO SAFEGUARD THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM NO MATTER THEIR
RANK OR TITLE. SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CONSISTENT
TRUSTWORTHY RELATIONSHIP. WITH
THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY MAX OUT
THE NECESSARY MEANS TO REQUEST
AND RECEIVE- WESTRAC CARD FOR
CERTAIN NON SWORN EMPLOYEES.
PROCESS IN SHORT EQUITY
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THESE REASONS HE HAS FAITH
PRESCHOOL SPONSOR AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY AND WE FIGHT THINK AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ CO
AUTHORING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. HERE IN
THE- FORTY TWO OH TWO. SEEN
ANYWHERE ON THE TELECOM.
CHANNEL SEEN. ARE YOU MAY UP TO
PAR LINE FOR A FOURTEEN EIGHTY
RODRIGUEZ- AT&T OPERATOR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE THREE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DOCTOR EVEN KIM- ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN GARNERS A
CALIFORNIA BOTH STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ON
BEHALF OF ALL LAW ABIDING GUN
OWNERS WHO GO THROUGH
BACKGROUND CHECKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- NOW WILL
GO TO IN OPPOSITION I'VE SEEN
NONETHELESS I MEAN LOOK AGAIN.
NO NOT ON THE LIST AND- OPEN IT
UP TO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. IN
THE ROOM FORTY TWO- TO ANYONE
AND I ON THE TELECOM. CHEN AND
THEN. OPEN IT UP FOR ON PHONE
AT&T A. B. FOR EIGHTY RHETORIC.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AND I OF AB FORTY EIGHTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIVE SIX FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SANDY-
RAVELLO A CONSTITUENT IN
CALIFORNIA- AND APART
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONING MR QUIRK. YES SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR TAKING THIS OFF
OF- CONSENT BUT I REALLY NEEDED
TO HEAR MORE AND HAVING HEARD
MORE I'M NOW SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL- IT'S BEEN MOVED HERE.
WAITING FOR YOU THANK SECOND.
THANK. THIS IS OUR CARE TO
SECOND. WHICH MOTION BY MISTER
QUIRKS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY
CONCLUDE OUR SPEC LAST PRIVATE
THANK YOU. CHAIR RECOMMENDED I
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL THE
BILL'S BEEN PROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
BY SOME MEMBERS- RODRIGUEZ THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI
BLACKIE I PARA QUE HAN BACKING
AND HI CORK. CORK I SAN DIEGO
SAY ARE TôI SERTA I WICKS
WICKS I LI. LI I. THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU MR LEE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK GOD
LIKE YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON OUR NEW SET OF
AMENDMENTS AND I ALSO WANT TO
BEGIN BY LETTING THE COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT I LISTEN TO THE
OPPOSITION AND DECIDED TO CROSS
AMENDMENTS TO REINCORPORATE
GREAT BODILY INJURY WHICH IS
PENAL CODE TWELVE ZERO TO TWO
POINT SEVEN BACK INTO THE
VIOLENT FELONY IN THIS SO
APPRECIATIVE OF OPPOSITIONS
HIGHLIGHTING OF THAT CONCERN.
NOW I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM IS
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM REFERS TO
THE WAYS WHICH POLICIES SUCH AS
THE ONES WE DEBATE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CREATE DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES FOR DIFFERENT RACIAL
GROUPS MANY POLICIES THAN
SHRINE INSTITUTIONAL RACISM OR
LARGELY ENACTED IN THE ERA OF
TOUGH ON CRIME A MOVEMENT
DRIVEN BY FEAR AND RACISM ONE
GLARING EXAMPLE INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM IS THE USE OF A
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS
PARTICULARLY FIRE ON BEHANCE
WHAT'S WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS TO OF COLOR. THERE
AREN'T ANY CREDIBLE STUDIES
THAT DETAIL HOW MUCH HOW THE
DETAIL MUCH HIGHER RATE OF
FIREARM USAGE WITHIN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR COMPARED
TO THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS YET
89% 89% OF ALL FIREARM
ENHANCEMENTS ARE APPLIED TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHAT THE ANTI
SENT ANTI RACISM SENTENCING
REFORM ACT THIS BILL AIMS TO DO
IS DISMANTLE THIS LEGAL
MONUMENT TO RACISM BY REDUCING
THE SENTENCE BY REDUCING
SENTENCE ADD ONS. FOR FIREARMS
THAT ESSENTIALLY PUNISH PEOPLE
MULTIPLE TIMES FOR THE SAME
CRIME. THERE ARE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS ON OUR PENAL CODE
AND IT IS ONLY FIELD MASS
INCARCERATION FOR DECADES
WITHOUT DETERRING CRIME OR
MAKING US ANY SAFER. IN FACT IF
MARK IF MASS INCARCERATION
ENHANCEMENTS WORKED WOULD BE
THE SAFEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
WITH WITH 25% OF. OUR
POPULATION BECAUSE WE COMPARE
OUR 25% OF ALL THE CARS ARE
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD COMPARED A
ONLY HAVING FIVE PERCENT. OF
THE WORLD'S POPULATION. IN THIS
BILL WE TAKE A DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH TO IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND MAKE THEM
SAFER BECAUSE INSTEAD OF BEING
TOUGH ON CRIME REALLY OUGHT TO
BE SMART ON CRIME. AND THE DATA
IS CLEAR. EXTREME PRISON TERMS
HAVE NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN
DETERRING CRIME AND CONVERSELY.
FOR EACH ADDITIONAL YEAR
SENTENCING YOU CAN INCREASE
RECIDIVISM BY 47% I REDUCING
THE USE OF SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS DOESN'T MEAN THERE
ARE NO PUNITIVE ACTIONS TAKEN
FOR CRIMES EITHER. PEOPLE STILL
SERVE OUT THEIR STATUTORY
SENTENCES FOR THE CRIMES THEY
DECIDED TO COMMIT. IF THE GOAL
IS TO CREATE A SAFER COMMUNITY
AN EXTREMELY LONG SENTENCES
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO RUN COUNTER
TO THAT OBJECTIVE AND ONLY
FURTHER DEPRIVES HUMAN BEINGS
WITH DIGNITY. NOT TO MENTION
HOW WASTEFUL IT IS OF OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. RATHER THAN
INVESTING ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN.
THAT'S OUR ONE HUNDRED TWELVE
SIX HUNDRED NINETY ONE DOLLARS
A YEAR SO THAT'S OVER ONE TO
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
TO INCARCERATE A HUMAN BEING.
WAS ALREADY SERVE THEIR
STATUTORY OFFENSE RESOURCES CAN
BE DIVERTED FOR REENTRY
RESISTANCE. REENTRY ASSISTANCE
AND OTHER SERVICES TO HELP
PROMOTE REHABILITATION. BETTER
YET IF WE INVEST IN PEOPLE AND
BASIC QUALITY OF LIFE WHERE WE
ARE PROVIDING HOUSING FOOD
CLEAN WATER HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION TO EVERY PERSON IN
SOCIETY. YOU CAN REST ASSURED
THAT WE WOULD SEE A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN ALL TYPES OF CRIMES.
IT'S OFFICIAL RACISM IS
SOMETHING THAT WE MUST ACTIVELY
DISMANTLE TOGETHER ESPECIALLY
IN THIS TIME. AND THAT'S IS
WHAT THE ANTI RACISM SENTENCING
REFORM THIS BILL AIMS TO DO. I
AM PLEASED TO BE JOINED TODAY
BY TWO INCREDIBLE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. LEAH LEAH GILLIS
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL SLAW AND
LETITIA ADWORDS PROGRAM
DIRECTOR RESTORED JUSTICE. AND
YOU CAN BEGIN UP WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. WE'LL START WITH
LEAH LEAH. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH AND I'M SPEAKING AND
TRONG REPORT OF A BEACON LONG.
I THINK PERSONAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY WHO HARD PAKISTAN
BROKE DOWN MARKING AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. I HAVE EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE COURT ROOM
ANNEX THIRTEEN AND THE IMPACT
OF EXTREME SENTENCING AB.
FIFTEEN OR NINE WEEKS TO
ADDRESS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
PROVIDED AN EXCELLENT
EXPLANATION OF WHY AB FIFTEEN
OH NINE WOULD NEED MORE. IN
FACT I HAVE WITNESSED FIRST
HAND WHAT THIS DOES THE YOUNG
MEN OF COLOR WHO ARE MOST OFTEN
THE RECIPIENTS OF THESE EXTREME
EXAMPLES. MY CLIENT OFTEN
PLAYED UP TO ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEARS TO LIFE IN PRISON
WHEN ALL OF THE ENCAMPMENTS ARE
ADDED UP. LIFT THE MORAL I
FOUND THEY LOSE HOPE AND THEY
END UP TAKING CREDO FOR WELL
OVER FORTY YEARS. NINE FOR A OR
SERIOUS INJURY HAS NOT OCCURRED.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS WHAT AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE THAT AND DOES
NOT NEED TO. THERE ARE WELL
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ENCAMPMENTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE. AB FIFTEEN HONORING
TO OBJECT A SMALL HANDFUL OF
BOTH ADVANCEMENT. THIRTY EIGHT
TESTIMONY DURING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE SHARING.
PROSECUTORS CHARGE THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF THE FRIENDS THEY CAN'T
AS THE PRIMARY CHARGE. THEM A
FAX ALL BEING THAT ARE
FACTUALLY SUPPORTED. THEY THEN
USE THE FACT THE ENHANCEMENT AS
A COERCIVE FORCE. TO OBTAIN
PLEASE HI TERMINATE BENSON SAYS.
FORTY FIVE YEARS THAT TRYING TO
AVOID THE EVEN SHOCKINGLY
HIGHER INDETERMINATE SENTENCING.
NOT A CLIENT WILL GET A FULL
LEAD THAT TRIAL. THE REGULAR
USE OF FEAR AND INTIMIDATION
EVISCERATES A COVETED
CONSTITUTIONAL DUE PROCESS
RIGHT AT THE JURY TRIAL. A
RIGHT THAT IS FOUNDATION OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE
REALITY IS OVER 90% OF THOSE
CHARGED WITH CRIMINAL OFFENSES
DO NOT INVOKE THEIR RIGHT TO
FILE. FIFTY OUT DUE TO THE
RATIONAL FEAR OF DYING IN
PRISON BEFORE THEY EVER GET A
CHANCE TO EVEN BE A PAROLE
BOARD. WHERE A CLIENT BASE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS ALIVE.
THE SIMPLY CANNOT LIVE LONG
ENOUGH TO EVEN BE A SINGLE
PAROLE HEARING. AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE WOULD NOT REMOVE JUDICIAL
OR PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION.
UNFORTUNATELY PROSECUTORS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY USING THEIR
DISCRETION IN CHARGING. THAT IS
THE CORE OF THE ISSUE HERE AND
JUDGING DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THEIR
DISCRETION DO YOU TO PLEAD
GUILTY BUT HI THERE CAN. IF
THEY DID WE WOULDN'T HAVE
DRAFTING PERSPIRATION OR
EXTREME TECHNICAL. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY USING THEIR
DISCRETION OR NOT. OUR BILL
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THESE
PENSIONS ARE INHERENTLY
UNCONSCIONABLE. AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE ADDRESS WITH SENTENCING
COULD GO AND DA'S AND JUDGES
CAN STILL USE THEIR DISCRETION
ON HOW THEY GET. EXTREMES
THANKS ENCAMPMENTS HAVE YOUR
MARK KNOPFLER CARS DURATIONS
FOR DECADES. WITHOUT DETERRING
CRIME FOR MAKING US ANY SAFER.
THESE LAWS WERE CREATED DURING
A SEVERE REACTION THAT YOU'LL
THE TOUGH ON CRIME AARON FAILED
POLICIES BASED ON NO EMPIRICAL
DATA WHATSOEVER COULD YOU WRAP
IT UP WE NOW HAVE THE HINDSIGHT
OF OVER THIRTY YEARS OF THESE
FAILED POLICIES AND THE DATA IS
CLEAR AND SHARP IN. THESE
ENHANCE MARK HUGHES PEOPLE OF
COLOR HELLO HELLO WE ONLY HAVE
FIVE MINUTES AND WE HAVE
ANOTHER SPEAKER YOU'RE TAKING.
UP WITH THE HARBINGER TOUCH
IT'S ONLY FIVE MINUTES BETWEEN
THE TWO SPEAKERS SO IF YOU
COULD WRAP UP THAT WOULD BE
GOOD SO WE CAN HEAR FROM. MS
EDWARDS. YES OKAY WELL THANK
YOU. R. DO EVEN HAVE HER GET
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE
CONSCIONABLE PORTION AND
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT MAKE A PAPER.
TWENTY TWENTY WOULD BE NEAR OF
DEEP REFLECTION AND PAINFUL
REALIZATION I THINK THAT
REQUIRED EXAMINES CHANGED. NOW
IS THE TIME FOR US AFTER. FOR
THESE REASONS WE HUMBLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OR
NINE AND BRING IT. AND THEN THE
BIG DARK AIR AND OUR GREAT
NEEDS BECAUSE DURING. THANK YOU
MS AVERAGE. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING FARE INCLUDING MY NAME
INCLINATION EDWARDS I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT RESTORED
JACKSON I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY CRIME
VICTIMS ADVISORY BOARD I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT CONSTANTINE
HAS MADE FRAMEWORK DOES NOT
WORK I MYSELF AND A SURVIVOR OF
MULTIPLE TIMES. I'VE HAD TWO OF
MY YOUNGER BROTHER WHO WORKED
AT THE PENTAGON I DON'T I
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN ONLINE
BECAUSE MANY VICTIMS. THE PRICE.
ONLY HAVE LONG LOVED TO GUN
VIOLENCE BUT ALSO BE OF HOW
THINKING. ENHANCE ARE YOU WITH
THAT THE PEOPLE OF COLOR AD
ARE. NOT ONLY ARE WE LIVED IN
OUR FAIR BECAUSE TODAY VIOLENCE
WE BELIEVE THEM A CHANCE AND-
THAT. AB FIFTY NINE ONE THING
TO REACH AND CREATING A MORE
FAIR AND EQUITABLE JUSTICE
SYSTEM FOR ALL COMMUNITY. I
THOUGHT IT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFY HE EXPECTS
AND NOT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WITH A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THERE ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT IN SUPPORT IN
THE FORTY TWO A TO SEE NONE ME
WITNESSES ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. OF SEEN NONE-
AT&T OPERATOR YOU CAN OPEN UP
AB FIFTEEN OH NINE LEE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY OR
MORE IN Q. BOOK OR TO LINE FOR
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SIX SIX EIGHT WHAT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CYNTHIA PREENCHER HAMPER
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN NINE AND REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AS
WELL. THANK YOU RIGHT SIX
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND I. GORGI SEVEN
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SIX FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE SIX FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T THINK
ANY OF US HAVE BEEN GIVEN
NUMBERS. OKAY THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT.
NINE FIVE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS GREGORY
BALLOT INITIATE JUSTICE THE
PRAGUE COSPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT EXPRESSING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE OTHER CO SPONSORS
INCLUDING RESTORE JUSTICE ESSIE
JUSTICE GROUP SILICON VALLEY DE
BUG AS WELL AS LOOKING SUPPORT
FROM THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION ENTIRE CITIZEN COALITION
ON COMMON LAW CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
ASIAN SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE
STANDING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
CHAPTER CONTRA COSTA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TWO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND TWO ONE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX
SIX FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
HELLO THIS IS CHILL WIND SHEAR
WITH FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME DESIREE
MIA GET KAREN I'M CALLING FROM
UP WEDNESDAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ONE FIVE ZERO NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SEVEN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
SEVEN ONE SEVEN HELLO. YEAH
PLEASE GO AHEAD HOPE IS GOING
ON- HI MY NAME'S AMBER
AGGIELAND FROM TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA AND ARMY SUPER
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE NEW ONE
FIVE OH NINE. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVEN OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS THE ONLY RODRIGUEZ-
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN OWN NINE I MEAN L. A.
COUNTY AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
ITSELF SFF WITH PASSING IT
THANK YOU. YOU THANK YOU RYAN
SIX THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALSO ALONE
I'M CALLING FROM THE SACRAMENTO
AREA I'M THE RESIDENT I AM
STRONGLY. IN THIS BILL PLEASE
SAY NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RANGE SIX SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CARLOS
ORTIZ ON THE BORDER FROM L. A.
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE FIVE ZERO NINE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CARLOS CRESSMAN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY
AGREE WITH A BE ON THE SUPPORT
OF AB ONE FIVE ZERO NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SIX
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS OPEN CORRECT AND I AM
CALLING FROM FOREIGN I AM
STRONG SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTEEN
ONE FIVE ZERO NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS GRETA MILLER I'M
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. FIFTEEN
OH NINE AND I HOPE LACKEY DOES
TOO THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SIX NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS YES PLEASE
LOPEZ AND I'M CALLING FROM
DISTRICT FIFTY THREE AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE AND I HOPE MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN SIX FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS LOWER THE THIRTEENTH I'M
CALLING FROM THE L. A. COUNTY
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF-
FIFTEEN OH NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MAHDI SELA LONGORIA I'M
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND ON THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE. AQ RIGHT FOR NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS GLENN BILLION AMID STRONG
SUPPORT AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR CO AUTHORS AND SPONSORS
FOR BRINGING THIS LONG.
LEGISLATION AND REFORM THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO NAME ADDRESS PLEASE
GO AHEAD. UNITY COUNTY I'M ALSO
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SIX SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NONTON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
RESTORE JUSTICE I MEAN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN ONLINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIX SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LEVELS OKAY- FOLLOW ASSEMBLY
CONSTANTES BORDERS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME OF MORIARTY'S LONG CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI FIFTEEN
OH NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN SIX FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BAMBI
ARAMBULA- A RESIDENT OF L. A.
COUNTY IS AN ANIMAL STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN ON NINE.
THANK YOU RYAN SIX TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
SILLY AND CHILDISH SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG AT PRODUCTS WILL
SPONSOR ALSO READING OFF- A
NUMBER OF ME I'M SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE BAY AREA SHOWING
UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE NORTH SAN
DIEGO. L. CLOSE COMMUNITY
GOVERNMENT CENTER SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE MOST OF
THE COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE AND MORAL
GOVERNING- URBAN PEACE MOVEMENT
THINKING MANY YOUNG WOMAN
STREET I'M CENTERS MARK JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS. PERSONAL BUTTONS
NEEDLES IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER AND KIRK THANK
YOU. AND AT. WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SIX EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARIA HERNANDEZ AND I'M FROM
A PLACE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
DINO COUNTY AND I AM VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. ONE FIVE
ZERO NINE THANK YOU WELL
OVERDUE. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS TINA BROWN FROM
SATURDAY AND I AM SYSTEM
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER. AND
ADVOCATE AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU RAIMES SEVEN OR
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIVE SIX EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS
ERICA WILL BE MITCHELL I'M
CALLING FROM ORANGE CALIFORNIA
WITH STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE FOR SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS COULD COUNTER
YET AS AND I'M CALLING FROM
TUSTIN CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN
OH NINE. THANK YOU RIDE FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA GARCIA
I'M A RESIDENT OF THE SITE
COUNTY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO ALIVE
AND PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
ONE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIX NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS NANCY
GARCIA I'M CALLING FROM SAN
CLEMENTE IN ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT SEVENTY THREE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL THE RUBIO I'M
CALLING FROM L. A. COUNTY I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTEEN OH NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WENDY
FORM SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUDGET I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU RYAN SIX EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS BEYOND A REPRESENTING BE A
EXCELLENT BUSINESS AND A
HEALTHY NETWORK WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE FIVE ZERO NINE H.
FOR ALOT I MEAN FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY HOW YOU DOING THIS IS A
LIVE VIA TELECOM VALLEY BEAT
BOTH PANELS THEY CALIFORNIA AND
REVOLUTIONARY SUPPORT FIFTEEN
ONLINE THANK YOU. GOOD THANK
YOU RYAN SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS YEAR
ALONG WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU I'M SEVEN OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS BETWEEN A GREEN I'M CALLING
FROM CYPRESS CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT SIXTY FIVE AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI FIFTEEN OH NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
SEVEN FOUR TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS FAILING
CALLING. I AM IN CRONK'S
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. WHAT MADE YOU WRITE FIVE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK WE SHOULD ALMOST CALLING
ON BEHALF OF AT THE JUST A
GROUP OF THE POWERBOOK FONG
THIRD INSTRUCTOR AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY THREE TO FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR PRIMARILY
SO DON'T HAVE NO MORE GOOD
PEOPLE LEAVE CALIFORNIA VOTE NO
PLEASE FOR OUR SAFETY. PLEASE.
FIVE SIX THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH AMANDA'S FRANKLIN
FROM- SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DISTRICT EIGHT AND I AM AND
STRONG STATE- FONG LAKE SUPPORT
AB- EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH TWO- VERY
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHAT FIND SIX SIX SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL MY NAME IS
STEVEN GREEN I'M LIVE IN
DISTRICT SIXTY FIVE NEXT- Q.
AND I SUPPORT AND I HOPE YOU
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OH NINE FOR
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK YOU.
FIVE SIX NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BERMAN SIX NINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SEVEN
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MAKE DANIEL FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PLACE FOR
GRACE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FIFTEEN OH NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIVE SEVEN FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARKETING DAVIS AND I'M IN A
STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL.
EIGHTEEN FIFTEE OH NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FIVE SEVEN SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN SIX
TWO. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
MENDOZA FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
DISTRICT TWELVE AND I AM IN
SHOCK REPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
RYAN SEVEN SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS BILL AND MELINDA
FROM AMERICA CALIFORNIA'S
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN ON.
YOU THANK YOU OH SEVEN SIX
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTEEN
CLICK HERE TO FILL A
COMMONALITY BARGAIN CENTER VERY
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT SIXTEEN OH
NINE THANK YOU. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I'M TONY CHAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND ON BEHALF OF JIM
CARLSON CAN CROSS ADRIN%
WOODBURY JORDAN AND KELLY
MILLER WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AGAINST THE DISASTROUS
INSENSITIVE BILL AB FIFTEEN
ONLINE THANKS THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MARIA HILL I'M
CALLING FROM LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS ALAN FALL
QUARTER BROWN SAY I'M NOT
REPRESENT YOUR MEMORY BY AREA
ASIAN AMERICAN APR I'M STRONGLY
AGAIN AB ONE FIVE OR. NINE
FIFTY STOP THEIR FIELD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEVEN SEVEN
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS RAYLENE RUIZ AND I AM
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GEORGE LEAVE A MARIN COUNTY I'M
REPRESENTING CHINESE AMERICANS
FOR FREEDOM ALL CAUCUS HERE I'M
STRONG OPPOSE. OPPOSE AB ONE
TITLE NINE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU KNOW WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I HAVE. BROICH
RIGHT GRIFFIN JUNIOR LEISURE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA RIFLE. AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND BURN
PIERSON EL DORADO COUNTY DA AND
PRESIDENT OF CD EIGHT. YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE LINE. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR. FOUR FIVE DASH
PROFILES ARE OPEN. WELL MISTER
BURN BURN PEARSON I THOUGHT
MISTER GRIFFIN HAD ASKED TO GO
FIRST- SO GOOD EVENING I'M
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK WITH
YOU BRIEFLY HERE TODAY- MY NAME
IS THE EDUCATED BIRTH PARENTS
AND I AM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF ELDORADO COUNTY AS WELL AS
THE CRRENT PRESIDENT. OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO GO BACK
TO- SEVERAL HOURS AGO AT FIRST
THANK THE CHAIR FOR BEGINNING
THIS HEARING WITH A MOMENT OF
SILENCE IN HONOR OF THE VICTIMS
AND TODAY'S GUN VIOLENCE. IN
LA- AND I'D I'D APPRECIATE THAT
IN PARTICULAR AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION BUT WE TALK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE MATH THE
SHOOTING THAT ARE GOING ON BOTH
IN CALIFORNIA AND NATIONWIDE
AND THE CONTINUED PROLIFERATION
OF GUNS IN THE HANDS OF THOSE
AND WHO INTEND TO DO HARM TO
OTHERS- NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO
MAKE GUN VIOLENCE AND THIS BILL
IS SPECIFICALLY THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ENHANCEMENT. AND AT LARGE
THIS IS ABOUT GUNS IN HAND
SPENT EIGHT SOMEONE WHO USES A
GUN I'M GOING TO DISCHARGED A
GUN FOR SOMEONE ARMED WITH A
GUN IN THE COMMISSION OF A
FELONY- NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO-
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE TYPES OF.
CRIMES SOMEONE ARMED WITH A GUN
IT'S NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS ON APRIL
SEVENTEENTH PRESIDENT BIDEN
STATED AND I QUOTE GUN VIOLENCE
IS AN EPIDEMIC IN AMERICA BUT
WE SHOULD NOT ACCEPT IT WE MUST
NOT ACT INSTEAD THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY TO THE AUTHOR-
GOES INTO THAT IT IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION. WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN THAT GUN
VIOLENCE AND CRIMES WITH
VICTIMS SUFFER SERIOUS INJURIES
ARE EXACTLY THE TYPES OF CRIMES
THAT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM MUST HANDLE WITH.
PRESIDENT CLINTON CENTER
PROPORTIONATE TO THE HARM DONE.
AND BROUGHT GOING TO BIDEN'S
WAR- AND IT RELATES TO GO
VIOLENCE- AREARE NOT JUST TYPE.
TWENTY TWENTY WITH BRASKEM BY
YEAR IN I BELIEVE IT'S TWENTY
YEARS AGO BEFORE WE HAD A YEAR
THAT WAS A VIOLENT IT'S PAST
YEAR- WORLD WERE NINETEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE KILLED
NATIONWIDE- WITH A FIREARM
OTHER THAN SUICIDE- BUT THAT'S
JUST TWENTY TWENTY. AND AT THE
END YOU KNOW LET'S FOCUS AND
TALK ABOUT MOMENT FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN THE LAST FOUR
PLUS MONTHS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MANY PEOPLE LIVING THERE FEEL
AS THOUGH THEY'RE PART OF A
LARGE SOCIAL SCIENCE
EXPERIMENT- BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
NEW DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHO IS
THIS VERY NEAT VERY ENHANCEMENT
BY DIRECTIVES ARE NOT IMPOSING
THEM. AND WHAT IS HAPPENED IN
THOSE AND ALBEIT A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME ALTHOUGH GUN CRIMES
WHEN AFTER IN HOMICIDES WENT UP
I SHOULD SAY IN LOS ANGELES
LAST YEAR BY 40% SO FAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE NUMBER
STANDS AT- FIFTY THREE
HOMICIDES. UP FROM THIRTY TWO
BLACK TYPE FOR THIS PERIOD OF
TIME LAST YEAR. WE ARE INDEED
SUFFERING AN EPIDEMIC OF GUN
CRIMES AND SHOOTING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA JUST LAST WEEK- I
SAT- WITH THE- AS PART OF A
FORUM FOR VICTIMS OF CRIME AND
THERE IS AN ASIAN AMERICAN
GENTLEMEN MY NEIGHBOR WILSON
YOUNG WHO SPOKE AT THE
EXPERIENCE OF HAVING SOMEONE
STICK A GUN IN HIS FACE. IN AN
ARMED ROBBERY IT WAS CHILLING
TO LISTEN TO HIS EXPLANATION OF
WHAT THAT EXPERIENCE WAS LIKE
AND QUESTIONING TO HIMSELF WHAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IF I HAD
BOUGHT BACK WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED TO ME AND THEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAT THE PRODUCT
FIFTEEN OH NINE IN ITS
AWARENESS OF THIS BILL. IS WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO HIM WHEN THE
PERSON WHO KEPT STUCK A GUN IN
HIS FACE AND HE TESTIFIED IN
WHAT THE COURT PROCESS ON HIM
THINKING THE PERSON WITH
SERVING LENGTHY PRISON SYSTEM
AS A RESULT OF FIFTEEN OH NINE
THIS PERSON MIGHT BE RELEASED
VERY SOON THIS TO IMPROPER TOOK
PLACE FIVE YEARS AGO- ESTONIAN
MR PEERS A PERSON. KNOWS WHERE
YOU LIVE. YOU'RE ALMOST AT THE
FOR MINUTE MARK AND MAKE. WE
GIVE ME GRIFFIN SO TIME. EVEN
THOUGH IT MAY BE A MAY TO SPEAK
IF HE'S IF HE'S ON RIGHT
GRIFFIN. FROM THE- CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION. I
DON'T SEE HIM DIE OFF THEN-
RORY IF YOU ARE ON PLEASE PRESS
STAR ZERO SO I CAN OPEN YOUR
LINE. SO MISTER PEARSON I GUESS
YOU GET THEIR LAST MINUTE. GO
FOR IT. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU. I THINK YOU MISTER KERRY
APPRECIATE THAT THE RETROACTIVE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL ARE
NOTHING SHORT OF A PUBLIC
SAFETY DISASTER WILL IMPACT THE
SENT TO THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
PROPERLY TRYING TO CONVICT AND
SENTENCE FOR COMMITTING
FELONIES USING CRIMES. OR
SERIOUSLY INJURING THEIR
VICTIMS RESULTING IMMEDIATE
RELEASE THAT MANY OF THEM. I WE
ARE THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NUMBER LOOK INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
CENA AND GOING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. PROPTER SEEN
ANY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
FIFTEEN OH NINE LEE C. N. NINE.
AND AGAIN WILL OPEN UP TO A
LIFE. EVEN THOUGH I HEARD QUITE
A FEW PEOPLE. COME ON IN UP. ON
THE PHONE EIGHTEEN AB. FIFTEEN
OH NINE THREE. Q. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN OWN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
FORTY IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
MARLENE TRANSPORTS PERSON FOR
VISITATION VALLEY ASIAN
ALLIANCE FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ELDERLY
AND NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
VICTIMS AND THE FAMILIES WHO
ARE STRONGLY A MAJOR DESIGN
SHOULD BE FIFTEEN OH NINE.
PATIENTS THAT EIGHT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION NEXT. THANK YOU
I'M SEVEN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M GAIL
STEWARD ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEPHAN WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIDE SIX EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MATURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FIFTEEN OR NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEVEN NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DETERMINE
MEMBERS THIS IS ROY GRIP ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION GUNNERS
CALIFORNIA NOW SHORTFALL
SOCIALIZATION FONG OPPOSITION
TO FIFTEEN ZERO NINE I
APOLOGIZE EARLIER MY PHONE WENT
DEAD RIGHT AS WE WERE. MADE UP
AND I COULDN'T GET BACK. BUT I
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT WE ARE
TRYING TO THE STATE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT EIGHT TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT'S WHY BROWN ON
BEHALF OF STORAGE AT TWO AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN OH NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
SEVEN OH NINE THREE FOUR HAS.
SEVEN ZERO ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WAIT YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I YES I WASN'T GIVEN THE NUMBER-
MY NAME TO BE NICE SAMPLE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND- ZHONGLI
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN ALL NIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SIX SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. FIVE THREE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS DOCTOR A
MENTION OF THE OPS OF ASIAN
AMERICAN GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA- WE'LL CLOSE AB ONE
FIVE OH NINE ON BEHALF OF ALL
MEMBERS WHO BELIEVED VIOLENT
ARMED CRIMINALS SHOULD BE
PUNISHED AND LAW ABIDING GUN
OWNERS SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXPAND IT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
ACADEMICS SPECIAL FATHERLESS
HOUSEHOLDS EXPLAINED DISPARITY
OF OUTCOME NOT. RACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CARLOS TRAIL FOR DAILY LIVE
CLOSE A. B. ONE FIVE THREE NINE
THANK YOU. WHAT ARE WE DONE.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT FROM OUR
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE. THANK YOU WRITE YOUR NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JEANNIE- SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AT EIGHTY ONE FIVE- NOT
STRONGLY OPPOSED OPPOSED. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO ALIVE IN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY. TWO ONE ONE. TWENTY
NINE. RIGHT TO FIVE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE READ BORN
IN POMONA CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ONE AND ONLY
CRIME SURVIVORS INK AND KEEP
CALIFORNIA SAFE WE'D LIKE TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE VERY NEXT
REPRESENTED AND ANTI BIG FAN AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS THOMAS TOYS FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I'M OPPOSED TO- AB
ONE FIVE ZERO NINE. THANK YOU
I'M THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN. THREE TO FIVE. NINE
THREE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO THIS IS LIANNA ASSEMBLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY FIFTEEN
OH NINE. Q. RIGHT FOR NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRANNER PLEASE
PRINT SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
FIFTEEN OH NINE AND THERE'S
ABOUT HALF A DOZEN PEOPLE THAT
HAVE NOT WITH EACH NUMBERS YET.
CATION WHY SHE WAS LATE GETTING
UP AND- THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JIM
CARVER ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGANS
AGAINST CRIME WE OPPOSE FIFTEEN
OH NINE BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
ANSWER TO GUN VIOLENCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT SEVEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MAPPING THE MORE FROM YOLO
COUNTY CALLING TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE FIVE ZERO NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FIND FIVE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS CARLA LOW I'M WITH
AMERICANS AGAINST LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA GOOD PENALTIES ARE
THE KEY TO PREVENTION WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE ONE FIVE ZERO
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUSINESS
ADDRESS WHAT IS FROM. SECOND
PLACE ADVOCATE GROUP AND STRONG
SUPPORT SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE MEMBERS SUPPORT AB. ONE
FIVE ZERO NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RAIMES THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT ZERO I OR-
SEVEN. SEVEN I'M SURE YOU
MEDICAL REGION ADDING IN YOUR
CAREER HELLO WHAT WORKED HER.
FIVE SIX TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
I COULD GET HEARING PRESIDENT
OF YELLOW COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION FOR AB FIFTY NINE
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SIX FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS
LAURIE PROP ON BEHALF OF OUR
THREE HUNDRED BLOCK MEMBERS
FROM THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FIFTEEN OH NINE IT IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM THANK YOU. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT CHIU FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. YOU
SENT ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I WILL SEND YOUNG THAT THAT
DISTRICT ANY MENTION I LOOK AT
CRIME WE CAN YOU KNOW IN CHINA
FIVE YEARS AGO AND THEY CAN
POINT. I AM QUITE NINETY MANY
STATE AUTO ALBEIT AT THE STATE.
BOTH LOCAL EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH
NINE BECAUSE OUR ALLIES
CALIFORNIA BE LOOKING MANY MANY
STATES WE ARE THE LUCKY ONES
WHO TO DATE WHICH SB ONE ROOM
HERE BUT THE ONE WHO THE-
CULPRIT PHOTO AP YOU KNOW NOT A
LOT BUT- THANK YOU BRIAN. SEVEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
YES GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS
CHERYL MODEL AMERICA'S ARMED
COME FROM ASSEMBLY TELL CONTE
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. FIFTEEN
OH NINE FIFTY MORE. VERY
IMPORTANT TO EVERYONE. THANK
YOU BRIAN SEVEN NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE AISLE
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
AM NO NO NO STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
IT AB FIFTEEN OH NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOUR SEVEN NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MALINA
MADRIGAL FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HI I'M LISA MAC I'M
CALLING FROM SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA I'M AN ASIAN IMMIGRANTS TO
THE COUNTRY AND THE MOTHER OF
TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN OH NINE I DO NOT FEEL
SAFE IN MY COMMUNITY AND I'M
SPEAKING UP NOW. SO THAT I
COULD NOT BECOME A- THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS TO
REPORT THE SECOND DIRECTOR FOR
SOMETHING TYPICAL MAINTAIN
POWER MEN CENTER AT NEARLY
PRESENT I WE HAVE MEMBER OF A
TWO HUNDRED PLUS MEMBER AND WE
ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHT
THREE ONE FIVE ZERO NINE THANK
YOU. IF YOU CHANGE YOUR MIND.
SIX FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SIX FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
JENNIFER'S SON CAN COME FROM.
LARA COUNTRY ALL RIGHT-
STRONGLY OPPOSITE DOES SHOCK.
EIGHTY ONE FIVE ZERO NINE THIS
IS CONTEMPLATE AND STICKY.
THANK YOU. NINE SIX NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
WATERS FROM A. K. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU RITE AID- THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS THE
WAY TEN I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED AB. ONE FIVE
OH NINE. THANK YOU I'M SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT TO SIXTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
EIGHT HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WITH THE AUSTIN LEE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE V. FIFTEEN OH NINE. THANK
YOU RYAN FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE TWO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT SEVEN OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS SALLY ANN CHAU I'M FROM
ALCOHOL CALIFORNIA AS AN ASIAN
MOM OF TWO YOUNG KIDS I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE EVEN THOUGH I WAIT FIVE
HOURS I'M VERY HAPPY TO HAVE
THE CHANCE TO TELL YOU THAT
PLEASE SAY NO TO THIS FIELD TO
GIVE OUR KIDS A SIX. THANK YOU
RYAN SIX FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS I REMEMBER
CLOUT FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED FIFTY DON'T
DIE IT IS NOT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU RIGHT THREE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GLORIA MITCHELL OF ST BERNARD
DINO AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO AB FIFTEEN OH NINE ON BEHALF
OF VICTIMS. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER SERVICE TERM AGREEMENT
ON THE CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTAL CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND IN A REMEMBER
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHT FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME OF COURSE
TAYLOR AND I'M CALLING
REPRESENTATION PRISON FROM THE
INSIDE OUT. WITH OVER THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS STRONG AND WE
ARE A STRONG SUPPORT AND-
FIFTEEN ONLINE. THANK YOU RIGHT
SEVEN EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVEN EIGHT ZERO. FIND SIX
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA AND I AM FROM
GLOUCESTER COUNTY AND I AM A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE FILE.
THANK YOU I'M THREE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
FRANKLY I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
ORGANIZATION FOR JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY WE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
AB ONE FIVE ALL NIGHT WHICH
ENDANGERS EVERYONE IT SEEMED
AND BORDERS PEOPLE TO COMPETE.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE
TWO FIVE. FIVE SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY SIX EIGHT
EIGHT. RIGHT THIRTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS RANGE
FROM A WITH RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S.
AND SANTA ANA POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION AB
FIFTEEN ONLINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT EIGHT FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THE CO
PRESIDENT. STRONGLY OR- EIGHTY
ONE FIVE ZERO NINE. THANK YOU I
DON'T PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS MY CAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD I THANK YOU
THAT WHILE IT I AM A CURRENT
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I'M ALSO A
FORMER VICTIM OF A VIOLENT
CRIME AND I WRONGLY IS
VEHEMENTLY APPROACH. AB FIFTEEN
OH NINE. THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHT
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. Y.
EIGHT FOUR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA COULD HEAR
SOME REPRESENTING CRIED IN
TRUTH AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- WE ARE THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF ENHANCEMENTS ARE
FOCUSED ON BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES SO ON BEHALF OF
OVER A HUNDRED MEMBERS AND THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE THANK YOU
LETTER WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. AB
ONE FIVE OH NINE. THANK YOU
RYAN EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA GOMEZ WITH PRIVATE
INSURERS- COMING FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF BOYLE HEIGHTS- AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT. FIFTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS YOUR LANDA NUMBER READY
AND I'M UPON YOUR COUNTY
CONSTITUENTS AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE OH NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHT SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALRIGHT J. PROGRESS SAN
FRANCISCO ON BEHALF OF VICTIMS
ADVOCATES OF AMERICA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AGAINST THE
UNACCEPTABLE BILL AB SIXTEEN OH
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
EIGHT FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY HI MY NAME IS
CLARA GARCIA I'M CALLING FROM
THE CITY OF MANTECA IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE FIVE OH
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RITE
AID SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M MICHAEL WILL CURIOUS
WITH A CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OR
NINE. THANK YOU RYAN SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS NANCY TOWN
AND CAREER PROSECUTORS SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA THE
CHARLIE OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN NON
IONIZATION. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER RISING YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- WITH THAT WILL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS FOR MR LAKE MR LACKEY
FIRST YEAH I REALLY DON'T HAVE.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS I JUST HVE
SOME REMARKS TO SHARE- I'M
SORRY TO DASH THE HOPES OF THE
EARLIER CALLER BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL- IT DOESN'T
ACT IN THE. THE INTEREST OF
PUBLIC SAFETY INSTEAD IT IT'S
MORE OFFENDER SAFETY. AND I
FIND IT INTERESTING THAT. THE
MAJORITY OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
MANY MEMBERS IN THIS BUILDING.
HAVE A REAL STRONG FOCUS AND
ENERGY TOWARD. GUN ACQUISITION
OF POSSESSION. YET THAT WERE
VERY RELAXED STANDARD ON GOOD
BEHAVIOR. I'M NOT I FIND THAT
TO BE VERY INCONSISTENT AND
UNFORTUNATE. BUT THE I'LL KEEP
MY REMARKS SIMPLE JUST SAY IT'S
NOT UNFORTUNATE I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL. AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT I'M VOTING ON THANK YOU.
YES THIS IS SURE TO EVEREST
SPORTS BONTA MMHM YOU CANNOT DO
IT IN YOUR TOTAL. FOR SO CAN
RESPOND TO THIS ONE- TALK ABOUT
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
ENHANCEMENTS. EFFECTIVELY DOING
WHAT BECAUSE I THINK MAYBE MY
EFFECTIVE EFFECTIVENESS OF IT
IS DIFFERENT THAN YOURS I WANT
YOU WHAT YOURS IS. SO TO BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE IT'S ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT EXCESSIVE AND RACES
SENTENCING AND OVER
INCARCERATION IN OUR SOCIETY.
IT IS NOT. A GUN CONTROL
MEASURE BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW
IF WE WAITED TILL THE
SENTENCING TO A PERSON IS
CONVICTED WE SLAP ON SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE HAVE
FAILED TO PROACTIVE PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE. GUN SAFETY IS GUN
CONTROL UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS MAKING SURE DANGEROUS
WEAPONS ARE ON THE STREETS
THAT'S PREVENTATIVE THIS IS AN
EXCESSIVE RESPONSE AND I JUST
WANT ALSO MAKE SURE TO KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW IF SOMEONE DOES
COMMIT A CRIME THEY STILL SERVE
THEIR STATUTORY SENTENCE THEY
STILL SERVICE. GUN ENHANCEMENTS
ARE AN ADULT ADD ON THAT CAN
SOMETIMES MAGNIFIED A CLUB
MAGNIFIED THERE- SUCH AS FOR
MUCH MORE SO I THINK LIKE I
SAID IF WE- IF THESE WERE.
EFFECTIVE MEASURES PREVENTING
GUN CRIME THEN WE WOULD SEE
THAT WE SEE THE RESULTS IN A
REALITY THAT WOULD BE THE
SAFEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD AND
YET WERE NOT WORN OUT WHERE
THESE THINGS. ARE IT ALSO
OBVIOUSLY AS I SAID IN MY
OPENING EVERY YEAR OF
INCARCERATION. LEADS AT LEAST
47% CHANCE OF RECENT INCREASED
CHANCE OF RECIDIVISM SO BY ANY
METRIC I DON'T THINK WE'RE
SUCCEEDING AND- WASTING.
UPWARDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PER PERSON JUST TO KEEP SOMEONE
OVERLY INCARCERATED SO I WOULD
SAY BY FISCAL METRICS BUYER
SEVEN METRICS ABOUT GUN SAFETY
METRICS IT'S NOT WORKING. SO I
WOULD SAY BY MY METRIC WHICH IS
WE KEEP THE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
PERPETRATE CRIMES LIKE THIS
SOME PEOPLE SEPARATE FROM THE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS THAT ARE
JUST DO MINE IN THEIR OWN
BUSINESS WHEN THEY GET A GUN
STUCK IN THEIR FACE- HI I THINK
IT IS EFFECTIVE. AND I THINK
ONE PERSON HAS A CHOICE AND
THAT'S THE PERSON THAT DOES THE
GUN STICKING IN THERE FOR
STICKING IT IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
FACE THEY HAVE A CHOICE TO
THINK ABOUT. WHETHER THEY FEEL
LIKE DOING. THE EX TIME. FOR
USING THAT GUN. AND TERRIFYING
SOME VICTIMS AND THE VICTIM
DOES NOT HAVE A CHOICE THEY
JUST SIT THERE BE VICTIMIZED
AND SO THAT'S WHERE I THINK
THAT YEAH I THINK THAT'S THE
WAY OUR DIFFERENCE IN
PHILOSOPHIES IS THAT I AM ALL
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE
VICTIMS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
PROTECTED HERE AND YEAH I DO
WANT TO HELP PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO HELP THEMSELVES. BUT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO IGNORE THE
SENTENCING NICK ENHANCEMENTS
AND DO IT ANYWAY AND TERRORIZE
SOMEBODY BY STICKING A GUN IN
THE FACE AND BY THE WAY DOESN'T
FEEL VERY GOOD- I CAN TELL YOU
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT I DON'T FEEL SORRY
FOR YOU YOU GOT TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND WE GOT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS DOING
ITS HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
STATISTICS ARE FOR THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T DO THE
CRIME BECAUSE THEY DID THINK
ABOUT HEY YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T
FEEL LIKE GO ON GOING UP UP THE
RIVER. FOR TWENTY MORE YEARS.
FOR USING A GUN. WE HAVE THOSE
STATISTICS BECAUSE WE DON'T DO
STUDIES ON THIS. AND THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT I THINK ABOUT.
AND BEFORE ANYTHING I THINK
ABOUT THE VICTIMS. AND THAT'S
WHY I'M TIMES CAN'T BE
SUPPORTING- LEGISLATION LIKE.
THANK YOU. WICKS THANK THANK
YOU AND MISTER CHAIR- I ONE
THING THE OTHER BRING THE BILL
FOR IT IT'S A THORNY ISSUE FOR
SURE AS AS NOTED BY I THINK THE
BOTH OF PRO AND CON FOLKS WHO
ARE WEIGHING IN ACROSS THE
STATE- I TOTALLY AGREE
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS DON'T
WORK TO DETER CRIME I TOTALLY
AGREE WE HAVE YOU KNOW MAJOR
RACIAL INEQUITIES WITHIN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. RACISM
EMBEDDED WITHIN OUR CREDIT
PROMOTE JUSTICE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED- I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT ONE THING I
WOULD STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER AND I WOULD BE. MORE
THAN IT IS YESTERDAY SUPPORTER
IS COULD BECOME THE- WAS THE
SAVINGS THAT YOU GET FROM THIS.
THAT YOU PUT INTO OUR CALVET
CALIFORNIA WANTS AN
INTERVENTION PREVENTION
PROGRAMS THAT WERE. ALWAYS
TRYING TO GET MONEY FOR EVERY
SINGLE YEAR- YOU KNOW I CARRY
THE BUDGET ASK ON THAT I'M
ALWAYS. LOVING THE GOVERNOR
LOVING SPEAKER LOBBYING SENATE
PRO TEM THE BAR BUDGET CHAIRS
TO INCREASE THAT MONEY. THAT
SUPPORTS PROGRAMS. NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE FROM
THESE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE DOING
VERY EFFECTIVE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION WORK AND IT'S
STOPPING VIOLENCE BEFORE IT
STARTS. AND IT NEEDS AN ONGOING
FUNDING STREAM. SO I WOULD JUST
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO- TO
CONSIDER THAT I WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT SHOULD
YOU BE INTERESTED IN. PURSUING
THAT PATH. THANK YOU MR BURKE.
MOVE THE BILL. THANK MISBACH
GALA. THANK YOU- MR LEAVE FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND TELL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS
ON THIS BILL THIS IS A HARD ONE
AND YOU KNOW I AM A
LONGSTANDING SUPPORTER OF GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION I THINK TO
YOUR POINT ALL OF THE DATA
SHOWS US THAT LONG SENTENCES
DON'T PREVENT CRIME BUT IT'S
NOT MAKING US SAFER AND IT'S
JUST LEADING TO OVER
INCARCERATION. AND SO I THINK
TO MISS WEEKES IS POINT WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT HOW WE
PREVENT THIS CRIME IN REALLY
MEANINGFUL WAYS AND NOT JUST.
IN PERSUADING PEOPLE FOR
DECADES- TIER POINTS
INDIVIDUALS WILL STILL SERVE
THEIR UNDERLYING SENTENCE NO
MATTER WHAT THE CRIME WAS THAT
WAS COMMITTED. HE ALSO RETAIN
SOME ENHANCEMENTS IN THIS BILL-
AND I THINK THAT THAT
PROSPECTIVELY IS. REALLY- MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE ADAM YOU KNOW
LISTENING TO YOUR FIRST WITNESS
ABOUT. AND WHAT IT MEANS TO SIT
IN A ROOM WITH THE DEFENDANT
AND TELL THEM. THAT THEY SHOULD
GO TO TRIAL BECAUSE THE
SENTENCE IS GOING TO BE TOO
INSANE IF THEY DO AND THE RISK
ISN'T WORTH IT I'VE DONE THAT
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE'S
SAYING AND I THINK THAT. THAT'S
REALLY WE NEED TO UNDER. EACH
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING. AT THE
SAME TIME HAVING. BEEN IN THOSE
ROOMS I ALSO KNOW HOW PLEA
DEALS ARE MADE. AND SO THE FACT
THAT THIS IS RETROACTIVE IS
CONCERNING TO ME BECAUSE DEALS
WERE MADE. AND WE ARE GOING
BACK ON THOSE DEALS IN WAYS
THAT THEY COULD HAVE BEEN MADE
PROBABLY. IN DIFFERENT WAYS HAD
THIS BEEN IN PLACE AT THE TIME.
AND SO I KNOW THAT YOU AND I
DISCUSSED IT AND I WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE. COMFORTABLE
IT IF THERE WAS SOME JUDICIAL
DISCRETION OR SOME. REVIEW OF
THE RETROACTIVE PIECE TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE SERVING A JUST
SENTENCE THAT THEY ARE NOT. A
THREAT TO THE COMMUNITY- AND
THAT YOU KNOW IT IS TIME TO LET
THEM OUT AND SO. I JUST WANNA
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THEIR ATTRACTIVE THE
PEACE. YES CERTAINLY AND I
THANK YOU SO EVER CANNED FOR
BRING THIS- THIS ISSUE TO MY
ATTENTION AND- AS WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL BACK AND FORTH TODAY
I'M REALLY COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. OF OUR
PROCESS IN MIND. BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT ULTIMATELY WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE AS WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
A SITUATION THAT PLAYS OUT
THAT. LEAD TO HAVING SOMEONE
HAVE THEIR JUSTICE DEPEND ON
THE COUNTY RECEIVED A
CONVICTION AND- MIGHT MY
SPONSORS AND ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH WORKING WITH YOU. AND
OTHERS ARE INTERESTED. TO
FIGURE OUT DETAILS OF A
JUDICIAL DISCRETION METHOD WITH
A STRONG PRESUMPTION. THAT
HOPEFULLY FAVORS THE FIRST
THREE SENSING AS WE ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THIS NEW. NEW
SYSTEM. SO IT'LL BE DIFFERENT I
PROMISE TO KEEP WORKING WITH
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR STRONG
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS I MEAN JUST
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY WERE
YOU. I'M TAKING OUT SOME OF THE
MORE EGREGIOUS CRIMES I THINK
SHOWS A WILLINGNESS TO REALLY
MEET THE LEGISLATURE WHERE WE
ARE AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
LOOK FOR TO WORKING ON IT ALL
SUPPORTED TODAY SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- IF I MAY I'LL SHARE
SOMETHING. OR THIS IS A SCORE
MISQUOTED YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
OKAY OKAY IF I IF I COULD I
PERSONAL ON ALSO READ AN
EXCERPT FROM A LETTER I GOT
FROM INCARCERATED VIGIL AN
EXCERPT IF THAT'S POSSIBLE. I
WAS THE FIRST YOU KNOW JUST
WANT TO THANK THE MANY MANY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CALLED IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO WRITTEN SO
MANY LETTERS AND ALSO TO OVER
THE PHONE OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY INCARCERATE
INDIVIDUALS OF WRITTEN SUPPORT-
ONE OF THEM. HAS ARE INTO ME
PERSONALLY AS WELL AND I WAS
VERY TOUCHED BY THE LETTER OF
COURSE THE TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS BEFORE I READ. THAT
LETTER I JUST WANNA SAY YOU
KNOW. THIS BILL IS A SAID HAS
HIS ULTIMATELY ABOUT EXCESSIVE
RACES RACES SENTENCING TO
PERPETUATE INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
IN OUR SYSTEM RIGHT. AND
SOMETHING THAT I FIND QUITE
DISTURBING IS WHEN FOLKS
OUTSIDE OF MY COMMUNITY COME
INTO IT AND THEY'VE PREY ON THE
FEARS AND ANXIETIES OF THE SE
ASIAN AMERICANS DURING THESE
TIMES AND HAVING THAT KIND OF.
A TOUGH ON CRIME RHETORIC AND
THAT IDEA HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY
SOLD TO OUR COMMUNITY SINCE THE
DAY WE ARRIVE IN THE SHORE IS A
DIVISIVE IS THE BASE OF A
SPECIALIZED COMMITTEES A CALLER
AND I THINK IT'S QUITE FITTING
THAT I AS SOMEONE BORN IN THE
NINETIES IS TRYING TO UNDO THE
HARM DONE IN THE NINETIES- TO
PROBABLY DO THAT. BUT I JUST
WANT TO READ A QUICK EXCERPT
FIVE IF I MAY ABOUT A LETTER
THAT I GOT I PERSONALLY
FACILITIES INCARCERATED JUST
REITERATE THAT THESE ARE REAL
HUMAN BEINGS WITH LIVES THAT
ARE BEING LOST REAL POTENTIAL
THAT. THAT THAT IS NOT BEING
REALIZED- THIS FIRST WRITES ME
THAT I WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD
AT THE TIME OF MY CRIME MY WAY
OF THINKING WAS DISTORTED I WAS
YOUNG AND I DIDN'T KNOW BETTER.
I REGRET MY INVOLVEMENT AND
SINCE SEVEN PARTICIPATING A
POSITIVE GROUP GROUPS EDUCATION
ENGAGING ANY AND ALL
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AS AN
ADOLESCENT IN THE PRISON PRISON
SYSTEM I DEVELOP AN ATTITUDE OF
I DON'T CARE WHO DO I HAVE TO
LOSE. AS TOUGH AS TIME PASSED
EXPERIENCE GROWTH THAT CHANGED
MY MENTALITY AND OLD WAYS OF
THINKING I TIME TO REFLECT THE
REALITY OF MY TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF A SENTENCE THE
NEW MIND SET A CLEAR VISION I
WILL CONTINUE TO BETTER MYSELF
I PLAN. ON UTILIZING MY
EXPERIENCE TO BECOME AN AD IT
TO HELP LEAD A- AWAY FROM
FALLING VICTIM THE STREETS
EVENTUALLY THE SYSTEM I WANT TO
GIVE BACK TO MY COMMUNITY AND
FIND WAYS ASSIST THOSE
TRANSITION BACK INTO SOCIETY I
DESERVE A SECOND CHANCE TO
PROVE WORTHY OF MY DREAM AT A
NEW LIFE OUTSIDE OF THESE
CONCRETE WALLS AND I WAS A
LETTER SENT PERSONALLY TO ME. I
WAS QUITE IMPRESSED THAT GOT TO
BE AS WELL SO I JUST WANT TO-
THANK YOU ARE MEMBERS OF THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION TODAY IN
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND IT WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU ALL
TO MAKE SURE THAT- YOUR NEEDS
THE CONCERNS ARE MET AND AGAIN
ONE EIGHT A RATE THAT YOU KNOW
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN VERY OPEN
ABOUT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT EVEN
WITH OPPOSITION OF HOW WE MAKE
IT WORKABLE. AND I JUST WANNA-
GEORGE I'VE UP TODAY THANK YOU
AND- HE CHURCH RECOMMEND I PUT
I ALSO AM CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE
THE MONEY GOES I THINK THAT'S A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA IDEA DATA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS BROUGHT
UP. IF YOU NEED HELP WITH THAT
SINCE TO SIT ON BUDGET AND HOW
MUCH SUPPLY I WOULD MORE THAN
HAPPY TO TRY TO GET MORE MONEY
FOR VICTIMS AND ORGANIZATIONS
TO HANDLE SO. BUT MAN I VOTE.
CABALLERO THE BILL'S. MOVED
INTO. AB KNOWN BISA A MEMBER OF
THE MOST. IS DUE. TO THE
APPROPRIATE. COMMITTEE JOHNSON-
ACTIONS I AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
NOW BARKING AND- BARKING AND I
A CORK. CORK I SAN DIEGO. CA
ARE TO. KNOW THEIR TEN NO
WICKS. LEE HI B. I. YES I
REMEMBER JONES SAWYER EUROPE
WOULD THEY BE EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU- MEMBERS AND CHAIRS
AND I WAS TOO LATE I AM HERE
TODAY TO REJECT AB EIGHTY NINE
TO PEACE OFFICER EDUCATION IN
H. CONDITIONS FOR EMPLOYMENT
ACT. FOR THE PEACE ACT RELY ON
A DECADES THE DATA THE PEACE
AFTER INCREASE THE CURRENT
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR ALL PEACE
OFFICERS IN CALIFORNIA FROM
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD WITH A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA TWO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD OR HOLD A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. RIGHT SIZE SHOWS THAT
INCREASING THE AGE REQUIREMENT
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD WILL
ALLOW FOR FULL BRAIN MATURATION
FOR THE PORTIONS WERE BOUGHT
AFFECTING JUDGMENT AND DECISION
MAKING. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
CRUCIAL WHEN OFFICES ARE PUT
INTENSE SITUATIONS WORKING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES IN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. FURTHERMORE STUDIES
SHOW THAT A FOR YOUR COLLEGE
EDUCATION SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES
OFFICERS PROPENSITY TO COMMIT
EXCESSIVE FORCE INCIDENTS WHEN
OFFICERS WITH NO MORE THAN A
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION. MAKE UP
75% OF ALL DISCIPLINARY ACTION
SOME COLLEGE IS NOT ENOUGH
IMPROVING OFFICER ENTRY
REQUIREMENTS WILL ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF COLOR WHO
DISPROPORTIONATELY FALL VICTIM
TO OFFICES SAYS OF COURSE. TWO
WEEKS AGO I PULLED THE PIECE
THAT FROM THIS COMMITTEE. SO
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND I COULD
HAVE A CONVERSATION. AND THAT
WAS THE DATA BACK AND NOT
MERELY A SUMPTER. SINCE THEN
I'VE HAD MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHERE MY
OFFICE SHARED RESEARCH SHOWING
INCREASED HIGHER EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT HAMPERED
RECRUITMENT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IN FACT WHEN WE RAISE THOSE
STANDARDS AND ARE INTENTIONAL
ABOUT WHO WE HIRE WE CAN
ACTUALLY INCREASE RECRUITS OF
COLOR AS WE MOVE THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD I AIM TO STAY TRUE TO
THE DATA. WITH AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS ISSUE
I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
IN FACT. WE'VE HAD MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH SEVERAL.
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS SOME OF
WHICH YOU WOULD BE SURPRISED
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO NOT
ONLY LOOKING AT THE BILLS FROM
THE- FOURTEEN OF BILLS FROM THE
OTHER SIDE AND MAYBE BRING INTO
THIS POLICY BUT MOVING FORWARD
WITH SOME. WITH SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON HOW WE CAN MOVE
THIS FORWARD THE PEACE ACT WILL
NOT. WOULD NOT ONLY
PROFESSIONAL ICE POLICING BUT
WILL ALSO CHANGE THE DEPARTMENT
CULTURE AWAY FROM EXCESSIVE
FORCE CONSISTENT WITH A BETTER
EDUCATED MORE MATURE FOR
FOURTH. WISH ME TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL IS DR HOPEFULLY SHE
STILL THERE BECAUSE SHE WAS A
GOOD A BIBLE STUDY AT SEVEN. SO
I'M SHUT UP TO WE GET AROUND-
RESEARCHER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. UNIVERSITY FULLERTON AND
ESTEBAN NO YES DIRECTOR
ADVOCATES INCOME OR- FROM THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION CO
SPONSOR. OF THE PEACE ACT. OKAY
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE THAT ECHO
ON THE LINE. IF THAT DOCTOR
GARDNER I'M ON THE LINE YES WE
WENT BACK TO GUARD OKAY YEAH GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME AND- MANY MEMBERS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT RAISING THE
MINIMUM EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR PEOPLE. HE HOWEVER I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED THAT EIGHTY
EIGHTY NINE IS CURRENTLY
READING COULD HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON HIRING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ESPECIALLY
IN LOW RESOURCE COMMUNITIES. IT
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
PHASED IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING
RECRUITMENT AND HIRING SUPPORT
FOR AGENCIES ESPECIALLY IN LOW
RESOURCE AGENCIES AND IT SHOULD
PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR STUDENTS
INTO THE PROFESSION THAT
INCLUDES SUPPORTS TO GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE. WE THINK OF THE
INVOLVED IT'S TIME THAT OUR
MINIMUM EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
RESPECT THE INCREASED
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROFESSION
AND OUR EXPECTATION THAT
OFFICERS THE MASTER PROBLEM
SOLVERS NOT SIMPLY REPORT
WRITERS. YOUR EVIDENCE THAT IT
DEGREE PROMOTE POLICE.
LEGITIMATE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND RAISING THE MINIMUM
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT AT THE
STATE LEVEL SHOULD HELP YOU
COLLIDE THE PLAYING FIELD SO
THAT WE HAVE COLLEGE EDUCATED
OFFICERS WORKING IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY. NOT JUST OUR HIGH
INCOME COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES CURRENTLY
REPORT THEY'RE HAVING A REAL
DIFFICULT TIME HIRING YOU
APPLICANTS THE NUMEROUS OPEN
POSITIONS AND MANY APPLICANTS
DO NOT MEET MINIMUM HIRING
STANDARDS. IT WOULD BE A TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCE IF THIS LEGISLATION
FORCED AGENCES TO CHOOSE A
COLLEGE GRADUATE WITH
QUESTIONABLE MORALS OVER A NON
IMPECCABLE CHARACTER. THIS IS A
REAL POSSIBILITY ESPECIALLY IN
LOW PAYING AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO IN LARGE
AGENCIES WITH MANY VACANCIES.
WHICH NUMBER THAT RAISING
MINIMUM EDUCATION REQUIREMENT
WILL NECESSARILY REDUCE HIRING
OF MINORITY AND FEMALE
CANDIDATES. WHILE SOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO COLLEGE AS WELL AS
LOW RETENTION AND GRADUATION
RATES IN COLLEGE AND THAT DOES
ADD A NEW BARRIER TO ENTRY
PEOPLE BY TALK FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE. AND IMPOVERISHED
RECRUIT IT DOES NOT HAVE TO
RESULT IN YOUR POLICE OFFICERS.
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS. MY
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT AGENCY
WITH HIGHER EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND QUITE DIVERSE
WORKFORCES. RAISING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD NOT
NEGATIVELY AFFECT MINORITY
RECRUITMENT AGENCY WITH
ORIGINAL POLICY REQUIRING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE TO BE HIRED
HAVE BETTER MINORITY
REPRESENTATION THAT AGENCIES
THAT REQUIRE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN PRACTICE. BUT
SOMETHING LACK BY READING
POLICY. ALSO THE PERCENT OF
MINORITY OFFICERS IN AN AGENCY
IS PRIMARILY RELATED TO
COMMUNITY FACTORS SUCH A POP
POPULATION DEMOGRAPHICS HOWEVER
THE PERCENT OF COLLEGE EDUCATED
OFFICERS IN THE DEPARTMENT IS
PRIMARILY DETERMINED BY EACH OF
THE FACTORS. SUCH AS MINIMUM
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AGENCY
FIVE AGENCIES HI HI THAT SORT
OF THING. AND WOMEN ARE
GENERALLY MORE EDUCATED THAN
THEIR MALE COUNTERPARTS SO IT'S
UNLIKELY TO BE AFFECTED BY A
CHANGING MINIMUM EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. PORTS FOR
STUDENTS BE INCLUDED IN THE
BILL TO ENSURE POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION EVERY COMMUNITY CAN
BECOME POLICE OFFICERS. I HAVE
IDEAS ON HOW TO BUILD A
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATION DEGREE
PROGRAM THAT I'M HAPPY TO THE
GAPS FOR ANYBODY WHO'S
INTERESTED. WE COULD FOR
EXAMPLE MODELED ON A BSN DEGREE
PROGRAM OR ON CAL STATE
SACRAMENTO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CANDIDATES CALLERS PROGRAM.
THAT HELPS PREPARE UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS FOR PRE EMPLOYMENT
TESTS AND POLICE ACADEMY. SO IN
CLOSING THIS BILL CAN HELP YOU
FOR A COLLEGE EDUCATED OFFICERS
EQUITABLY ACROSS THE STATE AND
THAT COULD MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION TO IMPROVING
POLICE PERFORMANCE OF
LEGITIMACY. THROUGHOUT THE
STREET AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE FOCUS OF A BEATING ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY NINE. I'M
REQUIRING A BACHELOR'S DEGREES.
FOR WORK AT THE PUMP CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICER BUT WOULD LIKE.
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THEM.
SPEAKING AMENDMENTS. THE BELL
I'M FEEL SHARED. WE CAN I ALSO.
APERTURE FUTURE. AND ACCESS TO
I'M GLAD FROM COLLEGE FOR THEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
ESTEBAN LEARN YES. I YES SIR-
BY CHURCH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NOT
SPONTANEOUS I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF ADVOCACY AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING WHAT THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M ALSO
KNOWN AS A R. C. A. R. T.
MEMBERS NOW WHAT VERY WELL THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING- PEACE
OFFICERS ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
WORK IN CORRECTIONS WHO HAVE
THE MENTAL CAPACITY TO MAKE
OBJECTIVE DECISIONS IN HIGH
STRESSFUL AND HIGH STAKES
SITUATIONS. WILL NOT CONTINUE
TO RECOGNIZE AND HAVE POLICIES
THAT REFLECT BRAIN SCIENCE THE
PREFRONTAL CORTEX WHICH GOVERNS
THE EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONS OF
REASONING ADVANCED POT AND
IMPULSE CONTROL IS NOT FULLY.
DEVELOPED UNTIL THE MID
TWENTIES. THIS IS SHOULD BE
REFLECT IN THE THAT GUIDE OUR
LOGS OFFICERS. HAVING
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE BRAINS HAVE
FULLY DEVELOPED OR WHO HAVE THE
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND TO
DEVELOP A DEEPENED
UNDERSTANDING OF THE VARIOUS
FACTORS THAT PLAY INTO
CRIMINALITY SUCH AS TRAUMA. IN
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY WILL
REDUCE THE RISK OF UNLAWFUL OR
IMPULSIVE USE OF COURSE AND
INCREASE THE PROBABILITY OF
REHABILITATION FOR THOSE
INCARCERATED. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOWN FORMALLY INCARCERATED I
SPENT SIX YEARS IN PRISON FOR.
A TRAGIC IMMATURE DECISIONS
THAT I MADE IN MY YOUTH. DURING
MY TIME INCARCERATED I WORKED
HARD- TO WORK THROUGH MY
CHILDHOOD TRAUMAS AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT DROVE ME TO
MAKE THE MATURE DECISION BUT I
DID. IN DOING SO I THOUGHT
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE FROM MY
FAMILY. HERE'S ANYTHING
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. IT WAS
IN MY EXPERIENCE. THAT THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS WHO ADDED
SHE A DEGREE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. THAT WOULD TREAT ME
AND I WAS INCARCERATEDAROUND
ME WITH HUMAN DECENCY. WHICH
ULTIMATELY PROVIDED ME THE HOPE
AND COURAGE TO WORK THROUGH MY
TRAUMAS. I ALSO FOUND THOSE
WITH NO HIGHER EDUCATION WOULD
DEMEAN AND BELITTLE US WITH NO
REGARD FOR REHABILITATION OR
SUPPORT. THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS
IN POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY BUT
ALSO IN A UNIQUE POSITION TO
HELP THOSE TO THE
REHABILITATIVE PROCESS. WE NEED
PEOPLE IN THOSE POSITIONS TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT HURT PEOPLE
HURT PEOPLE. AND WE NEED PEOPLE
CAN REACT. WELCOME FROM A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT. IT IS FOR
THE REASONS THAT WE ARE SUPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND- JUST
AS THEY ARE AWARE OF
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THOSE AT HOME
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
DISPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN OH
NINE WHICH IS A SO REMEMBER
LEASE BILL AND THE MEASURE HAS
A CURRENT VOTE OF FOUR TO TWO
AND ITS ON CALL AND EACH ONE
ADDITIONAL VOTE. WITH THAT SAID
OPERATOR CAN WE- NOW LET AND
COLORS OF SUPPORT FOR A- AB.
EIGHTY NINE. IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE NINE OF SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CURRENTLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU. EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SIX FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYWAY WILL
PREPARE YOU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU RYAN SIX THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGIA
MY HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE NINE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
EXONERATED NATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TECHNI CARRERA MERCED
CALIFORNIA I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHT FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT TO ALIVE AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LET'S SIX FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BYE NINE ONE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY NINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN
THEY WERE CHILDREN AND- THEN
I'M CALLING FROM CARSON
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ONE FIVE OR NINE. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE SEVEN ZERO NINE- HI.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN YEAH
I DON'T PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS LISA FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I'M MISSING THE CALL
ON FIFTEEN OH NINE YOU THINK IT
CAN. I WANT AND- EXPRESS.
CONCERN THAT A BILL ONE THIRTY
NINE THAT'S BEEN. THE JUDICATA.
WELL TRY LINE SEVEN NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I IS
CONNIE FROM CASE THE GLORY AND
I'M SORRY AGREE WITH EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN ALL NINE ALL. I NO
FURTHER THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF WE NOW NEED TO
LISTEN TO THE OPPOSITION-
MISTER JONATHON FELDMAN.
OPERATORS THE ONLINE. I DON'T
SEE HIM ON JONATHON FELDMAN IF
YOU ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE
PRESS STAR ZERO SO I CAN OPEN
YOUR LINE. I CURRENTLY DO NOT
SEE HIM DIALED IN. OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER UP COLLARS AND
SUPPORT. I'M SORRY IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB EIGHTY NINE.
HE WISHES SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I NINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I IN MY NINE THIRTEEN YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY I AM NOT
IN OPPOSITION I'M IN SUPPORT-
THIS IS NATASHA COMBUSTIBLE-
BUT DEFENDER AND ADVOCATE FOR-
POLICE OFFICERS TO BE EDUCATED
TO THAT WAY THERE'S LESS. USE
THAT OUR RELATIONSHIP WORK WE
GOT OUT OF IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL LINE
IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR THAT LINE NUMBER THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS NAMELY PETRON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH I MEAN I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN FORTY TWO
OH TWO THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR AGAINST. IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. AT BNL ANYBODY
ON COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THIS BILL. YES MISTER
COURT- TRY MISTER FELDMAN
DIDN'T SPEAK BECAUSE YOU ARE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
WHILE I DON'T LIKE THE CURRENT
BILL I WILL DEFINITELY GIVE YOU
AN AYE VOTE BECAUSE YOU ARE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
I EXPECT THE BILL COULD BE MUCH
BETTER WHEN IT GETS TO THE
FLOOR. I HAS BEEN MOVED YET.
YEAH IT'S BEEN MOVED GOOD THANK
YOU CHECK IN THIS COURT. THANK
YOU. MR CHARTER GO AHEAD SIR.
SO I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ILLS IN THE
IN POLICING. MY CONCERN IS THE
REALITY OF RECRUITMENT TODAY IS
THAT THE POLICING PROFESSION IS
BECOMING LESS AND LESS
DESIRABLE- WE DID PULL ONE
STATE AGENCY. AND RIGHT NOW
THEY THEY HAD LIKE THERE ARE
DOWN 50% IN IN THEIR
RECRUITMENT- AND THE APPLICANTS
THAT THEY GET. AND THAT 50% IS
LIKE TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
STILL. BUT OUT OF THAT TWELVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE ONCE THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS THERE'S
ONLY LIKE FIVE HUNDRED
APPLICANTS THAT THEY GET
THROUGH TO THE PART WHERE THEY
GO TO THE ACADEMY. AND THEN
THERE'S A DWINDLING DOWN FROM
THERE. AND SO GIVEN THOSE
LIMITED RESOURCES AND ALSO YOU
KNOW I THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW
YEAH I KNOW THE BRAIN SCIENCE
IS THAT THEY THEY'RE NOT MATURE
UNTIL THE TWENTY FIVE SPECIALLY
MALES- BUT- I ALSO YOU KNOW
LOOK AT PEOPLE LIKE- KIDS ARE
GOING TO THE MILITARY RIGHT OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND FOUR YEARS
LATER THEY GET OUT AND THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR CAREER. AND THOSE
CAREERS- THAT ARE OPEN TO THEM
A LOT OF THEM ARE ATTRACTED TO
THE POLICING AND BEING ABLE TO
HELP THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR I KNOW IN OUR FIRE
DEPARTMENT OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND- IN THE AREA WE
HAVE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF VERY
YOUNG OFFICERS AND THEY'RE
AWESOME AND THEY'RE BEING
TAUGHT THE RIGHT WAY- I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE ANSWER TO
FIXING THAT PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
HAVING OUT THERE AND. SOME OF
THESE LARGER AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY. AND I'M NOT
CONFIDENT THAT THIS IS GOING TO
SOLVE IT. AND I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
LEAVING A BUNCH OF PEOPLE OUT
OF A CAREER A POTENTIAL CAREER
FOR THEM BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WILL MAKE. A DECISION
WHERE THEY WANNA GO LONG BEFORE
THEY HIT TWENTY FIVE. YES SOME
OF THEM JUST DON'T WANT TO BE
AT MOM AND DAD'S HOUSE UNTIL
THEY'RE TWENTY SIX. AND AND SO
I CAN IMAGINE THAT THAT THEY'RE
GONNA GET STARTED SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND THAT JUST KIND OF
SHRINKS THAT POOL EVEN MORE- SO
I GUESS I JUST HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH THAT AND I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S THE APPROACH IS
GOING TO WORK- I'M SURE IT'LL
GO THROUGH HERE AND- AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'LL HAVE TO SEE.
BUT AND ALSO THE LAST THING. I
CAN THINK OF A LOT. OF NOT
MISTER PROFESSIONS. BUT
ENDEAVOR IS THAT PEOPLE ARE IN.
DEBT AND THEY COULD USE THAT
THAT HIGHER DEGREE. AND I CAN
THINK OF A LOT OF INSTANCES
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE REALLY REALLY
HIGHER DEGREES. AND STILL MAKE
BONE HEAD MOVES SO I DON'T
THINK IT EDUCATION IS THE IS
NECESSARY THE ANSWER TO- CAN
MAKING AT WHAT WORK WHAT'S WHAT
AILS OUR SOCIETY GO AWAY. I
THINK IT'S A COMPONENT OF IT
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE
INVOLVED IN IT SO. THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER SERRA
TO. WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF WEIGH IN
ON THIS THIS ISSUE AND I'LL TRY
TO BE JUST REALLY DIRECTING
SHORT. I THINK. AS A PERSON WHO
SPENT THE CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME MY LIFE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AND WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
LOOKING FOR. IS THE HEART OF A
PUBLIC SERVANT. THAT'S WHAT
MAKES A GOOD LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOT CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE- IN MY
OPINION LIFE EXPERIENCE HELPS
DEMONSTRATE WHETHER OR NOT YOU
HAVE THAT HEART. AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND AND I COMMEND YOU FOR.
TRYING TO APPROVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT'S GENERALLY WHERE YOUR
HEART IS. BUT I COULDN'T
DISAGREE MORE. WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PATH- I THINK
EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS ARE
HELPFUL I HAPPEN TO BE TWENTY
SIX AND WAS A COLLEGE GRADUATE
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT MADE ME.
THE PERSON IT WAS EFFECTIVE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT WAS THAT I TRULY DO HAVE A
SERVANT'S HEART AND A VERY VERY-
I FOUND IT AND THAT'S WHY
PROMOTED AS BECAUSE I WANTED TO
BE A FIELD SUPERVISOR. TO
ENSURE THOSE WHO ARE
ENCOUNTERING THE PUBLIC. DID
SO. IN THE WAY THAT OF THE
PUBLIC DEMANDS AND SO. I WON'T
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AT
THIS PARTICULAR JUNCTURE BUT
HOPEFULLY WE COME TO A PLACE.
THAT WE BOTH AGREE THAT WILL
IMPROVE. AND MAYBE HELP
IDENTIFY THAT SERVICE MARK IS
THAT I THINK THAT'S THE REAL
QUALIFIER. SO DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. OKAY I GUESS WE
HAVE A- I GUESS YOU GET A
CHANCE TO CLOSE MAN GLAD. AND I
APPRECIATE BOTH MISTER SAOTOME
MISTER LACKEY'S COMMENTS
BECAUSE I NEED YOUR COMMENTS TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER JUST JUST
SAY THAT- I WISH I COULD. I
HAVE A WHOLE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THAT RESEMBLE MR LACKEY- I
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE MORE AFRICAN
AMERICAN OR LATINO I JUST NEED
TO HAVE AND HAVE A GOOD HEART.
AND TO BE ABLE TO DO THE JOB
THAT'S WHERE I'M GETTING TO-
THAT'S WHY I TOOK OFFENSE WHEN
PEOPLE CAME TO ME TO SAY THAT
I'M GOING TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS- WE HAVE A
SAYING IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. THAT NOT ALL SKIN
FOLK ARE YOUR KINFOLK RECEIVING
THOSE SOMEBODY MAYBE AFRICAN
AMERICAN THEY MAY BE HORRIBLE
HORRIBLE POLICE OFFICERS. AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BEST PERSON NO MATTER WHAT THE
COLOR RED THIS AND SELL OUT
I'VE ALWAYS ADMIRED EVEN. I
KIND OF I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET THERE ARE WORK
REASON WORKING TO POLICE CHIEFS
MOSTLY BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
MANAGE THIS. YEAH AT THE END OF
THE DAY. THEY'RE GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SHORTAGES.
THEIR NUMBERS FIVE PHOTOGRAPHS
TAKE THE HEAT FOR- ABOUT POLICE
BEATINGS AND ALL THE- WRONG
THINGS THE BAD APPLES AS WELL
AS THEY GOT TO MAKE SURE THEY
CAN KEEP. THE GOOD APPLES IN IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND THEY RECRUIT
THE MEN THERE SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO AS MUCH TRAINING AND
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM. AND AND EVEN
LOOKING AT. ON GOING.
DEVELOPMENT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY THERE IN GIVING THEM-
THE SOME KIND OF EDUCATION-
LOOK WHEN YOU CAME IN. WHAT
DOES THE CHP IT'S GOT TO BE
TWENTY ONE. SO MAYBE EIGHTEEN
ISN'T THE NUMBER. MAYBE TWENTY
FIVE NOT THE NUMBER. BUT
BETWEEN THE C. H. P. AT TWENTY
ONE L. A. COUNTY SHERIFF IS
TWENTY ONE. AND PROBATION
OFFICERS. THE AGES TWENTY ONE
FOR A REASON. AND SO IT MAY NOT
BE TWENTY FIVE MAY NOT BE
EIGHTEEN IT MIGHT BE TWENTY
THREE BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF
NEGOTIATION THAT WAS TELLING MR
QUIRK WE'RE LOOKING AT- MAYBE
WE START EARLIER MAYBE PROVIDE
INCENTIVES. THAT IF YOU GO
THROUGH A- TWO YEAR PROGRAM.
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE MAY
WE GIVE INCENTIVES TO PAY FOR
YOU TO GO TO UC OR CAL STATE.
AND WE MAYBE GET RID THAT DAY
HOPEFULLY MISTER SEA OTTER THAT
DRIVES PEOPLE TO WANT THAT'S
LIKE A HUGE INCENTIVE. THAT
THEY COME IN WE SHOULD HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION AND FINALLY-
JUST LET YOU KNOW THAT THE-
**** STATISTICIAN OUR OUR OUR
OUR- EXPERT- SHE EVEN BROUGHT
UP THINGS THAT WE DID EVEN
THINK ABOUT. LIKE IT MAY BE
EXEMPTING. SMALLER POLICE
DEPARTMENTS FROM THIS. OP
BECAUSE- THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
PARK. HAS PROBABLY TWENTY FIVE
OR LESS DISMISSED THIS MAY BE A
BURDEN ON IT MAYBE WE NEED TO.
I TO GIVE SOME KIND OF
SUPPLEMENT ARE WE IT. MAKE SURE
THEY'RE NOT PART OF THIS
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO AFFORD WHAT I'M
PROPOSING. SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
WESTONE MISTER CORK WILL GET
EVERYTHING EVER TALKING
DIRECTLY TO. PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AND SAY WHAT DO YOU
THINK WORKS BEST. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR **** BOOK
I VOTE KNOWING THAT. I'M NOT
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS THE
RIGHT WAY. THANK YOU READY. THE
BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON EIGHTY EIGHTY NINE
BY THREE MEMBER JONES SAWYER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER IRAQI
NOT YET NOPE BLACKIE NOW
BARRICK HE HAND BACKHAND ON A
QUIRK. WORK I SANTIAGO. DID HE-
C. R. TERM NOW THERE TURNOUT
WICKS LI LI I THAT MEASURE SOME
QUALITY. WE ONE MORE. THAT I
CALL MY. RIGHT. WE'RE SANTIAGO
LAST YEAR'S OF BILLS THAT MAKE.
HE'S VERY ELUSIVE THAT MAN.
AND
ACTIVISTS. MR QUIRK WILL WILL
BEGIN SANTIAGO NUMBER NINETEEN
SANTIAGO A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN- AND THIS OBVIOUSLY IF MR
HE WILL. INITIATIVE STAB
STATUTES BY PROHIBITING THE
PRIOR JUVENILE JUVENILE
EDUCATION FROM BEING CONSIDERED
A PRIOR SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
FELONY CONVICTIONS FOR PURPOSES
OF SENTENCING CAMP ENHANCEMENTS
IN OTHER WORDS. YOU DON'T ALLOW
SOMEONE WHO IS A JUVENILE. AND
FOR THAT STRIKE TO COUNT
TOWARDS THREE STRIKES BILL
WOULD JOB PROVIDING MEANS OF
VACATING THE PRIOR JUVENILE
CONVICTION ENHANCEMENT. AND
RESENTENCING A DEFENDANT ON ANY
REMAINING COUNTS WHEN SPECIFIED
CONDITIONS APPLY. LOOTING WITH
THE ALLEGED PRIOR CONVICTION
OCCURRED WHEN THE DEFENDANT WAS
JUVENILE THE CASE WAS EDUCATED
IN JUVENILE COURT. I
REQUIREMENTS ARE DISSIPATION OF
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND PUBLIC
DEFENDERS IN THE RESENTENCING
PROCESS- WELL IT DOES THAT. AND
THE- I YOU KNOW THIS IS BEEN A
RECORD RECORD NIGHT SIX HOURS.
I'VE I'VE SAID ENOUGH. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ALLOW JUVENILES
WHO HAVE A STRIKE TO HAVE IT
COUNT TOWARDS THREE STRIKES
THAT'S THE NATURE OF THE SALE.
THIS MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES.
I'M SURE THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY RIGHT NOW YES THEY CAN
SAY MORE THAN I WOULD- TOM
STATEMENT NO DAN PHILOSOPHICAL
LA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE-
IT SAYS M. MIGUEL A. GARCIA AND
TO RECIDIVISM COALITION. IDEA
SAID VIDEO TESTIMONY. YEAH
LET'S GO FOUR WEEKS WE HAVEN'T
USED THIS THING. DAN MIGUEL
JUST PUSH START TALKING DISS
EXCITING STUFF. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DAN FILLS OUT ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. HOW
TO SPONSOR AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME AND WHAT HAPPENED HERE-
GO AHEAD. AS MR COURT EXPLAINED
AB ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
PROHIBIT THE USE OF JUVENILE-
STRIKE EDUCATIONS TO ENHANCE A
SUBSEQUENT ADULT FELONY THE
MAIN REASON FOR THIS IS THE
FACT THAT JUVENILES IN THE
JUVENILE COURT DID NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO A JURY TRIAL JURY
TRIALS ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TWO USE
EIGHT JUVENILE ADJUDICATION TO
ENHANCE OF THE DAHLE FELONY IS
BOTH BAD. LAW AND BAD POLICY
THE PURPOSE OF JUVENILE COURT
IS REHABILITATION. AND IT'S IN
NO OTHER AREA OF LAW CAN A NON
CRIMINAL. PROCEEDING BE USED TO
ENHANCE IT CRIMINAL SENTENCE
JUVENILE PROCEEDINGS ARE NOT
COP CONSIDERED CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS IN JUVENILE
PROCEEDING UP UNDER THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE IS NOT A
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING AND IS NOT
TO BE DEEMED A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING AND AGENT ALL A JUDY
CATION ISN'T NOT DEEMED TO BE
AT A CRIMINAL CONVICTION YET
UNDER OUR THREE STRIKES ALL
THAT JUVENILE ADJUDICATION CAN
BE USED TO ENHANCE. A
SUBSEQUENT ADULT FELONY. THIS
HAS BAD- IMPACTS ON OBVIOUSLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN YOUTH ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO FACE A JUVENILE
STRIKE THE G. EDUCATION THAN
OTHER RACES THIS IN TURN LEADS
TO. A LONGER INCARCERATION
CARED FOR A SUBSEQUENT ADULT
CONVICTION THAT MEDICAL SCIENCE
SHOWS THE JUVENILE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT IS NOT THE SAME AS
ADULTS JUVENILES MAKE RECKLESS.
DECISIONS BASED ON THEIR
IMMATURITY AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN RECOGNIZES THIS AND WOULD
SOLVED EIGHTY- A DISPARITY IN
THE LAW IT WOULD HAVE
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION ON
REFORMING JUVENILE JUSTICE
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER PHILLIPS OUT OF THIS
YEAR UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
ESKOM FLIGHT BY PRECIADO. THE
NEW YORK. GOOD EVENING AUDIBLE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN MY NAME IS
MIGUEL GARCIA AND THE ADVOCACY
COORDINATOR WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AS A TEEN
I WAS CHARGED WITH PREMEDITATED
MURDER AND WAS SENTENCED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE. JUSTICE
AND I RECEIVED A JUVENILE
STRIKE. UPON MY. UPON MY
ARRIVAL AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE I RECEIVED AND
USE ALL THE SERVICES AVAILABLE
TO ME TO REHABILITATE MYSELF ON
MY DESTROYED FROM DJJ I HAVE
EARNED THREE ASSOCIATE DEGREES
AND ONE BACHELOR DEGREE FROM UC
RIVERSIDE I SAID ON NUMEROUS
YOUTH JUSTICE EXECUTIVE BOARDS
AND I DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME STAY
OUT OF THE- JUSTICE SYSTEM. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
RECEIVED AN HONORABLE DISCHARGE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND THAT SAME YEAR THE
COURT ORDER MY CASE DISMISSED.
AND STILL HOWEVER I NOW CARRY
THAT SAME JUVENILE STRIKE. LONG
AFTER MY COOK MY OBLIGATIONS TO
THE STATE AND MY COMMUNITY. AND
IF I WERE TO COMMIT ANOTHER
HARM I WOULD LIKELY RECEIVE AN
ENHANCED SENTENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR MANY GET THE
COLOR GOOGLE HOME FROM DJJ AND
YEARS LATER COMMITTED. A HARM
THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVED AN ENHANCED SENTENCE
WITH LITTLE TO NO HOPE OF
REHABILITATION. THE REALITY IS
JUVENILE STRIKES ARE OVER
PUNITIVE. THAT IS WHY WE NEED
TO ELIMINATE JUVENILE STRIKES
YOU CREATE IT MORE. JUSTICE
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOCUSED ON%
REHABILITATION AND NOT
INCARCERATIONS. THAT IS WHY I
SUPPORT EIGHTY ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
WILL HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE CHAMBER FORTY
TWO OH TO SEE NONE AND- ANY
WITNESSES ON THE TELEVISION
SCREEN YOU GOT ANYBODY ELSE IN
THAT ROOM. NO WE DON'T OKAY AND
NOW EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR CAN
YOU GO TO THE PHONE LINES ON AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO.
Q. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ALIVE IN TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
ABOUT TEN IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE
SEVEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CAME WHEN
DEAN WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S
PAST THE MINSTER FOR SMART AT
THE CALIFORNIANS DRUNK THE PARK.
THANK YOU RYAN SIX THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX THREE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARED MEMBERS HAD
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MARCO GEORGE ON
THE HOUSE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NK
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING A. B. P. SHARE CAR WITH
CHILDREN OFFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE NIGHT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ARE NON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE NAME OF THE DROUGHT THE
NINE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING RON RAY
US ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER IS A
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THIRTY FIVE OTHER
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
ORGANIZATION ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TILL ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I NINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'RE NOT SURE HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT FIVE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
GREGORY FOR THAT WITH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
NINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE STEPHANIE CARRERA
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE NOW
BRING IT. TO THE COMMITTEE. NOW
ALL OPPOSITION WHERE IS MY
APPLICATION LETTER. I DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY LISTED HERE ARE ON
THE CALL SHEET FOR WITNESSES SO
GO TO YOUR HEARING ROOM SCENE
NINE GO TO THE-
TELECONFERENCING. AND AGAIN
COULD YOU OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO.
IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- OF EIGHTEEN ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU COOPER NOW
BRING AN END TO THE COMMITTEE
SO THAT MR SANTIAGO FINANCE
ANSWER. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE FOR HIM
RIGHT NOW. BUYS THE BRIEF SO
I'LL ANSWER BRIEF. SO ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. COMMENTS THIS
YOU KNOW I UNIPOL IDEAS. SO
SAID THE OUT OF IT. IT WAS GOOD
TO HEAR FROM THE YOUNG YES THE
YOUNG MAN WHO TESTIFIED. AND I
HAVE NO DOUBT THAT HE HAS TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM THERE YOU HAVE MILITATED
HIMSELF. AND I DON'T THINK HE'S
GOING TO COMMIT ANOTHER CRIME.
BECAUSE HE KNOWS HE'S GOT JUST
TWO MORE. BUT I DON'T THINK
HE'S GOING TO BECAUSE HE DID
WHAT HE NEEDED TO DO TO CORRECT
WHATEVER WAS WRONG IN HIS LIFE
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS. DOES
THIS EIGHT HI I'M NOT SURE THAT.
THERE'S A CORRELATION FROM
WEAKENING THE THREE STRIKES LAW
BECAUSE THEY'RE A JUVENILE TO
SOMEHOW- KEEP PEOPLE WHO ARE
RITUAL WHO REHABILITATE
THEMSELVES FROM STAYING OUT OF
PRISON. WHAT DID YOU DO YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING IT'S
LIKE IF THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT WHEN
THEY GET OUT AND IF THERE ARE
TWENTY THREE OR TWENTY EIGHT.
AND THEY DECIDE TO DO AN ARMED
ROBBERY. WELL I WE WILL CONNECT
ONE OF THE THREE OF THEM BEFORE
WE TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
THAT BOY THIS IS YOU KNOW. THIS
IS SOMETHING THEY'VE DONE
BEFORE AND THEY'RE CONTINUING
TO DO IT. I'D HATE TO BE THAT
THE THIRD FELONY IF THEY GET
THE DING DONG PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO COMMIT CRIMES ARE DONE DOING
THAT THE ONLY PEOPLE SHOULD BE
AFRAID OF- THE THREE STRIKES
LAW OR THE RUNNING THE RED
LIGHT CAMERA LAW OR ANY OF
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO RUN THE RED LIGHT OR
GOING TO COMMIT MORE FELONIES.
AND I DON'T THINK TAKING AWAY
THAT IS GOING TO- MAKE IT
BETTER I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO. I REHABILITATE THEM-
THEY'VE ALREADY PROVEN THAT
THEY PROBABLY CAN'T BE. WHAT
WHAT LOXO. ANYWAY THAT'S JUST
NOT JUST JUST COMMON I HAVE ON.
THE CARD FOR ME TO SUPPORT
BILLS LIKE THAT THANKS. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER
CORK- HASN'T HAS BEEN MOVED HAS
NOT BEEN MOVEMENT TO CRY WILL
MOVE IT THAT IT'S EASY FOR ME
TO SUPPORT BILLS LIKE THIS TO
SAY. IT'S GETTING LATE. THIS
THANK YOU ARE ANY MORE COMMENTS-
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER SURE
KNOWING THAT IT'S GETTING LAID
OFF KEEP- BRIEF AND THANK- MY
COLLEAGUES- FOR PRESENTING AND
THANK- DA GAS CONE HAS SPONSOR
AND OTHERS- FOR A CHAMPION AND
A BILL LIKE THIS BECAUSE IT
REALLY DOESN'T MAKE SENSE- THE
JUVENILE- TRIED BETWEEN FOR
JUDICATA BETWEEN SIXTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN- WHAT HAVE THAT SAME
ACT COUNT AS A THIRD STRIKE BUT
IF THEY DID THREE OF THOSE AT
AT BETWEEN SIXTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
IT WOULDN'T COUNT. AND THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM AS WE KNOW
SUPPOSED TO BE REHABILITATED-
BY NATURE- IN THAT IN THAT
WE'RE NOT COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES HERE BECAUSE WHEN AN
ADULT AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
AGE- IS TRYING TO COURT- THE
TRIBECA JURY OF THEIR PEERS AND
THAT'S NOT THE SAME- SORT OF
SCENARIO THAT YOU WOULD SEE
OFFER JUVENILE WITH ARE NOT
TRIED NUMBER ONE- THEY'RE
THEY'RE JUDICATA IT. EITHER NOT
CONVICTED- IT'S A WHOLE SET OF
DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND
CERTAINLY WE CAN GO THROUGH ALL
THE MERITS OF WHY Y.
IDEOLOGICALLY- I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
BUT BUT JUST ON THE MERITS OF
PURE FACT AND PROCESSES IT JUST
ABSOLUTELY MAKES NO SENSE- THAT
YOU WOULD. USE I KNOW JUDICATA
ED AN ACTION THAT WAS
ADJUDICATED IN YOUR USE AS A
CONVICTION WHEN YOU WERE TRIED
BY A JURY OF YOUR PEERS- AS AN
ADULT- IN AND WE DO THIS KIND
OF WORK BECAUSE IT'S HARD IN
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE OUR SOULS
AND IT'S THE RIGHT THING. TO DO
NOT THE CAN CAN YOU TO. MASS SO
HAVING SAID- TO BRIEF I CAN SAY-
SOME THAT CAN SAY ON SOMETHING
THAT I FEEL VERY. ABOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR ADULT.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR OF COKE FOR
PRESENTING. IT AND- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS TO US- AND
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US LEARN
ABOUT THE NEW DAN FILLERS ANO
THE NEW LOS ANGELES COUNTY DA.
AND IT IS LAW SAYS IT COUNTY
DA'S OFFICE. I'M GOING TO THIS
I DON'T LIKE IT HERE. I THOUGHT
IT WAS GOOD. SO WITH THAT THE
CHAIR ENTHUSIASTICALLY COMMENCE
AND I BOTH. CALDERON THE BILL'S
IMPROPERLY MOVED AND SECONDED
AB ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI CONSIDER IRAQI.
BLACKIE NOW BARAKAT BARAKAT HAD
I WORK I WORK AT A SAN DIEGO
SAN DIEGO BANK SAY OUR TOWN NO
THE R. TO KNOW WICKS. WICKS HI
LI LI I. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NOT CONNECTS WE WILL DO ANY ADD
ONS FOR BOTH CHANGES INCLUDING
THE MEASURES THAT ARE ON CALL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE GO
THROUGH ALL THE MEASURES TAKEN
UP TODAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BACK OR CAN BARRICADE
HAD ICE SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO HI
WICKS WICKS I DON'T NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY FOUR BY THE
MEMBER BARRICADE HANNAH JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI WICKS
WICKS HI THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
DON'T NEVER TOO AB NINE THREE
NINE BY MISTER CONTEST JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI WICKS
WICKS I LEVY. AB NINE THREE
NINE BERMAN CERVANTES. LEE I. I
REMEMBER THREE THIS MEASURE
WHAT SOME CALL AB TWENTY EIGHT
BY THE MEMBER CHILD SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO HI WICKS WICKS HI LEE.
THIS IS THE HATE CRIMES MEASURE
BY MID DECEMBER CHILD. HI LEE
BY THAT MEASURE PASSES. I AM
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE BY SEVEN MEMBER CHU
SANTIAGO. I AM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER CHIU SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I. I DON'T NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX WAS ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE
BY FAMILY MEMBER CHU THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
ISOMER COOLEY THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL BARRICADE CAN BARRICADE
HAD ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
WICKS. WICKS I LEE. LEE HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES I DON'T NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
HUNDRED BY SOME MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WICKS WICKS HI LI LI I THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY NINE FIVE EIGHT BY
SEPTEMBER GIPSON BARRICADE CAN.
BACK HE HAD ICE SANTIAGO. SAN
DIEGO HI WICKS WICKS HI THAT
MEASURE PASSAGE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTY ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
BY SEPTEMBER GIPSON THIS
MEASURE WITH ON CALL SANTIAGO.
THAT VEHICLE I LEX WICKS HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE OH SIX BY
SIMILAR MEMBER GONZALEZ BAUER
CAN BARRICADE HAD ICE SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I WICKS WEEKS BY THE
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHTY NINE. BY
SEMI MEMBER JONES SAWYER THIS
MEASURE WITH ON CALL SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI WICKS. WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN WAS ON CONSENT AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
OH NINE BY SOME MEMBERS LEAD
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO I WICKS
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
REMEMBER SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SIX WAS ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY BY SOMEONE OR
THROW THE BIGGEST SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
BY SOME A MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I REMEMBER
NINETEEN WAS JUST DISPENSED
WITH THAT MEASURE PASSED ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTY NINE
THIRTEEN WITHOUT CONSENT. I
REMEMBER TWENTY ONE AB THIRTEEN
NO WAY BY SOME MEMBER TEAM THIS
MEASURE WITH ON CALL LACKEY
LACKEY NO BARRICADE CAN BACKING
HAD ICE SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO HI
WICKS WICKS HI THIS MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO BY
THE MEMBER TEAM WITHOUT CONSENT.
I DON'T NUMBER FIFTEEN SEASON I
DON'T EVER TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY BY THE MEMBER
TEAM THAT MEASURE WITH ON CALL
BARRICADE HAN. BARRICADE HAD
ICE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I WICKS
WICKS HI LI. LI I THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THANK YOU N. I HAVE.
OUR THIS CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
OF FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.